>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> So, welcome to the
Audio Media Preservation
through Imaging Conference.
This is the first meeting of
this particular group of people.
This is a very new technology.
We're really excited that all
of you have been able to come.
And we hope that we continue this
dialogue even past this conference,
so we have some opening
remarks from Mark Sweeney.
And, are you ready to --
>> Yes.
>> Thank you, Peter, and
good morning to you all.
I'm Mark Sweeney, the associate
librarian for library services
and on behalf of the Librarian of
Congress, Dr. James Billington.
It's my pleasure to welcome
you today to the library
and to this three day
conference on Audio --
Audio Media Preservation
through Imaging Technology.
As Peter says, this is just -- just
an excellent opportunity for us
to share our knowledge
and experience and sort
of chart a path for the future.
And you're having wonderful weather
today here in Washington and --
and for those that had an
opportunity to go out to Culpeper,
I think something really
special yesterday.
So, audio recording has
existed for over 150 years.
The development from the
phonautograph to tin foil
to the myriad of today's, you know,
modern high fidelity
digital recordings.
You know, it's -- it's -- it's
all amazing and astounding.
And over a comparatively short
period of time, about 15 years,
many of those in attendance
here have developed, introduced,
refined the imaging
technology to capture audio
from physical audio carriers for the
purpose of preserving information
from these valuable artifacts.
The collaboration that has
surrounded the development
of these specialized imaging tools
has been open and a collegial one.
And there have been
substantial contributions
from the Lawrence Berkeley
National Laboratory, the University
of Applied Sciences in
Fribourg, Switzerland.
The University of Southampton
in England, the University
of California, Berkeley,
the Northeast Document
Conservation Center, First Sounds,
the National Museum
of American History,
the Thomas Edison National
Historical Site,
the Roja Muthiah Research
Library in Chennai, India,
University of Chicago and of
course, as well as the Library
of Congress that you're here today.
The research has received major
funding from a number of sources,
the Institute for Museum and Library
Services, The National Endowment
for the Humanities, the Library
of Congress, as well as support
from the University of California,
the Department of Energy,
the Smithsonian Institution, the
Schenectady Museum of Innovation
and Science, the National Archives
and Records Administration,
Harvard University.
The Council on Library
and Information Resources,
the Mellon Foundation,
Guggenheim Foundation,
the MacArthur Foundation.
So we have many supporters that
have been helping us along the way.
As is true with any
technological development,
there are successes
in and challenges.
Utilizing imaging technology
on audio media has already
given us access to recordings
that were broken into pieces,
in too fragile of a state
to be touched physically and in --
or early experimental
formats for which, you know,
we have no playback equipment.
So only a relatively short time ago,
these recordings were
considered lost to history,
but now they're accessible again.
But there are also issues
that have yet to be solved.
I would put high on the list,
maturation of this technology
to meet our specific needs at scale.
This gathering of collection holders
and instrument builders can
help define the priorities
for new tools to meet our needs.
By balancing the most pressing
needs of our collections
with the capabilities
of the technology today,
while also planning for the future,
those gathered here can help shape
the development and the roadmap
for these imaging media
systems of tomorrow.
There are so many sound
recordings in need of preservation.
Setting the proper priorities for
development is the first imperative.
We believe this technology
has diverse uses
as a noninvasive format
migration tool for media
in a wide range of
physical conditions.
It also serves as an
assessment and measurement tool
to set standards for media playback.
These are core requirements
for preservation.
A future roadmap will
allow others in the field
to consider how this technology fits
into their preservation
strategies and to plan accordingly.
As the technology gains capabilities
and preservation specialists
accumulate real world experience
with these tools, the
position of the acceptance
of the technology will
broaden -- should broaden.
By working cooperatively, this group
of mavericks has made
considerable progress
over the relatively short period
of time, ensuring the application
of new technology from a very
-- for a very specific purpose.
As future challenges are met
and solutions are proposed,
the collegial nature of
this group should see it
through the most difficult
future issues.
Since preservation serves not
only living scholars and patrons,
but also future generations, the
generosity of this group shows
that it's -- that it's
deep knowledge
to solve longstanding
problems inherent
with this valuable historical
record is recognized.
So I thank you for your dedication.
I'd like to conclude by
also thanking the members
of our conference organizing team.
That would be Peter [inaudible],
Gene DeAnna, Carl Haber,
Audria Henley, Steven
Legitt and Angela Newburn.
Thank you for your hard work,
please enjoy the conference
and I look forward to
sitting in and learning more.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning, everyone.
I'm Gene DeAnna.
I'm head of the recorded sound
section here at the library.
And I want to welcome all of you
that I didn't welcome yesterday
at the tour of the Packard Campus.
This is a great, exciting
meeting, it's wonderful
to see you all here today.
We had a really, I
think interesting tour.
We had great discussions
yesterday --
or beginning discussions
with lunch, in the hallways
between our stops at
the Packard Campus.
And before we get too far along,
I want to make sure to invite all
of you who weren't able to make
the trip, to please let us know
and we'll try to make
arrangements to get you
out there to see the facility.
I'm sure it'll be worth your while.
I want to second Mark's thanks,
particularly Audria Henley
and my colleague, Steve Legitt who
I'm not sure has made it today.
But Steve is the coordinator
of our National Film Board
and our National Recording
Preservation Board,
there are several board
members here today.
The support of the
library and Congress
of these boards has allowed
them to support national efforts
at preserving film
and sound, you know,
it helps to make events
like this possible.
As an archivist who's been in
the field for over 25 years now,
seeing this gathering
of scientific, technical
and archival expertise
focused on an exciting
and still emerging technology
for capturing sound is
extremely gratifying.
In December of 2012, the library
and the National Recording
Preservation Board,
with the assistance of
the Council on Library
and Information Resources,
published a national plan
for the preservation
of our recorded legacy.
That plan distilled over -- over 100
preliminary recommendations gathered
from an extensive study, multiyear
study and the recommendations
of an eminent group of expert task
forces, distilled them down to
about 32 major recommendations.
And since its publication,
that plan has been anything
but just another report, good ideas
that sits on a shelf somewhere.
It's -- it's been a vital document;
it has influenced the direction
of the work and provided a
national framework for the --
the focus of audio preservationists
and the institutions
and organizations that support
their work all across this country
and actually internationally
as well.
So today, we gather here under
the auspices of recommendation 1.7
of the National Recording
Preservation Plan,
which says to encourage scientific
and tactical research leading
to the development of new
technologies to recover, reformat
and preserve audio recording media.
The development of
imaging technology
for audio is a terrific story
when you tell people about it,
when they read about it they
respond to it like it's magic.
It's -- there is an element
of magic to it, I think.
And -- and from a more
technical standpoint, it's --
it's just really cool [laughter].
There remains a lot of work to
be done discussing, defining,
guiding that work, defining the
framework of how to guide that work.
It's going to be one of the
important goals of this conference.
Now for me as an archive
manager of a two large archive
of recorded sound, I see three clear
significant benefits and pathways
to development to audio preservation
that imaging technology offers.
And that does not include
the coolness factor.
The first is obviously
the safe recovery of audio
from fragile damaged
or broken carriers,
sound that otherwise
might not be recovered.
So playback of the unplayable or
probably should not be played.
And that also includes the
safe playback of unclean,
unprepped recordings to enable
us to identify them for purposes
of assessment and prioritization.
You'd be amazed at the --
the resources that have to go
into the conservation prep work
to get recordings that just -- you
just want to hear what they are.
To get them ready to put a stylus on
them, that's a commitment of a lot
of resources and if you
can imagine, those --
those materials that
demand that kind
of work often get just shunted
aside for practical purposes.
Secondly, it's a non-time base
method for making transfers
of groove media and it can
be carried out in parallel
and a non-monitored workflow.
So I decided to do a little third
grade math because occasionally I
like to push beyond my
comfort zone and I calculated
that [inaudible] holds
about, say a million hours --
a million hours of unique audio,
that is no dupes, one
of a kind audios.
So clearly if you think about a
million hours of preservation to do
in standard time based capture,
we need to develop other ways
of doing this that overcome
playback time in the limitations
of standard reformatting.
And thirdly, the -- this is a little
harder for us, this is new for me
to -- to get my head
around this, but it's --
it's the transformational
ability that 3D imaging provides
for digitally preserving
the carriers themselves,
that is the grooves.
To image those grooves, capture
that image for future generations.
Audio archivists operate justifiably
so under the understanding that all
of this media is going to degrade
or eventually become unplayable
for one reason or another,
obsolescence, over time.
But imaging is adding
that new paradigm.
The goal of capturing and
preserving the groove structure
of historical recordings,
historically important recordings,
the earliest recordings
of humanity is --
is really now a realistic
consideration for archivists.
And I guess we have to ask
ourselves, what's that worth?
And what's that going to be
worth down the line in a couple
of hundred years for people?
So there's -- there's still a lot
of work to do, but one thing I want
to point out, yesterday at the tour,
the group saw what I think is one
of the great success
stories of AV preservation.
Up on the third floor
in the video lab,
there's an array of
five SAMA robots.
They work in parallel.
Their hoppers full of u-matic,
VHS and beta cartridge tapes,
these are video formats
that carry the vast majority
of recorded television worldwide.
So, 20 some decks digitizing
in parallel in a workflow
that generates now 25
terabytes of content a week.
Ladies and gentleman, I can
tell you that 10 years ago,
television preservation was
nonexistent, virtually nonexistent.
This content was more at
risk than our nitrate,
more at risk than our audio tape,
our lacquer discs and
our wax cylinders.
Now my colleagues in
the moving image section
and one yesterday while we
-- he talked to the group,
mentioned the word finishing and
that's the word that doesn't come
up too often in the
recorded sound section.
Finishing preserving television
and you think, well, what happened?
Well, obviously the Packard
Humanities Institute and the Library
of Congress with congressional
support happened.
But really what happened to make
that a reality was good science,
engineering brilliance
and a clear understanding
of the archival principles
and practices of preservation.
So scientists, engineers
and archivists,
it's exactly the mix we
see in this room today.
So I -- I looked forward to this
conference, I think it's very,
very important, essential
that we continue
down the development of imaging.
And I want to welcome you and I
look forward to the discussions.
So now I want to introduce my
colleague, Peter [inaudible],
who leads the IRENE Project
here at the Library of Congress.
Peter?
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning.
I don't have a lot to say, but I
wanted to give a little perspective
that I think may not be the
common way we think about this.
There are obviously a lot of issues
involved in this preservation ,
there's degradation in materials
and there's the time factor
of getting all these
things preserved.
But this imaging technology
actually does an interesting thing.
When I -- when I came to
the Library of Congress
as a preservation specialist,
preserving audio recordings,
we went to analog tape,
we preserved things and --
and actually that's
incorrect to say.
We did not actually
technically preserve things.
At that time, preserving something
was making sure the original carrier
was in good condition.
It was very much from
the book world.
But what I did was --
was reformat materials
and it wasn't considered
part of preservation.
Not so long ago, people realized as
these materials are degrading and --
and going away and equipment
to transfer them was becoming
less accessible, that the process
of reformatting was
actually part of preservation
because you might lose
the original item.
However, that did for the particular
items we're talking about today,
that actually does a transformation.
These items are physical items.
And when you do a transfer, you
actually convert this physical thing
into an audio stream and then
you recapture that audio stream.
So the thing that's so
fascinating about the idea
of imaging is we're back to the idea
of actually preserving
the original item again.
And it gave us a whole host of --
of possible uses in the future
for these kinds of things.
I thought I'd mention
a couple technologies
that have been developed
over a period of time,
which aren't actually
in the physical realm,
but kind of highlight this.
There's a -- there's
a technology called
from plangents [phonetic]
processes, which uses bios tones,
which are high frequency
signals on audio tapes,
which aren't for listening back, but
for use for alignment of the tape.
To actually re-speed the
tape, you can actually lock
on to these signals and then --
and then actually get a better
speed for the tape playback.
That's an idea where -- where you're
using something that's not normally
preserved on a tape
for a purpose of --
of actually preserving
the thing better.
There's also work at the --
the University of Maryland
where they're actually
marrying [phonetic] records
of the power grid cycles to
signals on audio recordings
because there's date stamps on the
actual fluctuation and power grids.
And you can actually then match
these up with audio recordings
and figure out exactly when
something was recorded.
So, those may seem very
esoteric and people
who have collection
problems may think, you know,
I just have trouble
getting through this stuff.
Why -- that's so out in
the, you know, weeds,
why would we ever think about that?
But I think if you look at --
at what's happening when you
start collecting large --
collecting large data sets, which
essentially what's happening
when we make digitized
files of these things.
The kinds of research,
the kinds of relationships
between these data sets that can
happen in the future are things
that we don't really
envision right now.
I mean, once -- once audio
completely gets into that realm and,
as Gene said, finish is not a term
we necessarily talk about a lot,
but as we get larger and
larger data sets of -- of --
of audio, some of the
things people will use them
for will be nonaudio reasons.
They will be data sets that
will be referenced and -- and --
and cross related to
other data sets.
And it's hard for us to imagine
that, but that's what's --
that's to me what's
really interesting about --
about imaging, is that there's a
lot of things you lose once you,
in terms of a record or a
cylinder, put a stylus in that thing
and only get the audio signal back.
There's a lot of conditional
information, there's --
there's just the -- the -- the
surface of these images have --
have all sorts of information in
them that we may not be envisioning
as valuable right now, but
are part of that record.
And that's -- and that's
interesting because, you know,
originally when people
talk about preservation,
they wanted the original to live.
And -- and that's kind
of the same thing again.
So it's funny that we're
kind of going full circle,
what this technology
is allowing us to do,
what we originally
would've wanted to do.
Now that doesn't say that
this is the perfect solution,
it's going to cover all, you know,
it just wipes away everything else.
That's not, you know,
the case at this point
and it may never be the case.
But it -- it's something I
think we need to keep in mind
as we hear what people are doing,
these projects that people are --
are envisioning now, how saving the
image actually is a change, it's --
I really is a change
in preservation.
It's a fundamental change.
So I'm really looking
forward to this.
I'm, you know, I've been
working on this for what,
about 12 years now with Carl.
So, I'm extremely happy
all you are here.
And I would like to invite Carl up,
I guess we're a little bit ahead
of schedule, but that's
not bad, is it?
So -- so, Carl?
[ Applause ]
>> Carl Haber: Good morning.
Hi. So -- excuse me, I'm Carl Haber.
I work at the Physics Division,
Lawrence Berkeley National
Laboratory,
which is part of the
University of California.
So this is an introductory
kind of overview talk.
I will try to address general
issues of modern noninvasive
and data centered methods
of recorded sound preservation
and access.
I'm -- I share with Peter, the
thrill to attend this meeting
with so many people who have worked
on and thought so deeply and worked
on these and related subjects.
Excuse me.
I would like to acknowledge our
host, the Library of Congress
and the agencies which
have been so key
in supporting this
work internationally.
So, I'm going to talk a
little bit about the technical
and historical context
of sound recordings
and imaging based methods.
And then I'll try to
define a little bit
because I know there's a
whole variety of people here
with different experiences.
What we mean by these methods.
I'll try to address the question,
you know, why should -- why --
why do we bother doing this at all?
And then what -- what does the field
from my perspective
need to move forward?
So here's a zoology of --
of early sound carriers.
You see a lot of different
pictures of disparate objects.
They're all forms of --
of sound carriers that --
that encode sound in a whole
variety of different ways.
So, you -- you should
be struck with the --
with the diversity and the lack of
similarity among these things and --
and that's what we face
when we look particularly
at the -- at this early period.
A lot of different materials, a lot
of different formats, shapes, sizes,
structures, modes of
recording sounds.
So, the challenges, how do
we deal with all of this?
So, there is of course as I said,
this -- this great diversity,
but in the service of
simplification, I want to focus
in on two general formats
that encompass much
of what is represented
in this diversity
and it will help motivate our
understanding of the approaches
to -- to digitizing these materials.
So, on the top, I'm
referring to this --
the famous wax cylinder of Alexander
Graham Bell and Thomas Edison and --
and others in the -- in the
early period of sound recording.
So this is a cylindrical object with
a groove that essentially makes a --
a helical pattern around the
surface and that grooving code sound
in a vertical modulation
of the surface, so the --
the bottom of that
groove goes up and down.
And if you put a needle on it,
that needle is following
the up and down motion.
So there's obviously a cylinder --
a couple of cylinders and this
picture is a blown up region
of a tiny, tiny portion
of one of those cylinders.
And so, the -- the groove is --
is here between these two ridges
and time is in this direction,
so you can imagine a
stylus riding up and down.
This is a picture --
looks like a photograph,
but you should actually think of
it as a -- as a map of heights,
so if it's dark, it's deep
and if it's light, it's high.
And so, as you go along the time
direction, you're going deep
and high, and deep and
high, and so forth.
And if you follow this,
it -- it's a -- it's a --
basically a -- a up
and down pattern.
And the -- the extent of this
motion is just about 10 microns,
so that's not going to be a
familiar unit to everybody.
So, think of a human hair.
According to Wikipedia, the average
human hair is 50 microns, okay.
So, this is a fraction of a human
hair, but in that tiny amount
of space, the audio which has --
which has been recorded on
the thing is -- is encoded.
If we look across -- now
you're going around and around,
you see that it's a -- it's a kind
of a circular shaped structure
and the bottom of it is --
essentially the entire
structure is moving up and down.
So we refer to this as a
vertical recording and typically,
cylinders are made that way,
but there are vertically
recorded disc formats as well.
Over here is the more familiar
disc, the -- the phonograph record,
if you like, it was the common --
common term that maybe we used
when some of us were kids.
There instead, you have a
groove of -- of fixed depth.
For example, it might be
around 75 microns and it's sort
of like a 45 degree triangle.
And the sound now is encoded in a
side-to-side movement of the group.
And so, here's the -- the needle,
and you can see in this picture,
the groove undulating
from side-to-side.
And we refer to this as a
lateral or side-to-side recording.
And there are many
variations on all of this,
but most recordings
can be classified
as vertical or -- or lateral.
Again, the -- the -- the size of
the movement from side-to-side is
as small as less than a
micron and as big as many,
many tens to hundred
something microns.
Okay. So, what about
these -- what are these --
what are these noninvasive
and optical approaches
to playing recordings back?
So, you really start off when you
think about using light instead
of a needle to get information
off of a recorded sound carrier.
Back around 1960, people
were already talking
about using the reflected pattern
of light bouncing off test records,
records which just contained
a set of fixed frequencies,
as a way to do quality assurance
and -- and test the -- these things.
In -- in the mid-1960's,
people started using the
scanning electron microscopes
to study the structure of
grooves on records again,
as part of -- of engineering.
In the 1970's, interferometry,
the interferons of light
as it is reflected from the surfaces
was used to study CD-4 discs.
And then in 1977, people really
started to work with the idea
of using light to really
play records back,
not just to study them.
And in 1977, Heine patents
a laser disc players, okay.
In the 1980's, a company
called Finial tried
to take this system
commercial and failed.
It was then taken over by a
company called ELPJ in Japan
and they turned it into a
marketable product in the 1990's.
And you can buy these things
now, this is the laser turntable.
In the late 1990's and early
2000's, a variety of --
of essentially research labs
and universities and places
of that sort, tried to use a
variety of laser reflection methods,
particularly to try
and read cylinders.
They're sort of small projects.
Syracuse University and Lausanne
in the Soviet Union and in Japan,
so the -- the names of the --
of the principle players are --
are listed here and there
are probably some others
that I -- I neglected.
But fundamentally, all the
methods that I just referred
to replaced the stylus with light.
So you're essentially -- you're --
you're still playing these things
in this -- in the way -- in
this kind of continuous way.
Light is bouncing off of surface
and being picked up like a --
instead of a stylus, okay.
But the approaches that
are really the focus
of this meeting are what I would
call metrological approaches, okay.
Instead of -- of -- of replacing
the stylus with a beam of light,
the idea is to treat the
entire surface as a very,
very high resolution, digital
data set, a big digital data set
that you can analyze offline to
extract the recorded sound in --
in terms of a mathematical
algorithm.
So, we're not making a player
anymore, we're making a way
of migrating a physical
object into the digital domain
and then applying large-scale
data analysis tools to --
to extract the information from it.
And I -- I think the originating
idea and sense of the --
of the literature as far
as I could find is --
is in a paper by Stanke and Paul,
which was called 3D Measurement
and Modeling in Cultural
Applications ,
which was published in 1995.
And they point out that a whole
variety of materials, statues,
ceramics and all sorts of things
could be digitally rendered
with 3D scanning methods.
And that would add value for
scholarship and museum work
and archiving and so forth, to have
these objects in the digital domain.
And I know they were interested
in sound recordings as well
as statuary materials and so forth.
In 2001, Cavaglieri,
Babst and Johnsen
in Switzerland developed
a 2D photographic method
of transferring disc records
into the digital domain,
which is called the visual
audio and you're going to hear
from Stefano here today
about visual audio.
And in 2003, a two dimensional
and three dimensional direct
surface metrology approach
to digitizing these materials
started to be worked on by our group
in Berkeley and colleagues at
the University of Southampton
in the U.K. In the U.S.
we refer to this as IRENE,
you probably heard the term
in the tours and so forth.
So, that's -- that's kind of
where that -- that originates.
So, what's the basic process?
I -- I want to transcend
the specific on limitation,
so I picked a picture that nobody
will confuse as a sound recording.
But the point here is -- is you
see the David and this rig is --
is some kind of a digital scanner
that you can see this little patch
of light on -- on his nose.
It's actually digitizing.
There is a digital David
that exists through this work
and it's a tremendously
interesting project.
So, think about a generic
scanner and a generic object
of cultural value and
then replace it
with a phonograph record,
disc, or a cylinder.
And through some scanning
methodology and you will hear
about different ones, we end up with
either a three dimensional rendering
of the surface or a two dimensional
rendering of the surface that --
that then is the form -- the
basis of this digital data set.
[Inaudible] archive it and then you
also pass it through an algorithm
that calculates how would a
needle move through this surface
if it was actually playing.
That creates an audio waveform,
which you can than put
into the form of a file.
So in the process of this
of course, you can --
you can do digital
restoration, you can ask questions
about the condition of the material
and so forth through these --
through these analysis processes.
Okay, so the two basic ways of
getting information once you're
in -- on the computer from --
from these data sets
are -- are as follows.
If you have a very high
contrast, two dimensional image
of the surface, that
can be suitable for --
for grooves that move
from side-to-side.
You can obtain these through --
either through direct imaging
or through the photographic films
of the surface that you then scan.
You have to have an
illumination system
that highlights the surface
features that are flat
so you can see distinct edges.
You need sufficient resolution
to match the audio content,
so that turns out to have about
one pixel in your imaging system,
needs to refer to about a
micron on the object surface.
You naturally end up sampling
the audio in the time domain
up to 100 kilohertz or even more,
quite readily when you
-- when you do this.
There are high speed cameras for
collecting pictures like this
that allow you to collect
the data in --
in just a small factor times
the actual real play time.
And then finally, you
can extract the --
the groove information and
information about damage and debris
by applying a very well known
mathematical image processing
technique that is called
edge detection.
And that's what happens when
you apply an edge detector
to this picture.
It throws everything away except
the -- the interfaces between light
and dark where all the
information is stored.
Once you have this, it's basically a
swarm of data points that -- that --
that reflects very directly the
-- the stored audio information.
It's almost trivial to go from --
from this kind of a data
set to actual sound.
But the great thing about --
about this is that it's --
it so nicely captures the very
regular, but undulating structure
of the groove, but when there's
a -- a damaged area, or dust,
or a big scratch, the edge detector
kind of goes crazy and you end
up with a swarm of uncorrelated
-- relatively uncorrelated points.
And that's a great way
of identifying damage
and spurious features in the
audio right there in the image.
So, it's -- it's a
pretty powerful method
and it's widely used among
the different approaches.
Instead if you go to
three dimensions,
you want to capture the entire
three dimensional structure
of the surface.
That's important in the cylinder
or any vertically cut material
because photography
is not a very good way
of capturing the third dimension.
So the method of choice which
has emerged among people working
in this field, is a type
of confocal microscopes.
It's a microscope which actually
measures the third dimension very
well and the other dimensions in
a scanning kind of an approach.
And it -- it's actually very
clever the way -- the way it works.
It takes white light
and it focuses it
through a lens that's a
mixture of a lens and a prism.
So all the different colors get
dispersed by this lens and they come
into focus at different places.
Okay, so you get this swarm of --
of points of red, green,
blue, and so forth.
And then when you pass the
surface through that region
of multiple focus points, you
get reflections back strongly
from the color that's
in focus and weakly
from the colors that
are out of focus.
And so you can -- you can
really color the depth.
These are extremely powerful devices
and they have a very
significant industrial
and manufacturing application,
so they're --
it's a very growing field and we're
really benefitted from these things.
The point that they
measure is very small,
it's only about three
microns in diameter.
And they have vertical
resolutions of 50 to 100 nanometers.
So 100 nanometer is
a tenth of a micron.
A micron is a 50th of a human hair.
So it shows you, you know,
what we're talking about --
sizes which are small compared --
resolution which is small compared
to the natural scale
of how the surface
of these materials
change due to the audio.
And they're very verbose.
You get a lot of repetitive
data about the surface,
so you can apply averaging
and -- and so forth.
Okay, now when you take a
physical carrier and you migrate it
from the -- from the -- the --
the physical object
to an electronic form,
you're in a modern day,
we're digitizing, okay.
So it's important to understand what
we mean when we say digitization
because it -- it really has
a kind of different meaning
in these image-based approaches than
in the more traditional approach.
So let -- let's consider
the traditional approach.
So in the traditional
approach, you put a needle down,
the needle follows the groove, the
motion of the needle transforms --
well, the -- the velocity
of the needle is transformed
by the mechanism in the cartridge
into an electrical signal.
That's what this waveform is.
That's passed through a
filter and then into an analog
to digital converter that's
running at a certain speed,
let's say 44.1 kilohertz for
standard CD's or 96 kilohertz
for the higher speed archival specs.
And that represents -- and that --
and that results in a
series of discreet points
that represent the
filtered version of what --
what was on -- what was on the disc.
So there's a clock
and there's an ADC.
Now when we digitize a sound
carrier using these optical methods,
we're essentially taking
a picture of the surface.
And so we're turning the physical
object into a grid of points,
so pixels or voxels, right.
Now, those pixels have different
meanings in different directions.
So the pixels that are going
along the time direction,
the direction of increasing time,
the way those pixels are sliced
up tells you how fast
you're sampling the audio.
So that's like the clock, right.
The pixels in the other directions
in some way relate to the accuracy
with which you're measuring
the amplitude.
But that's a much more
complicated relationship
that depends on many things.
It depends on the properties of the
imager, it depends on the algorithm
that you're using to
-- to get the data out.
So, while in the case of an
ADC, I can tell you, well,
according to the specification
book, this is a 16 bit ADC
or a 10 bit ADC -- is
not a simple way to say
that a particular optical
process results
in a certain particular bit depth.
There are many particulars and I --
I'm not going to address
this point more until I get
to my own presentation later about
the IRENE system and I will talk
about it in that particular
context, but I --
I'll invite obviously the other
speakers to address that --
that issue as they see it.
Okay, so why do this?
And by the way, Peter, can
you let me know when --
when is this talk supposed to end?
I'll keep going, okay.
So, never.
Okay. So why do this?
Why are we doing this?
In the -- in the first, Peter
and Gene, I think eloquently --
and Mark, eloquently addressed
this, but to reiterate --
we do this for preservation, to
protect delicate or damaged objects
from further degradation,
to restore the unplayable.
We do this for access,
to use automated scanning
and analysis methods to massively
digitize large collections.
We do this to assess
the, in detailed way,
the condition of these
sound carriers.
We do this to avoid the need to
maintain legacy playback systems
and diverse legacy playback systems.
And we do this in the hope of
applying high resolution methods
to extend the frequency response
and noise reduction opportunities
of getting data from
-- from these carriers.
And I could add, you know,
Peter's really nice point
about getting access to what --
what we maybe even considered to be
intangible at some time, these --
these hidden, latent
sets of information
that can be very meaningful
in the end.
Okay. So where are the advantages?
So, remember that we're
transforming the object now
into a very large digital data set.
This is a modern notion of
the digital humanities, okay.
And then once you get into the
realm of the digital humanities,
you can ask questions and do things
that you never would have
though you could of done before.
So, there are advantages -- and
I will have a couple of slides
that address these, but just
as a list, I'm going to argue
that this approach is very general.
I try to make the point about
the diversity of sound carriers.
The -- the methods are
redundant, they're verbose,
you get a lot of data that -- that
has repetitive information in it.
They have extraordinarily good
frequency response and resolution
out to -- to very high frequencies.
They allow you to deal
in a really rational way
with delicate and broken materials.
And they lack the physical dynamics
of a mechanical playback system
that responds in real time and --
and that is an important
thing as well.
So generality, these methods
have already been demonstrated
on a large variety of
materials and formats
that required actually
very little reconfiguration
of the scanning system.
So, shellac discs, lacquer discs,
aluminum discs, memovox discs,
dictation belts, wax and plastic
cylinders, copper galvanos,
tin foil cylinders and discs,
experimental optical discs,
paper tracings, wax discs with
both vertical and lateral cut.
These are all examples of
things that have been scanned
and then restored already
by optical methods.
I reproduced the picture
from the first --
second slide because those are
actually examples of all things
that have been already
looked at to this day
with -- with optical methods.
So sound redundancies -- a sound
is recorded not just in one point
on a surface, but in the
entire profile of the groove.
The entire profile
contains multiple copies
of the same audio information.
So the groove is moving -- and a
stylus when you plop it in there,
really only samples a small
portion of the groove.
But a more complete data set,
the entire groove profile,
gives us analysis options
which can sometimes add value
and that's represented showing that
these lines are the computers choice
of using all the points along the
edge as an estimation of the sound.
And here's a case where there's
some sort of a defect or a damage
in this -- in this particular
portion of the groove.
That can be eliminated from the
data set because it's so redundant.
So frequency response --
I'm going to dwell on this
for a moment before finishing
up because this is, I believe,
a really critical issue for
optical restoration and something
that people really
need to keep in mind.
On a lateral disc and when the
groove is moving side-to-side,
as the frequency goes up what
happens is the stylus sort
of gets pushed higher
up into the groove.
On a vertically cut disc,
something really different happens.
As the frequency goes
up, the stylus starts
to sample the groove incompletely.
And I'll show you in
a picture why that is.
This leads to distortion,
to attenuation,
and to non-linearity
in the playback.
Optical probes are so much
smaller than physical styli,
that they don't suffer from this
at -- until you get to a very,
very high frequency, okay.
So, these little undulations here
are supposed to just, you know,
be higher and higher frequencies
that might be vertically recorded.
So when you -- when -- when
the stylus is placed in there,
you can just see very
clearly from the picture
that at a certain frequency, the
stylus is going to be too big to fit
into the structure
anymore vertically, okay.
That's called a tracing error, okay.
Once that happens, the
amplitude gets attenuated,
the sound gets distorted and
it happens in a non-linear way
because it samples one direction
of the swing, but not the other.
The optical stylus is so tiny,
that this problem only shows
up at a much higher frequency.
So where does that happen?
So here's just a simple
little calculation.
Let's look at the numbers.
So, a cylinder's playback stylus
of 7.5 mils, which is a kind
of standard value, plops down
into the groove which let's say,
has a depth of 10 microns.
And it reaches the bottom
at -- and at some point,
there's something I'll call the
critical chord, it's the place
where essentially you
-- you just fit, okay.
So that occurs around 85
microns for this geometry, right.
So the question is,
where does the wavelength
on the surface actually hit 85
microns and the -- and the --
and the cylinder playback
stylus no longer fit anymore?
Okay. Well, that depends on the --
on the speed with which
the record was recorded,
whether it's a 90 RPM or 160 RPM.
So I, you know, did this whole
spreadsheet, but you can see
that this -- this stylus will
start to not fit anymore at three
to 4000 cycles per second.
Okay? The optical limit occurs
around 100,000 cycles per second.
And it's just because one
is bigger than the other.
So really, if you play a
cylinder back with a stylus
and you digitize it at 96 kilohertz,
your affective bandwidth is
equivalent to only sampling it
at eight kilohertz, which is twice
that critical frequency,
it's the Nyquist rule.
So, people think, well, I'm
running this thing at 96 kilohertz
or 48 kilohertz -- you're
not getting that information
because the stylus
just can't pick it up.
It's too big, all right.
Who cares, right.
Who cares about high frequencies
on an acoustic recording?
Acoustic recordings only capture
sound up to a few kilohertz anyway,
but the problem is that damage and
wear don't respect these limits.
Cracks, scratches, the effects of
mold have high frequency information
in them which is -- which is --
doesn't care about the
frequency limitations
of the recording process, okay.
That's the reason in any case, that
you want to transfer a recording
with very high sampling rate,
because you want to
get at the noise.
Only an optical scan gives
you the resolution to measure
and process these high
frequency features, okay.
And here's an example.
So this is a cylinder
which was played back
on a modern stylus player and
was played back optically.
This is a plot of the
energy or the --
the power essentially at
different frequencies.
So here's the -- the music,
it's the Rakoczy March,
so it's if you're a
Hungarian nationalist,
you're going to like this.
And once you get above
a few kilohertz,
the frequency content
drops really fast.
That's because the
stylus is too big, right.
So, let's listen to
what it sounds like.
[ Music ]
Okay. And now, the same cylinder,
the same portion played
back optically.
[ Music ]
Now, you might not like that because
it sounds brighter and tinnier
and is more noise, but
that's exactly what you want.
You want all the information,
you want all the noise
because then you have what to
work on when you try to process it
and -- and handle it, okay.
So this is a -- a more true
rendering of the information
than that which limits
you when you have a stylus
that has a natural frequency cutoff.
Okay. Here's where it comes in
when you try to do noise reduction.
This is a depth map, so dark is deep
of a little portion of the surface
of a wax cylinder from the
collection of the University
of California's Hearst Museum.
It's a recording of Ishi, he was the
last speaker and surviving member
of the Yahi band of
Northern California.
He was recorded in 1911 by
Professor Waterman and Krober,
a very famous collection, it's on --
been on the national sound registry
and it has damage due to mold
that eats into the surface.
So that's all this
black stuff that is deep
into the surface, it's dark, okay.
So when you play it back with a
stylus, this is what it sounds like.
[ Singing ]
When you do an optical version
and you capture all these --
these fast noise transients
and can process them,
you're going to hear this and
don't pay attention to the rumble,
I want you to pay attention
to the crunching sound
due to the mold damage.
[ Singing ]
Okay. So, broken and
delicate materials,
these are obvious for
noninvasive methods.
A number of broken and damaged
things have been shown already,
you're going to see more
later in the conference.
There are issues related
to how you collect data
from these segmented objects
and there are different
approaches and visual audio.
And IRENE, you're going
to hear about those,
but there are many common issues in
the way the data has to be analyzed
and how you link groove
segments across gaps.
And then the problem of
what happens when the number
of broken segments approaches
infinity, how do you deal with that?
That is a very interesting problem.
I think finally, modeling, okay.
What you see is what you get, that's
a little bit of a pun I guess,
but what I'm saying is
because you have these very,
very high frequency response
and very high resolution,
you get optical transfers that are
truly flat in the frequency sense.
The optical measuring processes
don't have an intrinsic frequency
response, which it then
imposes on the measured audio.
A stylus on the other hand is
a dynamic, mechanical system
and that creates a
particular sound when you --
when you hit a defect, okay.
Physical modeling can be used to
add these to optical measured data,
but that's really a choice.
So here's a -- this
is a stylus playback
and you can see it hits a scratch
and the stylus actually rings
for some period of time.
The mechanical stylus
respond dynamically
and to these imperfections
and that creates the sound
that you're familiar with
in a stylus playback.
But that's -- that's an
effect, okay, it's an artifact.
It's not actually part of
the sound recording, okay.
Is this a universal solution?
No, not yet.
At present, the tools are expensive,
there's scientific instruments
with a limited expert base.
They take longer than traditional
playback methods by a fair margin
in some cases to --
to collect their data.
For commercially pressed shellac
discs, which is most of what's
out there in some numerical
sense and if they're
in reasonable condition,
traditional methods are faster,
much faster and are often superior.
But for vertically cut
records and delicate, damaged
or special needs materials
like lacquers, there are very,
very significant advantages
and I think that's what
brought everybody here today.
So what does this field need?
The field has made I
think very good progress
in about 15 years considering the
small number of people at work.
In the 1980's, over $20
million of venture capital,
in then year dollars, was
invested in domestic R
and D for the laser turntable
that actually never really worked.
And then, the Japanese
started working on it.
So, I can only imagine
what they invested
in it before it became
a commercial product.
The amount of money which has
been invested internationally
in optical methods, of
the metrological sense,
is much, much less than this.
We need a larger community
of developers and users
to bring this into greater use.
We need to develop accepted
standards and specifications
that everyone agrees
upon and can adhere to.
We need more targeted engineering
and software development.
We need access to new
instrumentation as they appear.
We need to offer more
training opportunities,
educational opportunities and
internships to younger people
to -- to learn these methods.
And we need more focused,
large transfer projects as ways
to gain experience and converge on
best practices across a community.
Okay, so I'm going to conclude just
with a little anecdotal reference.
When you're -- when you're
confronted with an opportunity,
a new idea or some direction to go,
obviously people are often hesitant
and maybe don't want to take
the chance to try something new.
I think the library showed a lot of
leadership and the funding agencies
in Europe who supported this
showed a lot of leadership
to embrace these things
and say, you know,
why don't you try to
do these things?
But you should always keep in mind
that sometimes your assumptions,
if you're scared of
them, they prevent you
from -- from going forward.
So I want you to question
your assumptions.
So the invention of sound recording
in the 19th Century utilizes
technology and methods
which actually could have
been applied hundreds
of years before that.
So I always wondered, could Leonardo
DaVinci who's like the smartest guy
of the 14 to 1500's, you know,
have invented sound recording?
Why didn't he do that?
He had everything he could
-- he needed to do it.
But it turns out that Da
Vinci believed that poetry
and music were inferior to sculpture
and painting because hearing is
and I quote, "Less noble than
sight, in that as it is born it dies
and its death is as
swift as its birth."
Okay. So he figured, you know,
God didn't care about sound
or he would have made
it more permanent.
He didn't realize that he was put
on earth to solve that problem
and find a way to record sound,
but he just didn't do it, okay.
So, you know, it's always
good to think about Leonardo
when you're trying to make your
next funding decision, okay.
Anyway, so -- so I think
that's all I have, yeah.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
So, I think you're doing questions
at the end, right, Peter or now?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Oh.
>> Here, let me give
you a mic [inaudible] --
>> So, Carl, as you're -- as
you're talking about the maturation
of this, I guess traditionally if
I went to the Library of Congress
to get a recording,
I'd get a recording.
But now is there a method
to distribute the data sets?
Is that -- is that the
future you're seeing?
>> Carl Haber: Well, so
you're asking a question
about how the results of these
optical studies are disseminated,
okay.
So, for -- for small pilot
projects and I'll speak about some
that we did at Berkeley and I'm
sure our colleagues will speak
about other ones that they've done.
We have it set up, you know,
websites about the Volta
Laboratory Collection
from the Smithsonian and so forth.
But in terms of the
library's process
for disseminating the results of
this, I would like to defer to Peter
or some colleagues from the
library to answer that question.
>> Sorry, I actually was --
>> Carl Haber: The question is --
>> Can you hear me?
>> -- is if you do these
large-scale transfers, how do --
how are the results made
available to people?
>> Yeah, can I get the data set or
do I just still get the recording?
Is that ......--
>> Carl Haber: You mean,
you want the image data?
>> -- the future that you see
that you will distribute the --
the 3D data set, the
image of the recording
as well as the [inaudible] --
>> Well, I mean, the -- the
mission of the library is
to make the stuff available.
There's nothing, you know, if --
if this was previous to the ability
to image these things and someone
wanted to physically look at a --
an object, you know, they'd
have to come here and see it.
That' similar to being able
to distribute data set,
I guess there are copyright
issues, right, Gene?
I mean, if -- if something is
copy written, I suppose the --
the image data set is as copy
written as an audio file,
so you certainly have
that, you know,
you can't just pass
these things around.
But do you have something --
>> -- but doing something
that's completely new.
So, you know, taking copyright
aside, if you were asking for a --
>> If you're asking for,
you know, an image --
you know, IRENE transfer, say
of -- of a sound recording,
in my opinion you would get the
full data set and an audio file.
That would be just -- that would
just be what -- what you got.
But that's a new or a -- that's
a new idea, although you know,
now we give it -- we provide you
with maybe a scan of the label.
People sometimes ask for the
scan of a label of a disc and --
and the audio file as well, but
nonetheless, that's a new idea.
But yeah, I would consider that part
of the transfer and I think any DCC
who was actually doing this
-- this work does the same.
>> Is Bill there, or?
>> I'm certain that they are
distributing the data set along
with the --
>> Carl Haber: Yeah, so is -- I
don't know, is Bill or Mason here?
Yeah.
>> Yeah, so we -- in general
for institutional clients,
we include the image data and
some of them aren't interested,
but we've had some people
that were more interested
in the images than the sounds, so.
Yeah, I think they're
really important and useful.
>> I can -- the -- my name's
Jerry Favers [assumed spelling],
I'm the curator at the Thomas
Edison National Historical Park
and I can speak to this as a user --
as a customer both with experience
that Library of Congress
at any -- and at any DCC.
And I think with this process,
it's important to understand
that the archival data that's
captured is the image data and we --
in my experience, I was given
the image data, but not the --
no capability of using it.
Not the software, in other words.
I think that's something
that needs to change.
>> Carl Haber: I think that's
a tremendously good point.
And so what you're saying is, to
translate to a more general way --
so, the optical systems scan,
they create image files.
Then the operators use software
to transform the image into audio.
And so, simpleminded things, okay,
and then when you give the user the
audio -- if you give the user the --
the image, there is software that
can be used to -- to transfer that.
And you can make different
choices when you do
that about noise reduction or a
bunch of choices that you can make.
And one of the goals really
should be and as part of this --
this notion of -- of larger
community of developers and users,
and more targeted engineering
and software.
It would be great to make an
application that is easy to use,
that is very user-friendly, that
has the basic presets or choices
and it gives a person with
just a little bit of training,
the possibility to
process the image data.
And it's a great goal.
It's just something that
hasn't been accommodated yet,
but it's certainly something that
you could define quite readily
and -- and think about doing.
And you're right, that -- that is
something that you should have.
>> Jim Nye from University
of Chicago.
Thanks, Carl.
You used the [inaudible] of
zoology, but it occurred to me now
as you're talking, as this
discussion is going forward
about images and distribution
of images,
that you've added a new element to
the zoo in an important way and --
and extended zoology
really, carrying it forward.
But speaking to the importance
of distributing the --
the images themselves,
if I think of an analog,
the Dead Sea Scrolls come to mind.
And for a long time, many
of you probably will know
that it was only the research
on the Dead Sea Scrolls
that was distributed and the
images themselves were not
until fairly recently.
But by virtue of distributing
the microfilm or other sources
that have the full context
of the Dead Sea Scrolls,
you've increased the
number of users.
And here I'd like to point
back to your set of needs.
You've talked about
a larger user base,
but presumably you want a
larger research base as well.
>> Carl Haber: Absolutely.
>> By distributing the images,
effectively you increase the
possibility that a larger group
of scientists can address these
questions of interpretation
of the signals in new
and creative ways
that might not be possible
now or even imagined now.
>> Carl Haber: I mean, it
might be a good idea to sort
of do a pilot project where we
put up a variety of image files
from a variety of sound carriers
and put it out there to the --
the world of universities
and interested people,
like a data challenge,
to see what they can do.
I actually went to a data
challenge event in San Francisco.
This is where these big data
companies offer a prize to come
up with a better way
to analyze things.
So, for example, I'm a high
energy physicist and they put
out the data set that led to the
discovery of the Higgs particle
and they just ask the world
to try to analyze it and see
if they could get a better signal
to noise than the physicist got.
They did. But -- but these kind
of data challenges, you know,
they gain -- they gain
some traction and --
and there's a lot of
smart people out there
who think about large data sets.
And so, it might be a way
to seed something like this.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, there's going to be a general
discussion after -- yeah, okay.
[ Applause ]
>> Ottar Johnsen: Thank
you for the opportunity
to present the visual audio project.
I would like to say many
people, same as with Carl,
many people have contributed
to this project.
Some of the names are here.
I have forgotten many and also
[inaudible] maybe 50 names to add.
I am not going -- I'm going
to jump over some of the --
my slides because Carl has
already given you the most
important information.
And what's the problem?
Well, [inaudible] that's
why I will go to.
Next slide, to -- and this
slide is mainly interesting
because that's a kind of
slide we have been working on,
and Stefano will get into more
detail about such records.
And the fundamental again, Carl
has talked about and now I'm going
to the fundamental technique.
It's the idea from Stefano, I will
talk a little bit about it later,
is to the entire surface of
a disc could be photographed.
Here is the same observation if we
look with a microscope of a groove,
probably you know what
kind of record this is.
This is your stereo record because
you see the widths and the --
the lateral movement
change with time.
And here is a basic block diagram
of the visual audio concept
where we have one step -- one
extra step from the record.
First we make film, then we digitize
film, then last step, we go from --
we extract the sound from
the image to get a sound.
Now why should we have an
intermediate photographic step?
It's controversial something, it's a
good solution something [inaudible].
I believe one idea is that it's
urgent way to -- to extract --
not extract the sound, to save the
disc before it decays even more.
Film are small, cheap, quite stable.
We know it [inaudible] microfilms.
Microfilms are last a few
hundred year [inaudible].
And we are using film
relatively similar to microfilm.
Here is what we get if
illuminate a record from above,
a record [inaudible]
both with 78 rpm record
where the groove is a little
bit round and with 33 rpm record
where the groove is much
more triangular groove.
And this is what we get
at the bottom on the --
on the film, but I will get
in more detail on it later.
So what do we need for the film?
If we have the highest possible
resolution, the smallest grain,
it should be black and white.
We don't care about color and also,
black and white film have
much higher resolution
than color photographic film.
And also, the speed should
be high of the films,
so that we can reduce the time
and also we can reduce
the amount of light.
We melted a few records I believe
at the beginning in our first trial
because we had 500 watts light,
but we did it on --
on record of no value.
Here you see the picture
of the system [inaudible]
and the next we see the
system to take picture.
Basically, the system while you
will make a one to one picture,
here we have a 40 centimeter
focal lengths lens.
If it were one to one,
we need 80 centimeter,
two times the focal length
on each time -- each play --
each side of the lens, so it give
a total length of one meter 60.
And the total system is a
little bit more than two meter
because we want -- we need
some hardware [inaudible] --
some mechanical hardware outside.
So how does -- how do we
make the illumination?
We make the illumination so
that we can separate the --
the interesting part.
We use directional light,
we use monochromatic
[inaudible] monochromatic light
so that we can -- first of all,
we select the shortest
possible wavelength
and that is blue or deep blue.
And secondly, we have less
problem with [inaudible] dispersion
when using a single color.
And now, in optics
or in photographics,
in the photographical optic,
resolution is limited
by two main factor.
We have the diffraction
that gives us an airy disc.
It mean one point become a
spot of a certain [inaudible].
And we have the de-focusing error
because we are never
completely focused just
because our record
had a certain depth.
And both of them give
a certain enlargement.
And we can calculate all
of them and they depend
on the numerical aperture.
And both of them depend -- and one
of the problem is that one improves
when you increase the numerical
aperture, the other one goes down.
So we must get -- so
there is a compromise.
It's a good thing with a compromise,
is that when we have the
sum, the bottom is very flat.
So we can use practical
consideration, for example,
the size of the system of other to
select something that is within one
or two percent of the optimum,
especially taking into account
that it is [inaudible] optimum.
There, yes -- here are the --
are the value with -- with the --
with the end number that we can
actually have on the optic we had.
And here again, you see the
-- the resolution in micron.
So now we have done one
process, we have taken a picture
and what's interesting with the
picture is that with this picture,
we have a big [inaudible].
We have a [inaudible] of one
millimeter and that is good due
to -- because many records are not
flat, are in bad shape, can be bent,
but a depth of one millimeter
we can get bigger [inaudible].
Simply then we have less resolution.
Now, next step we have a film.
We use negative film, but people
could use also positive film.
And then we have to use a scanner.
And our scanner is
quite similar to --
has many similar characteristics
to Carl's 2D system.
Simply while scanning a
film, not -- not a record.
What it means also we get
light, a reflective light,
we have light going through
the film by transparency.
And here, when you see a little
bit better, you recognize under --
on the bottom of the
system, a light source.
Unhappily, we had to use red light
because blue light
source are not available.
It is LED [inaudible] already.
And we hope -- we at each --
we have a rotating scanner at
each rotation with 2048 samples.
So we -- we are scanning in
each rotation a certain number
of [inaudible] if there are only
five, but usually [inaudible] 10
to 12 rotation we get when we scan.
Our sampling frequency is valuable.
We have used sampling
frequency of up
to 200 kilo samples per ring
corresponding for 33 rpm record
of sampling frequency up to
110 and for 78 rpm records
of sampling frequency
up to 260 kilohertz.
That is probably used less,
but again as Carl said,
now it's [inaudible] useful
information to improve
in -- to reduce in-band noise.
So here is what we get with the
-- when we scan the picture.
That is a more typical example while
you recognize the sound and you see
that for each groove,
we have two white lines
and in the middle we
have black line.
Remember, it is a negative,
so all we talk
about the lines get inverted.
And now, if we look at the optic,
we go from the photographic
optic now to microscope optic.
We have the same physical
constrained
from the optic, but
different number.
We have the diffraction
giving the airy disc
and we have the de-focusing.
And there, we consider that we need
a depth of field of 30 to 50 micron
and it gives us blur, total
blur of about 13 micron.
And what is interesting is
as it is shown on this curve,
increasing magnification does
not increase the resolution.
Because when increased
magnification at a certain point,
you have a reduction in
the -- in the resolution.
And here are just we have different
figure whether we need a [inaudible]
of 30 or 50 micron.
Where does it -- the number
30 and 50 micron come from?
They come from our knowledge
about the negative film
[inaudible] accuracy
in negative film plus the
film is put on a glass plate
and the glass plate rotate.
We have measured how the glass
plate move up and down on a rotation
and -- and that is how we came
to -- to the fact that we are --
we need a depth of field of
between 30 and 50 micron.
And here I go back
to what is happening
with 78 rotation per minute record.
We have -- we have form with
a groove and it gives --
where we have a lot of
light, reflected light, we --
it's black because it's negative.
And where we have no
reflected light, it is white
and that's why we have two
white lines for each groove.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I put -- pushed the wrong button.
And the -- for our 33 rpm
record usually we have nothing
at the bottom, but sometimes
because the cut is not perfect,
we have also very same line,
black line appearing in --
at the bottom, but not often.
For processing the
image, we do basically
as Carl said, edge detection.
And we have two or four edges.
Secondly, important
thing, the resolution --
the edge detection can be
detected with better than a pixel,
that's what I call
subpixel accuracy.
If the accuracy of the position
of a edge depends on signal
to noise concern [inaudible]
problem.
Not to the size of
pixel on the scanner.
And as I said, noise and distortion
are the problem, the main problem --
it is not [inaudible]
it is not a blur.
It is mostly the noise
and distortion.
But the good -- but if we have
less blur, we have more information
on a noise and we might
be able to --
to get rid of the noise
in a better way.
And the noise distortion, many
-- there are many of them --
dust, defect, non constant
illumination.
Our main noise that is different
from what Carlo does
is a film grain.
We have random shaped
crystal system in photography.
We have -- we have noise
naturally in the linear CCD camera.
We have -- we might have,
but -- well, it's very low.
Our sampling frequency of
sampling time is not perfect,
so might be vibration, mechanical
vibration on the scanner.
There might be bad centering
of the record, same issue.
And - but -- bad centering create
only second or third order problem.
So one thing we do to
light is not -- we don't --
can't have constant illumination due
to the optics -- optics of the --
the microscope makes it our
lightest, not constantly constant.
That can be corrected with
a curve, but any correction
that you [inaudible]
some slide noise.
And it's easy, we measure
a film without anything
and that gives us a
correction curve.
And now, we look at the processing.
Here is a typical example,
we have two white lines
and we want to extract the edge.
And we are looking, we cut
with looking at one pixel
and you have the intensity .
We dictate up to constant
level on the top and the bottom
and after the threshold,
it's put about in the middle.
It is more complicated than that.
And then, we are going
to do it with time --
with time, yes, vertically
it's a time --
or it is space here what
is correspond to time.
And now, what are going to do?
We are going to look at the
image -- image to find mistake.
As you can see below, if we
take just the average about --
between the four edges
or between the two edges,
we see clearly some distortion.
And we have some information
to get rid of information.
We know that all the four
lines should be [inaudible].
So [inaudible] being stupid
and adding the four lines
to get [inaudible]
the best position.
We -- we add the four lines when
everything is perfect [inaudible],
but when one line is clearly
different from the other,
we suppose that that
line is incorrect.
And then you will make an
interpolation on this line based
on the three other lines.
When I say line, I mean
naturally the edge.
And -- and typically, yes, it's
also -- we use [inaudible].
And when we have cut we
do interpolation linear
of [inaudible] second
of the interpolation.
And here is another
example where you see
where we have the four edges.
And where we detect
where there are problems.
And in red, we have the edges,
the four edges after correction.
Here is on top, we have what we --
the basic signal, it's
a edge signal.
And on this edge signal, I
like to show the top one.
We have two special
effects, we have a ramp.
The ramp is due to the
spiral in the groove.
Then we have a [inaudible],
nearly a [inaudible] wave.
The [inaudible] wave is due to
bad centering of the record.
And then at the beginning,
you see some jump.
That when we jumped to the
next groove we made a mistake.
We jump on one groove to next
and then back again later.
It didn't happen much, but I want
-- I, on purpose, I put one --
one bad case where
we put it in evident.
So after taking away
[inaudible] and a sine wave --
and the sine wave has a
frequency equal to rotation,
to our 32 -- 33 rpm record.
It correspond to 0.5 hertz
signal for 78 at 1.2 hertz about.
So it is very easy to get rid of
it just by high pass filtering.
And then afterwards, we get the
sound waves glitches at place
where it jumped or where
there was some noise.
Afterwards, I don't want to go
into all the specialty record,
but most record are equalized.
It mean that what you see, the
lateral movement is not the sound.
There are some derivative
and integration
to be made before getting
the equalized sound.
It means that when reading we must
make inverse equalization operation
as [inaudible] when
writing on the record.
That is done in most mechanical
playing device, the same is done.
The problem, we don't always know
how the equalization was made.
We know it for after
the a1930's we had stand
out equalization before each
record was nearly equalized
in a different way.
And additional post-processing
might be applied,
but many sound specialists
say, don't process,
don't do any additional
post-processing on the original.
Only do it on copy.
Keep the original even if bad shape
because later we might
have better technique.
Now, how can we measure the quality.
That a big issue.
Perceptually is one possibility.
Another possibility is
to measure the noise
in silent section of a groove.
A third solution is
to have a test record
and to measure what we obtained.
As an example, this is
just for showing On the --
on the bottom slide, we have a sine
-- the spectrum of a sine wave.
And what do we have if we have
a perfect sound on the record.
We'll have a peak in -- at
the frequency of the sound
and elsewhere, we will have noise.
That what we see at the bottom.
And it's much -- it's some high
frequency of some small peaks
that can be due -- due
to many [inaudible].
For example, 30 or 60 hertz
interference during recording
that comes out -- can come out
a different frequency later.
And on top, we have example, that
is what happened when we have none
of [inaudible] and we have
an [inaudible] harmonics
and [inaudible].
So such technique can be used to try
to measure the signal
to noise ratio.
And what resolution do we
need to get, for example,
a 40 dB signal to noise ratio?
With constant amplitude record,
we need a resolution at 1.75
or accuracy at 1.75 micron.
For constant velocity, 0.25 micron
and for equalized record,
1.28 micron.
And this is amazing number showing
that in mechanical engineering --
in mechanics, 150 years ago, they
did as well as electronic managed
to do with [inaudible] 20 years ago.
So, electronic is 100 -- more than
100 years behind -- mechanics.
I like to tell it especially
to my electronics colleagues.
I am electronics also,
not a mechanic.
I show how perfect one wasable to
record things in a mechanical way.
So does it make sense
to try to get this?
One -- one thing now, a blur
of 25 micron and a resolution
of one micron, I mean,
we're far away.
But the blur is low pass filtering,
so resolution is related
to the noise.
That's why it's -- it
does -- it is possible.
But actually, if we can reduce a
blur, it will be a good solution.
It helps always.
Now I go through something
Stefano will go more through it,
is the time of processing.
And I believe each
case is different,
and Stefano has much
better [inaudible].
Yes. So the advantage
I believe I have talked
about already, compared
to mechanical.
I want to go now into the detail
of the record cut in many pieces.
When you look the image file,
when you scan the record,
the [inaudible] record become a
file like this, and the sound is
in a groove vertically,
and we have big crack.
And [inaudible] that we have pieces
of the puzzle, except [inaudible]
but with a slight cut between them.
So what can we do?
First thing we must label each part
of our puzzle as it is shown here.
And now we must try to fit
perfectly the different pieces
of the puzzle using information.
And first [inaudible] first we
have to detect the common border
of a chunk, then we must
look at the best match
and then we must add together
or put together different parts
of sound on each [inaudible].
So here is an example,
we have a chunk,
and you see the vertical line
corresponds to the groove.
And afterward we have now the common
[inaudible] between the groove
and we must [inaudible] best
match of the two blue path
or the two red path or
the two [inaudible] path.
And this is done [inaudible] here.
First we put the -- we look at the
path of the groove near the boulder
on each side, and we look at
what shift gave the best math.
We have found that there
can be shifts up to five --
equivalent to five groove,
maybe even six or seven.
So we have to test what
displacement give the best match,
it means give the best similarity
in the statistical property
on the groove above
and below the cut.
And there are many
different [inaudible].
And there are some
special situations.
For example you see here,
sometimes one groove might disappear
[inaudible] because it was
exactly where there was a cut.
Okay? And here you see how -- we
can see how usually relatively well.
Now, what happened in some case
the computer is much more stupid
than human.
So what do we have to build?
We have to build something so that
when the computer is not sure,
it let an operator
decide what to do.
And I will show it only very
happily here on this picture,
on the left, the operator.
For each place the computer
can't make a decision,
the operator can change what
groove fit which -- each other.
For example, it can say that the
groove should be fitted this way.
There are still some problems.
Sometimes there are [inaudible].
Secondly, sometimes on record
there are several [inaudible].
A record stops and the -- because it
was, for example, for a court case,
at the end they will lift
the groove [inaudible] --
not the groove, stylus,
and a new one will start.
And there might be
some other problems.
Sometimes that what happened
with our first record,
the reading was the wrong way.
The reading was the wrong way.
With the first, six months after we
started the project we got the very
same sound until we
found the right idea.
Let's try to turn around the sound.
So that is -- one should
never forget it.
Then afterwards simply we
concatenate all the sound together
to get the sound.
We have processed the
number of such records.
Typically that will go on to say we
couldn't recover all the records,
at least at that time.
Typically 35 faces out
of 46 could be extracted.
Some were in too bad a shape.
Now just a few more words.
As a professor I'm very happy
that the project doesn't finish
by collecting dust because
that's what happened with 99%
of the project of Professor
[inaudible].
But the one who initiated
it, Stefano Cavaglieri
from the Swiss National
Archives in Lugano,
is also the one taking it
over, and I'm very happy,
especially that I am now one
year before retirement age.
So it's good to know
that the same continuing.
It was very interesting
because it's very valuable.
That's why I didn't
believe in this project
of [inaudible] the beginning,
but I knew it was a very
interesting project for the students
because updates, electronic,
mechanic, everything.
What I found later so very
interesting is working with people
who are not engineering
near of non-physicists --
engineering near the same --
but people from the humanities
and people from, yes,
from the cultural world.
It was a collaboration
between many institutions
and with funding from
different entities.
Thank you very much, and so --
[ Applause ]
>> So, let me [inaudible]
Stefano [inaudible].
>> Maybe I'm --
>> Hi, Stefano, how you doing?
>> This is Bill Storm.
I have a question regarding
the way you've --
>> How are you?
>> Pretty good.
>> Oh, hi.
>> There we go.
In the 1980s, there was a major
project done in this country
that resulted -- it was called
the Rigler-Deutsch Index.
That's a microfilm copy of many
thousands of sound recordings
that allow the Library of
Congress, New York Public, Yale,
Syracuse University, and I'm going
to forget somebody,
to -- we did a --
>> Yeah.
>> -- photography of all
of these sound recordings
with very, very even lighting.
It was using high-contrast
microfilm.
Is it possible that your
system might literally be able
to play those images from
the Rigler-Deutsch Index?
They're very high-resolution.
>> Okay.
>> Ottar Johnsen: Yes, what
are the size of the films?
>> Thirty-five millimeter.
>> Ottar Johnsen: Thirty-five
millimeter.
Oh, no. That's for the first test
we tried 35 millimeter and just
by simple calculation we found
it was completely impossible
and we arrived to the fact
that one to one was about --
was what would make it possible.
>> Okay. That's too bad.
>> Ottar Johnsen: Yeah, it is.
>> Thank you.
>> Another question for Ottar?
>> I was surprised to hear
that your depth of field
for the photo was only one
millimeter, because it seems to me
that warped records tend
to be, or can be worked
by much more than one millimeter.
So, if you could explain that.
>> Ottar Johnsen: Yes, our depth
of field is one millimeter,
but simply if it can go to
much higher value simply
than the resolution is lower.
>> So what [inaudible].
>> Ottar Johnsen: Yes, but I
would say I made calculation
with one is more like we have --
I would say the order
of three millimeter.
>> But warped records
which are acetates --
>> Ottar Johnsen: Yeah.
>> -- probably you don't because
of their glass or aluminum backing,
you don't get that huge warpage
where you might get with a vinyl
or a -- because they don't
have that same heat problem,
and so to the extent that you've
been focusing on lacquer discs,
I think this large warpage
probably doesn't come in.
>> Ottar Johnsen: No.
I don't believe so, but Stefano
maybe can answer also about it.
>> The delamination.
>> Is a delamination but --
so that curvature's -- yeah.
But that's not a couple
of millimeters, typically.
>> It is or it can be.
It could be seven millimeters.
But you have to work with
the disc [inaudible].
What I think he's saying is --
>> Carl, give him the mic.
>> I think the warp can actually
get up to seven millimeters
if you include the warp of the
disc base and flaking lacquer.
But if I understand correctly,
if you decrease the
magnification you can continue
to increase the depth of
fields, so if you were willing
to have a lower resolution
image file
and lower resolution audio you
could get a high depth of field
that would allow you to image
a delaminated lacquer disc.
>> Ottar Johnsen: Yeah.
Or we can reduce the --
>> Aperture.
>> Ottar Johnsen: -- the
aperture [inaudible], yes.
Much better.
You don't change the magnification.
You change the aperture,
and that's a good way
to get the bigger depth of field.
>> But then you get
fracture [inaudible].
>> Ottar Johnsen: Yes.
That's what you pay.
That's the price you pay to
get the bigger depth of field.
>> Okay. So are there --
>> Okay, we can move on.
>> We're going to move on.
Okay.
>> Yeah, so we have another talk
about [inaudible] from
Stefano Cavaglieri.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: Okay.
Good morning, everyone and --
well, that of Dr. Johnsen of the,
let's say, scientific
approach to this project
or to this system called
VisualAudio.
Mine will be a very
practical approach
with real day-to-day experience as
we used the system at our facilities
at the Swiss National
Sound Archives.
It has been a long journey
because we started effectively
with this project more
than 15 years ago.
It was in 1999 and I'm happy that we
at least got some tangible results.
But, of course, there are
challenges, still challenges.
There are ups and downs
and there is, of course,
room for further improvements.
The basic idea, as Dr.
Johnsen said, was --
came from the microscopic
observation
of the surface of the disc.
If you look at the
shape of the groove,
it visually represents the acoustic
vibrations which are very close
to the electrical signal
of the recorded sound.
There is plenty of information
available everywhere,
but it requires a very, very high
resolution photography or scanning.
This is just a schematic overview
of the VisualAudio concept.
You're getting familiar
with that, but I'm --
I try to insist on a
couple of important points.
What we do is we actually photograph
the disc and then we scan the film
and then we process the image.
But we've been talking
about photographs
and how does it look like?
It looks like this.
This is an actual photography
shot with the VisualAudio system.
It's a one-to-one ratio.
It means if your record is 25
centimeters in diameter it's going
to be 25 centimeters
on the negative film.
So why, why do we have this
analog photographic step?
Dr. Johnsen already told you about
a couple of important aspects.
To me, having put this system
into a productive environment,
I see those points as
very, very important.
The first one is, well, it's
a quick and reliable way
to freeze the relation of
the surface of the disc.
You just shot a picture.
Even if within the next few
years your disc is degradating --
I mean, it is getting destroyed,
you'll have that frozen image.
We also have a certain depth
of field which is granted
by photographing principles.
We've been mentioning
that earlier on.
We can also think of the picture
as some kind of an analog copy
of the record as it has a very,
very, very high resolution.
If you look at the picture through
a magnifying glass, for example,
you'll see that the
-- it is just perfect.
It's like looking at the
grooves under a microscope.
So it's small, cheap, and stable --
-- while it's still in
the market [laughter].
I'm trying to anticipate
some questions [laughter].
Good. There are some additional
benefits of the analog photography.
Of course the picture is
shot without interfering
with the surface of the disc.
There is no need to
manipulate the disc except
for placing it inside
the photo camera.
We can take pictures of discs
in virtually all conditions --
delaminated, broken, deformed,
and they can later on be read
and hopefully the sound
can be restored.
Each and every disc format -- it
doesn't matter the size, the speed,
the cutting [inaudible] is
read using the same equipment.
On some cases -- well,
under some circumstances,
we even try to get a picture
out of a vertical cut disc,
[inaudible] disc, the
typical [inaudible] disc.
I can tell you that we were
able to look at the groove even
if it's just a 2D system,
a two-dimensional system.
This is because the way
of the groove changes
in function of the depth.
So we were able to extract this
information from a 2D image.
Image processing is
well-established.
It's easy to make corrections to the
physical [inaudible] of the disc.
Again, film is stable, small, cheap
for storing sound information even
if it sounds strange, storing
sound on film [inaudible].
But this means that it
might be implemented or --
this is at least what we do -- as
well as a long-term storage format.
So what we are doing right now, for
example, is we are taking picture
of some thousands of acetate
records because it doesn't take
that much time and it gives us the
possibility while storing these
things in our archives
to process them later on.
So we'll still have time later
on to process this image.
You already saw that picture of
the first generation photo camera.
It was big.
It was huge, not just
big, and heavy.
This is where it is right now.
I guess you can't figure
out where it is.
It is a sound recording
studio in South Africa.
This is the way we got it there.
The funny thing is that our
colleagues at the School
in Engineering in Freeburg had
to cut, literally cut the frame
of the door of the room
where the camera was built
because it couldn't get out.
You can see it here.
Well, you can see we had some
trouble taking the camera
into the studio in South Africa.
Well, it survived and it's there.
It's working.
Nothing's broken.
It's just -- it's a simple
thing, a simple set-up.
Here we'll look at the
-- as for the main parts,
the third generation photo camera.
I'm not showing the second
generation of the photo camera
which is that one that we are using
currently at the sound archives.
This is the third generation
photo camera
which is being built right now.
The first camera will be
delivered in a couple of weeks
in a photographic lab
we've been setting
up in another part of Switzerland.
Being the third one
has the advantages
of having fixed old problems of
the first and the second one.
This one can be transported,
can be just disassembled
and reassembled quite
easily, and it's very,
very, very easy to operate.
Then we have a turntable scanner
which is our kind of turntable
where we put the film
for reading it.
It's still the first generation.
It's the only one existing.
That's probably the weakest part
of the whole chain right now.
So, as I said, practical
VisualAudio.
The workflow.
The workflow is a three-process
or three-step process.
Well, there's the first step
which is the photography.
Photography takes more or less 10
minutes for one side of a disc.
Why does it take 10 minutes?
Because you have to position the
disc, you have to shoot the picture,
and you have to develop the film.
It's an analog film.
You have to develop it.
An automatic developing
machine takes more
or less five minutes
to develop such a film.
Of course, if you have two operators
in the same room you can cut the
time by two because one shoots
and the other develops, and the
other shoots and the other develops.
You can really make it much quicker.
Then we have the film
scanning process.
Film scanning process,
it takes, let's say,
30 minutes per face, or per side.
We have the film positioning.
We have a ring-by-ring scanning
procedure and a merge procedure
in order to acquire the whole
image of the whole surface.
Finally, we have the
image processing and image
to central [inaudible] which can
take up to two-and-a-half hours
where the groove is aligned
and reconstructure [assumed
spelling] the image.
It's transduced to sound
and the emphasis is applied
if necessary and stuff like that.
So the good thing is that the
three processes are independent.
I mean, of course, you can scan
a film if you have the film,
but once you have the photograph
in your hand you can decide
whenever you want to go further on.
They can be carried
out by different people
in different locations
on a different schedule.
The timing as for steps two
and three is just a guide and,
of course, it relies very much
on the shape of the discs.
When I say half-an-hour for scanning
the film and two-and-a-half-hours
for extracting the sound, I mean
if you're processing records
like this one, completely
delaminated,
things that you cannot read
on a conventional turntable --
-- because the -- from my
perspective the main, let's say,
target for such a system
is not to read records
in perfect conditions simply
because the quality is not enough.
It's not good enough,
the sound quality.
Now, let's get more practical.
I have some images and
some sounds for you.
First of all, we've been
talking about rings, okay.
How does a ring look like?
This is --
-- this is in row format.
It's the reason why
I have to -- okay.
So this is the ring.
It's a number of grooves --
-- okay, for one rotation.
So we scan a ring.
Then we can the next ring.
We merge the two rings together,
and so on, up to the end.
This is how it looks
like just after scanning.
While --
-- this is how it looks like --
-- now I'm working with row files.
That's not that easy.
I don't know if you can see the
green and blue lines on the edges.
So there is a green line here, a
blue line here, a green line here,
and another blue line here.
These are the four
edges of the two whirls.
I mean the upper edge, the lower
edge, the lower edge, the upper edge
of the two whirls of the groove,
and these lines are the result
of the first processing
as Dr. Johnsen said.
So this is the, let's say, how
we estimate where the groove is
and how we estimate how
the groove moves laterally.
Then linking the grooves
is not that magic.
You saw these pictures before.
You saw that we can apply an offset
to the image just to tell the system
when you come down here you have
to continue on that one instead
of just continuing straight
on because the two parts,
broken parts of the
record, do not match.
Here you can see it a little
bit better with a wider gap.
But getting some sound
is better, I hope.
So I prepared a couple
of different things.
We didn't try the level
so I just play it now.
[ Static and Music ]
Okay. That was read
with a turntable, hmm.
by applying the emphasis
curve that is necessary
for properly reading this record.
If we do a one-to-one comparison
with what came out of the system
when we got it from
the school, it's this.
[ Static and Music ]
From here I don't know.
I cannot make any judgments because
I don't know if you have enough
of a lower frequencies
and things like that.
But the two files, or the two
sounds, are in a way similar.
I'm not saying they are equal.
Are in a way similar.
If we take another look
at a different version,
which is this one --
[ Static and Music ]
-- we could tell linear
extraction with a turntable.
[ Static and Music ]
Now the linear extraction
with the VisualAudio System.
[ Music ]
We have some audio
engineers here in the room
and I'm quite sure they noticed
that linear doesn't mean linear
when we switch from a turntable
to an optical system, so.
This has different
reasons, but it has also --
it sets some new challenges.
If we want to go into the challenges
and start thinking scientifically,
we may come up with things like why
don't we take a constant amplitude
output, which is this.
[ Music ]
Or a constant velocity output.
Or what happens if we just apply
an RIAA curve, the emphasis curve?
[ Static and Music ]
I've not -- the answer's, well,
I would have some answers for you
but I'm not mentioning my answers.
My main concern here -- and
I saw something similar,
a similar situation yesterday while
visiting the [inaudible] facility
when we had a demonstration
of the --
a very little demonstration of the
IRENE system -- is that when --
looking at those things from
a scientific point of view,
we get a lot of different options.
A lot of different options
which do not mean too much
to an audio engineer, or not always.
An audio engineer is used to -- take
a record, put it on a turntable,
select a speed, select
the correct stylus,
select the correct equalization,
and just do the copy, and that's it.
The end result is absolutely
correct, is --
I mean from an audio engineering
perspective, it's correct.
It's what you want.
With this kind of approach
you have a lot
of different options, as I see it.
You have the theoretical possibility
to reproduce equalization and stuff
like that as it happens in the
traditional electromechanical world.
But the result you got
is not exactly the same.
So, why? Let me take
you to another example.
This one, different
music, a different piece
of music is a very early extraction.
[ Static, Music, and Singing ]
That was done using
the VisualAudio System
at the Engineering
School in Freeburg.
This was just applying -- they
just applied a low-pass filter
at 21 kilohertz here.
The same thing applying a 48
kilohertz low-pass filter is this.
[ Static, Music, and Singing ]
It's a little lower
high end, but it just --
[ Static, Music, and Singing ]
But what makes me uncomfortable --
I should say what makes me sick,
but what makes me uncomfortable is
that the next version is -- I'm --
[ Static, Music, and Singing ]
Do you know what N.R. means?
Noise Reduction.
So this was supposed to be
the noise-reducted version
of the previous extraction
which is not a true -- not true.
Why did that happen is
because -- if I go here --
you can see I have two folders.
One folder is audio as I got it
originally from the scientists
which not always have a
very deep knowledge in audio
or maybe the knowledge, yes, but
not the feeling, the right feeling.
The other version which is -- or
the other folder which is that one
where the files, the
sample files reside now,
is a folder with old
files, loudness normalized,
or I mean not level normalized
but loudness normalized.
I mean just by applying the
EBU-R128, which is the equivalent
of the ITU-1770 here in the States,
which is what makes
the perception more
or less the same of a certain sound.
So if you take the original WAV
files as I got from the school,
they were just -- the noise --
that one with the noise
reduction was just,
had just such a lower level that
you couldn't notice the noise.
But you couldn't notice
the music at the same time.
So we went a little bit further
trying to measure things.
Oops. It was not that one.
It was that one.
So we took a test record.
Standard AS 78 rpm test record.
You can still buy it.
It's still on the market.
We put it on a turntable.
We extracted the 96 kilohertz,
32-bit float file,
and got this result.
>> One thousand.
[ High-Pitched Sound ]
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
That's a lot of kilohertz.
[ High-Pitched Sound ]
Then we did the same
thing with VisualAudio,
and we tried to match the loudness
of the one kilohertz signal.
>> One thousand.
[ Static and High-Pitched Sound ]
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: So I'm
not saying that the system is bad.
I'm just saying that there
is still some work to do,
especially if I look at --
-- at the noise floor, for example.
Noise floor.
So this is the typical noise floor
you can measure out of a turntable.
You can just forget this
little green line here.
There's practically nothing.
This is the same thing used -- yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
This is the same thing
when I measured the output
of the VisualAudio system.
This is the typical noise
floor I get out of the system
without applying any corrections,
any equalization, nothing.
Just linear.
Mm-hmm. Of course this has
also an impact on harmonics.
But somebody said harmonics
are good.
Somebody said harmonics are bad.
But we are used to harmonics
so when you play an instrument you
never get a pure sinus out of it.
You get the main sound
or the main tone,
and you get a lot of
harmonics out of it.
So if we consider harmonics --
I'll go back to that one and
switch back to the one kilohertz.
Sorry for that.
>> One thousand.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
But this time [high-pitched
sound] we'll see [inaudible].
They have a one kilohertz signal,
a two-kilohertz harmonic, a three,
a four which are visible.
This is what comes
out of a turntable.
This is what is -- and
I'm sorry to say it again,
this is what we are expected
to get out of a sound system.
If we look at the same thing here --
>> One thousand.
>> You [high-pitched sound]
could clearly see the one
kilohertz signal.
More or less we can also identify
the two kilohertz harmonics,
still there, see?
But the others are --
[ High-Pitched Sound ]
So.
This is my last slide.
It says, well, maybe we get
-- we get all that noise.
I'm talking as an audio engineer.
My very first background
is as an audio engineer.
I've been working in that field for
more than 30 years doing recordings
and all the stuff of things.
What I see is that,
and maybe I'm wrong,
but I would like that somebody in
the scientific world would be able
to investigate these problems.
Things that bother
me a little bit is
that the current image sampling
frequency, we say it's 64
or 128 kilosamples per ring
while if we think audio we talk
about 44.1, 48- or 9 is six.
How do these things
correlate together?
Do we have an impact
in the audio quality
because the two things do not match?
I don't know.
But I would like to hear
a very solid answer,
not the theoretical
answer, a very solid answer.
On the image, the radial position
of the groove can be estimated
by detecting the edges
of the groove.
Two edges, four edges, that's fine.
On a turntable it is determined
mechanically by the pivot
and the inertia of the arm as well
as the stylus tracking the groove.
It's a different approach.
It gets different results.
Can we measure that?
Can we compensate that?
Can we replicate that?
These are all the questions I have
for my friends in the
scientific world.
Maybe the last one is -- image
processing extracts the position
and affect the amplitude
of the groove while a
stylus gets the velocity.
That was very well
described by Carl Haber.
Is the derivative, which is the
signal, the same for both methods?
If so, can we apply the same
de-emphasis such as the RIAA
or other less-known curves?
I would like an answer.
But not a mathematical
answer, a practical answer.
Something that I can
measure or, even better,
something that I can hear.
Oh, there's another little question.
Is maybe IRENE suitable for
processing our analog pictures?
I was dreaming the other day of
putting my film on an IRENE system
and being capable to read
it using their algorhythms.
What I mean by that is --
-- image or sound processing
by imaging is a very niche
mark, a very tiny market.
To my opinion it really makes sense
if we could just merge the efforts
and to merge the knowledge
and in order to get something,
maybe just one system or two
systems that really take advantage
of all the beauties of the
[inaudible] developed so far.
Therefore, I'm still dreaming.
I'm dreaming a lot.
But sometimes I also
get to the point.
I'm dreaming of setting up some
sort of a center of excellence.
For example, in Switzerland,
having the two systems,
IRENE and VisualAudio,
sitting together
and somebody every day using the
two systems and other people coming
in to do some more research
and development in order to try
to achieve better results.
So I hope that will come true
sometimes, but, well -- Good.
That was it.
Thank you very much for listening.
[ Applause ]
>> Is grooved media
still being produced
or is there new stuff
being produced or is the --
I think this is a trivial
question but I assume the body
of grooved objects out
there is finite, right?
It's now growing anymore.
Is that true?
>> Carl Haber: I definitely
think that it's finite.
Certainly vinyl has
had a resurgence.
My 15-year-old now wants only
to buy [laughter] vinyl discs.
But the target for these
technologies I don't believe is the
new emerging vinyl market.
It's the finite historical archive
beginning in the 19th century
and probably ending somewhere in
the middle of the 20th century.
>> Thank you.
Stefano, to address the
last point that you made,
there will be a proposal made --
there's a group of scientists that
are having a conference in Padua,
Italy on September 17th, and the
proposal will address the issue
of trying to bring together
the scientific communities
and taking advantage of the fact
that we don't always have to be
in Washington or Berlin or San
Francisco, but to take advantage
of the technology that
exists in a virtual sense.
Why can't there be global exchange
of information using something
as simple as Skype, and how you
integrate the different communities
in that manner.
For example, in a university
environment you may have an archive
and the archive is a
certain amount of expertise,
but the Engineering Departments,
as your example proves,
how do you leverage your
needs with the expertise
that are in the universities?
Or how do you work in New York City
in an archive and find out, gee,
I'd like to work with
the Swiss archive
and use social media
in that technology.
I think you could facilitate exactly
what you're asking for tremendously.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
Yeah, thank you very much for that.
I think this is a good
approach, yeah, yeah.
>> Hi. I'm Jenny Doctor from
the Balfour Audio Archive
at Syracuse University.
I just want to say I think you're
asking really good question,
and I really like the fact
that you're saying that we need
to use the audio engineer
expertise in conjunction
with the scientific genius that
has been bringing together --
sorry, I was using the
genius a word kind of a --
but the point is that there's
been a huge amount of approach
that has come from the
scientific side and I think
that there are decades' worth
of expertise that does come
from the audio engineer
side that has to do
with how the stylus does
fit in the groove, how --
whether you do go right down to
the bottom of the groove or not,
whether some of the noise may
be coming from that issue,
and whether maybe the edges
-- I don't know enough.
I'm not a technician.
But I wonder if some
of the noise problem is
because it is targeting the bottom
of the groove and that is a problem.
So I hand that over to
some of the audio engineers
who can answer that more.
But I know that that when we
were talking to the engineer
at Syracuse University who
was doing the laser project
that Carl mentioned earlier, and he,
for the first time, 10 years later,
talked to our audio engineer
about why that project failed.
He hadn't never realized that he
should not be directing the laser
at the bottom of the groove.
He should have actually been
directing it to the wall higher up.
So that was a huge
revelation to him.
But he hadn't bothered to talk to
the audio engineer to find that out.
So I just -- I don't know about
why some of the noise is coming in,
but I do wonder if maybe -- if the
edges going right to the bottom
of the groove, if it
was slightly higher up,
I don't know if you
would get better results.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: Well,
in our case it's a
little bit different
because we are not just
measuring what happens
at the bottom of the groove.
As I mentioned, we are trying to
figure out, or to set an average
between different reference points.
But the different reference points
are either the top or the bottom,
never in the middle, while,
when you use a stylus,
you read up on the groove.
It's never going to be on
the top or on the bottom.
That's probably one of
the major issues, yeah.
>> Yeah, that [inaudible].
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: Yeah.
>> Carl Haber: So,
Stefano, you put up a bunch
of questions just before
your last slide,
and I was thinking maybe we
could try to address some
of those questions since
they were questions.
Is that okay?
>> Sure.
>> Carl Haber: So some way
we could put them back up?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Carl Haber: Okay.
So let me turn this mic
and see if [inaudible].
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: Okay.
So we can see it [inaudible].
>> It's all [inaudible].
>> Carl Haber: Okay.
So one of your questions was
that the current image sampling
frequency is some tens of thousands
through hundreds of
thousands of samples per ring,
while standard audio sampling
frequencies are 96, 48, whatever.
How do the different
figures correlate
and what is the impact
on the audio quality?
So, I would like to
say, I think the answer
to that question is
very straightforward.
You have a disc.
Let's say it's 78 rpm.
That means it takes some .7 seconds
approximately to go around once.
If you take a certain number of
optical samples around the disc
by a simple ratio involving that .7,
it translates into the
equivalent audio sampling.
So I happen to remember in
my head that for a 78 rpm
if you take 80,000 optical
samples that is 104 kilohertz.
So every single number
exactly correlates
to an equivalent audio sampling.
So 96 kilohertz would
correspond to something less than,
a little bit less than
80,000 for a 78.
If it's a 45, it's going
to be a different thing.
But there's a completely
well-defined clear correlation.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
Yeah, but my question is maybe more
to him, is why while reading
the image these two numbers do
not match?
I mean, the reading or the
producing of the, let's say, images,
image samples or just straight
lines, is not the same number
as the final number
of audio samples.
I mean, for one second, for
example, for one second of audio
with the VisualAudio System, you
will not take 96,000 pictures.
You will take 120,000 --
>> Carl Haber: Right.
But that's because --
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
-- or 80,000.
>> Carl Haber: But that's because
the record is, for example, at 78.
Suppose the record
was at 60 rpm, okay?
Then it would be one
second per revolution.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
Mm-hmm.
>> Carl Haber: Then to get
96 kilohertz audio sampling,
you would take 96,000 pictures.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: Yeah.
>> Carl Haber: But because you're
at 78, it's just a different number.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: No.
But if you change the rotation
speed, it doesn't matter.
>> Ottar Johnsen: Yeah.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
Because the rotation speed
of the scanner's changing
in our case.
>> Carl Haber: It just matters
when you trigger the camera.
Ottar, you --
>> Ottar Johnsen: Yes.
I believe it is related to the
problem of sampling rate conversion.
When you have digital sound,
when you change a sampling ratio,
you have to do a mathematically
operation,
and were it were done first was
when converting 44.1 kilohertz
sound record sampling frequency
to 48 kilohertz sampling frequency.
An example.
I'm going from 44.1 to 48,
is that if you do it professionally
you can't hear any difference
of the record at 44.1 compared to
48 kilohertz sampling frequency.
As long as it is the right
way that you have no problem
with sampling [inaudible].
In my opinion, that is
also the case when you look
at the VisualAudio System or IRENE.
We have a sample rate conversion
and sampling rate conversion
is nearly perfect.
You can get as perfect as you want.
Simply you have to increase the
length of your digital filter
that does the sampling
rate conversion.
>> Carl Haber: But you can run any
of these systems if you want exactly
at the sampling rate so you
don't have to do any conversion.
You could choose to digitize
96,000 native, or you could choose,
for various historical purposes,
IRENE runs at 104 kilohertz,
and then we, if we want, we can
down-sample to 96 or to 48 or to 41.
But you could set it up to digitize
exactly at the audio if you want to.
I'm sure you can do this.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: I
wish we could with VisualAudio.
>> Carl Haber: Okay.
But there's no fundamental
reason why you can't.
>> Ottar Johnsen: Beside we
have phase lock [inaudible] --
>> Carl Haber: Okay.
>> Ottar Johnsen: -- and
[inaudible] making it difficult.
>> Carl Haber: But you could do it.
Okay. So, let's go to
the second question.
Okay. So on an image,
the radial position
of the groove can be estimated by
detecting the edges of the groove
on some number of points.
On the turntable it is determined
mechanically by the pivot
and the inertia of the arm as
well as the stylus tracking.
So where's the question?
You --
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
It's not really a question.
It's just a [inaudible] two
different ways to determine
where your groove is and how it
moves from one way to the other.
The point is, using the optical
systems, you have no, let's say,
no mechanical impact that
is, on a standard turntable,
is designed to produce
a certain result.
You remove that while reading
that -- while reading the image.
>> Carl Haber: Right.
So I think what you're saying is
that the mechanical
dynamical response --
I use the word dynamics in a
physics/engineering context,
not in the way audio maybe
uses a dynamic range.
In a physics dynamical sense,
you don't have the compliance
of the mechanical components --
the tone arm, the stylus, the mass.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
Exactly.
>> Carl Haber: -- the
natural [inaudible].
So these are all parts of a physical
system which, together, conspire,
hopefully, to give you good results.
There are many examples in the
literature of problems associated,
resonances and distortions that
people have worked for years
and years in perfecting mechanical
playback systems to minimize.
Right. Those effects are not
present in an optical scanning
and VisualAudio or IRENE.
All you're doing is you're
measuring the shape of the groove.
Mathematically, the sound
should just be the derivative
of that shape.
When you take the derivative
of that data,
it is a absolutely
mathematically flat infrequency.
I think when you were using the
term linear transfer you mean a
flat transfer.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: Yeah.
>> Carl Haber: It's
a completely flat.
In the ideal world the cartridge
would simply take that derivative
by the fact that it's a
velocity between the magnet
and the coil inside
creates the voltage
that gets measured, and
that's what you get.
If you want to add the flavor
or the aesthetic, if you like,
of a mechanical system, that's
called physical modeling,
and you can develop that.
But it's not there.
It's not there.
Then it becomes a question
of aesthetics, right?
Do you want that ambiance, because
you're not going to have that.
It's just going to measure
the information that's
on the disc or the cylinder.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: Yeah.
I understand that perfectly.
I understand that.
This is actually my problem.
I mean, because also the -- when the
groove has been cut into the disc,
it has been done with
mechanical means.
>> Carl Haber: Yes.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: It
hasn't been done in an ideal world.
>> Carl Haber: But a different
mechanical system cut it --
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: Yeah.
>> Carl Haber: -- then
you're using to play it back.
The mechanical system in
Indiana, and the mechanical system
in California, and the
one in Switzerland,
they could all be different.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
Mm-hmm.
>> Carl Haber: So in some sense some
people might argue that it's good
that you've removed one set of
variables from the playback process
which is the mechanical response.
Now you raised the
question about noise,
and you very dramatically
showed these high noise levels
that you're seeing.
So I was thinking I would
like to address that also
because I think it's
part of your question.
So when people use the term noise it
refers to a whole variety of things.
So if you have sharp defects
-- click, click, click,
okay -- people call that noise.
If you have a very broadband
like the hiss that you
so strongly showed the
[hissing sound], okay,
they also refer to that as noise.
But those are very different
things, and they all get stuck
in the same category
and called noise.
What you were dominantly
experiencing or sharing with us
in the thing was this
very, very broadband noise.
It was very clear when you
showed the noise spectrum
that at some point around a
kilohertz or something it started
to rise and it rose sort
of in a straight line,
and it was much less prominent
when you, for example,
in the test record, when you
played it back with a stylus
than when you did with the
VisualAudio System, okay?
That noise is due to a --
just a structure that exists
in a random way throughout
the data, okay?
It can be due to perhaps
the film grain;
it can be due to the
roughness of the surface;
region of the groove
that IRENE or VisualAudio resolves.
But it's a general structure
of the surface as rendered
through the imaging which
gets worse and worse as you go
to higher and higher frequencies.
Because you're taking
a derivative you are --
a derivative is a high-pass
filter so you're pushing
up those high frequencies which
you should be doing, okay?
But you should apply the RIAA curve
or whatever the corresponding curve
is for the older materials which is,
in fact, designed as part
of the standard process
to partially roll off
those high frequencies.
It does it for the stylus.
It does it -- and it should be
applied in these visual as well.
I don't know if you
were applying it.
It didn't look like
you were applying it
because I would have
seen it turn over.
But it definitely should be
applied because it's part
of the way the record was recorded.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
Well, yes, of course.
I thank you for this explanation,
but it doesn't really answer my
questions because we are well aware
of the fact that we have to
apply compensation curves.
The problem is not there
because the compensation curve
in this case removes, in our
case, removes everything.
Removes the signal as well.
The signal to noise ratio,
especially in the higher
frequencies is that low
that you can't remove the noise
without removing what's
embedded into the noise.
>> Carl Haber: Sure.
Once it's below the noise,
if you put a curve on it,
you're not getting it back.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: Yeah.
But the two noise floor I showed
were obtained using the same
equalization curve.
One from the turntable and the
other one from the [inaudible].
>> Carl Haber: Okay, okay.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
So it was already in.
>> Carl Haber: Okay.
>> Okay. We should let
people get to lunch
because we need to
be back here at 1:30.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri: Okay.
>> Carl Haber: So.
>> Thanks.
>> Stefano Sergio Cavaglieri:
Thank you [applause].
>> Okay. Good afternoon everybody.
The first session after lunch
is always the worst one to have.
That's when -- especially
if you've had a large lunch
and you're beginning to fall asleep.
So I'm going to try and liven
this up a bit with some,
hopefully some interesting
material for you.
What I should say here
as an introduction.
I'm an engineer.
I've only dabbled in this
area for around five years.
The project I'm going to talk to you
about here actually
concluded around 2010.
I'm going to give you a bit
of an update as we go through,
but it was just a piece of
work I did from my main job.
So I'm a research scientist.
I work primarily on structured
surfaces, on surfaces, and,
of course, recordings
are structured surfaces.
Structured surfaces are really a
big area of research at the moment
for all kinds of things -- flights,
ships in water, everything, yeah?
So this is just kind
of a side road for me.
But I hope you find some of
the work we did interesting.
There's a bit of a
history behind this.
Let me just get my notes here.
Can I have the first slide?
Do I do that?
Yeah, okay, all right, okay.
So I'm just going to give you
an introduction and overview,
and probably just focus
on the case studies.
Actually, Carl here has done me
a great favor and Ottar as well.
You covered most of
the technical aspects.
So I'm kind of going to leave that.
I've got a lot of slides here
which I didn't really know
what I was going to say today,
so I'm probably going to jump quite
a few of these slides and just go
into the interesting stuff.
I'll probably focus on some of
the recordings we looked at,
particularly the Queen Victoria
and the tinfoil recording,
and maybe the Berliner disc as well,
but we'll come to those shortly.
Before that I think the next one is
a video which I hope is new to you.
One of my PhD students
found this on YouTube.
I hope you like it.
>> So this is a one-of-a-kind piece.
There's no other one like this
particular one in the world,
and you can see the
tracks go this way.
It's really cool because it
records much more accurately
[breaking sounds].
Oh, shit [laughter].
Oh, my god.
>> So that does happen
every once in a while.
That can't be good.
Now are you done with that?
>> Yeah, I'm done with that.
>> All right.
Apparently we're [laughter]
really done with that one.
>> So some of you have seen that I
guess, but if you haven't seen it,
I think it's on YouTube,
and it's worth it.
That's the way to damage a cylinder
recording I guess [laughter].
Here's another one actually
which I'm not going to play,
but Carl would probably
would be interested in this.
This is the Radio 4 Today program.
It's the most serious radio program
in the U.K. It's early
in the morning.
You get presidents, prime ministers.
It's really serious.
This lady here is one of the serious
people who present the program.
I think about five years ago
she was giving a talk on --
it was a very small slot on one
of the early sound recordings,
and I think it was one
of the [inaudible] ones,
and she gave the one-minute
slot on this piece of news
that somebody had managed
to decode this recording
from 1850 or something.
The guy in the headphones said,
"It sounds like a bee
in a bottle," yeah?
She burst into laughter.
She then could not stop laughing.
She had a giggle fit which
actually went on to the next part
of the program which
was an obituary.
So she's reading an obituary of
some famous person who passed away,
laughing as a result of this.
So if you want to find it.
Carl, you'll probably be
-- would be interested
in hearing that [inaudible].
>> Carl Haber: I've heard it.
>> Oh, you heard it.
It's good.
Okay. I'll come back to
more technical subjects.
So probably I can miss this.
This is really just saying that what
we're trying to do with this piece
of research is not
real-time playback.
This slide was for general audience
so I'm going to skip most of this.
It really describes what Carl
said in the first presentation.
Let's just move on.
Okay. I'll jump this one.
There is a website which we still
have active, actually, which,
if you get the slides later on, we
should be able to log onto this.
All of the material that I'm
going to show you is actually
on this website so you can look
at this in your own measure.
I think the key thing is
archivesound, one word.
If you Google that you
should come to this website.
Okay. Let's move on.
So, as part of the project, we
published quite a few publications.
These are primarily in the
scientific literature domain.
So those of you who are maybe
engineers or scientists,
a lot of this work
is easily available.
It's downloadable.
So a lot of the technical
content is published.
I won't bore you with the details of
these but I'll maybe make reference
to a couple of these
papers as we go along.
All right.
You've seen this.
This is the measurement method.
Carl explained this
earlier this morning.
I'll probably say a few words
about some of our systems.
This particular system
is very similar, I guess,
to what you call IRENE, which is a
white light sensor with a cylinder.
This has got a cylinder on here.
I can't see it very
well on the screen here.
I hope you can see
it on your screens.
There's a cylinder
here being scanned.
These are really important
so X is a long cylinder.
Obviously theta is the
rotation of the cylinder.
And zed is the height position,
so we're actually measuring
as we scan along the
length of the cylinder here,
we're measuring the zed
height, Z, sorry, Z heights,
as a function of X. Then you rotate
and then you do the next scan.
From that you essentially are
creating a three-dimensional
representation of the object.
Let's just move on.
Another system -- I'll have
a movie of this system later.
This is a flatbed scanner.
It's an air bearing which is
a high-end piece of equipment
for actually manufacturing
silicon wafers.
But what we do with this
is you can see on here.
Probably this is a 78
I guess with a laser.
Again you've got the
theta, the rotation.
X and Y now you've got Cartesian
coordinates with a Z height.
Okay?
I'm just going to pick up on a
few of the aspects which we kind
of discussed a few times from
the presentations this morning.
Something about resolution.
Maybe resolution is the
main one we should focus
on because this is taken
from one of our papers.
The reference is there.
I hope you find this is interesting.
This graph is essentially
the physical displacement
of a cylinder surface
measured in nanometers, okay,
against the frequency
response of a spoken word.
Now if you talk to people who
are experts on spoken word,
the harmonics -- here you
got the main sound here
which is around 600 hertz.
These are harmonics, the peaks
that are come afterwards,
so the harmonics.
Here you see a harmonic
around, what, 3000 kilohertz?
If you look at the amplitude of this
harmonic it's around 50 nanometers.
Now this is a recording
from the early 1900s.
It was a cylinder recording.
What we've determined from this
is that actually, if you're going
to measure these surfaces and get a
good audio record from the surface,
you really need to be measuring
to this type of resolution.
So we published this.
I think, 500 nanometers
was the value
that we suggested from this work.
It's to do with the
spoken word and the way
in which the ear interprets
the spoken word
that these high frequencies, these
harmonics, are really important.
Let's move on.
One of the other issues we haven't
seen mentioned this morning is the
optical sensors that
we use are not perfect.
In fact, they have
some major limitations,
and one of the limitations is
demonstrated very easily here
from a 78 disc where as we saw again
this morning the side wall here is
like 45 degrees.
Actually, it's very
difficult to get light back
from a surface that steep.
What you see is you get a lot
of [inaudible] basically
on the side walls.
Now, from what Ottar
presented in his presentation,
this probably isn't that
important because actually
if you can detect the edge
you can get the sound actually
from these edge points and
also from these points here.
We have an example of that later.
I'm going to jump this.
This is a signal extraction.
This is really a whole
area in itself.
I could talk to you for an hour
just on this, how you do this.
In the simple sense it's
actually what we said all along,
all the way through this conference.
Basically, you're getting a
three-dimensional representation
of the surface.
Then the secret is
to find the groove,
and there are many,
many ways of doing that.
You're really entering the realm
of signal processing and anybody
who knows anything about signal
processing, it's endless,
the possibilities are you can use.
The one that we tended to
focus on is one particular.
So the dark line on here is a cross
section of a groove structure.
I think you can see
it's damaged, yeah?
The bottom of the groove here
has quite a strange base.
It's not curved.
You can see if you just try
to find the minimum points
as a representation
of the sound on this,
the minimum point is
actually going to be noise.
It's actually a damage
to the surface.
So, actually, what we were
doing here was putting a filter,
a particular filter, to the surface
and getting the minimum
points of the filter.
Again, there are endless filters
that you could use for doing this,
but having got -- the key thing
is you have the raw data here,
the solid line, is accurately
as you can get the data.
Okay. So that's really all I'm going
to say about the technical aspects.
I could talk -- as I said, if
you have any questions I can go
into all the details if you want.
What I'd like to do is
just focus on some of these
which I hope you find interesting.
I'm going to jump the first one and
not bother with that, and just focus
on -- There's lots of cylinders
that we've scanned as
part of this project.
They're all available on
the website so if you want
to listen to them you can.
"Just Before the Battle, Mother" is,
I think, the first one we did, Carl.
That was a collaboration
with Carl Haber
and with Bill, the
cylinder supplied.
So that was -- we did that probably
2005 I guess, something like that.
So there are lots of
other examples on here.
Now this is quite interesting.
We saw this partly this morning.
We actually found an
unusual character
in the U.K. who made test cylinders.
This is one of the
cylinders that he made for us.
So these have fixed frequency
sounds embedded in the grooves
so that we could do a way
of testing the quality
of our sound reproduction
from these scanning methods.
I think you can just
about see that if you look
across the cylinder here.
You can probably just visually see.
I haven't got it very clearly
on this monitor but -- yeah.
But on here I think you can just
about see the different regions.
Then we've scanned the cylinder
and what I'm going to show you.
This just jumps over -- here's a
groove structure from the cylinder.
Let's just jump on.
This is just some of the same.
So I'll just take one example here.
If we look at the one -- we'll
just do one kilohertz, yeah?
I'll play the stylus first.
So this is a stylus playback
of the cylinder we had made.
Oop. Let's try that again.
[ High-Pitched Sound ]
What do you hear?
Can you hear a single frequency?
>> It's modulating.
Yeah. There's some variation.
Let's listen to the optical.
The same frequency.
I'm sorry there.
[ High-Pitched Sound ]
We've written a paper on this.
So one of the publications
-- I think it's JASA,
the Journal of the American
Acoustical Society .
It's one of the top acoustic
journals in the work.
There's a paper published
on this work.
So we created the artifact so
that we could test the quality
of the methods that we were using,
and actually from this work we
actually determined some quality
parameters that you could
use in actually in going back
to the measurement and the way
in which we process the
surfaces afterwards.
Now I could go through all
of these but let's just jump
on [high-pitched sounds].
Oh, sorry [laughter].
Okay. So these are frequency
analysis diagrams of the same data.
If you aren't used to seeing this
type of stuff, this is the one
that we've just been looking at.
I think the one kilohertz
around here.
So you've got the stylus scan.
So this frequency here, where the
arrow is pointing, is one kilohertz.
Then you got the harmonics which
is probably the same variation
that you were hearing.
If you compare that to the
optical, there's more noise on here.
You can see slightly more noise,
but the primary sinusoidal
signal is well-represented here.
As I said, you could
read the technical papers
on these if you want.
This is one that is
really interesting.
I have quite a few
slides on this one.
So this was scanned -- I hope you
can imagine Queen Victoria's quite
an important character.
It is for the British [laughter] so.
There was a book, I think, written
around the recording of her voice.
But at the time it
wasn't sure if it was a --
it hadn't been authenticated.
I'm going to show you
some evidence later
about the authenticity of this.
So this scanned at the Science
Museum in London back in 2005.
I just really want to focus on
-- oh, there's the cylinder.
This is a Graphophone cylinder.
I think you can see three bands.
One here on the left, one in the
middle, one on the far right.
I hope you can see from here -- I
don't have it very clearly on here,
but I know the slide pretty well.
You can see the groove structure.
Yeah. What you can also see is
this artifact on the top here.
You can guess what that is.
That's a stylus, yeah?
So, essentially, what
has happened --
this artifact has obviously been
deemed to have been important.
It was in the vault of the
Science Museum in a huge safe.
I think probably at some stage
in its history had been played,
probably played with the wrong
stylus, with the wrong force.
What it has done is
essentially damaged the bottom
of the groove here -- though that
was our interpretation of that.
Okay. Let's just move on.
Let's see the consequence of that.
Well, this is the consequence,
really.
So this is a cross-section
from the data.
This would be the top
surface here of the cylinder.
These are the grooves.
You can see -- I think
what you can see here.
This may have been done in
the distant past, in fact,
because it looks like a piece
of wire has been used
to try to play this.
I think, Bill, you were
saying that wire, piano wire,
was one of the early
styluses that was --
>> Steel wire.
>> Steel chisels [inaudible].
>> Yeah? You can see what this is.
You see this repeated shape on the
bottom of the grooves essentially
like a piece of wire
that's been cut.
What that's done is it's
essentially removed, of course,
some of the key content
of the material here.
But that's one of the great things
about doing three-dimensional
scanning.
If you look at the -- yeah,
it's a virtual stylus.
That's what's been removed.
But if you look to the left and
right of that -- let's just go back.
Okay. This should be
-- okay, here you go.
So you got the left-hand side,
the right-hand side,
stylus in the middle.
But you got this whole region to the
left and right of the virtual stylus
which is essentially where the
sound would have been carried.
Because this is all in the digital
domain, we've scanned the surface.
We can then actually just use --
decide where we run the tracking
for this to get the
sound from the groove.
It was quite damaged so we don't --
we're not going to hear anything.
But you'll hear -- I'll play
you something and you can judge.
So this is pretty much what
we saw this morning as well.
We were using -- if you want a
binary indication of the surface.
So the red is the left side;
the right is the blue side.
There's the green is
the track of the stylus.
Then all we're going to do is we're
going to move that to the left
and just track to the left.
Okay. So let's listen to something.
I'll actually go straight
to the end.
I won't go into the
complexities of this, but.
I've kind of kept this secret.
I played it a few times in the
U.K. at some archive conferences.
But we've never released this, so --
and it's certainly never been
played outside of the U.K. Let me --
listen to it first and
then we'll go to the words.
[ Static and Inaudible Speakers ]
Okay. So what we're trying
to do here is just interpret
what we think is being said.
So, "greetings" is
quite clearly stated.
We can hear spoken word but we
can't hear what's being said.
The answer is very
clear, and it's said
with a very high-class
British accent.
"Can be" is also clear.
This we're unsure of.
Lord Granville, I think,
was the Prime Minister.
I have to go look in
my history books.
"Absolutely" is very
clear, and "has never" --
"has never forgotten" is also clear.
Let's play it again.
[ Static and Inaudible Speakers ]
Okay? Could you --
[applause] thank you.
There was some uncertainty
about who's speaking, yeah?
Actually, the book
that was published
on this left the question open.
But then, since the
book was published,
and I think that should be
my next slide -- yeah, here.
This is a letter -- I wrote
to the Royal Archives.
This is April, 2007.
I've just highlighted part of this
text here which is the next bit.
So the first bit in yellow is
referring to [inaudible] book.
It's talking about a letter from
the Queen's Private Secretary,
Henry Ponsonby's wife, Mary,
which came into the archive
after the book had been published.
Essentially this is the
key bit on the bottom here.
"HM," Her Majesty, "spoke into it."
So this was on the letter from
Henry Ponsonby to his wife,
so we know that she
spoke into this device.
I think if I, I may get
the dates wrong sometime --
here we are, 29th of August, 1888.
So we know that she spoke into this.
Actually she said she
didn't want to --
I think what she said is she
didn't want to -- yeah, here we go.
"But we told Mr. Morse he must not
go round the country producing the
Queen's words" [laughter].
So, very early piece of
history on sound recordings.
I think, actually, the
machine was a Graphophone.
It was one of the artifacts we saw
in the museum yesterday,
at the Smithsonian.
It was taken to the U.K. from the
U.S. and then taken to the Queen's
which I think her and her
husband were keen advocates
of the new technology.
Okay. So a bit of history.
This is another particular
piece of history if you're Welsh
or if you got Welsh ancestry.
I don't know who this person was.
I have to go back and remind myself.
But this came from the
Welsh National Archives,
and essentially this was Edmond
Roberts who was a preacher, 1905.
But the artifact had been broken
so it wasn't the one that was
in the movie that we
saw at the beginning.
But this is the casing that held the
artifacts of the broken cylinder.
This was held in the museum
in Cardiff I guess, in Wales.
It was sent to a dentistry
expert in Los Angeles
who did restorative dentistry, yeah?
This is what came back.
This is before we got involved.
So this is actually what
we were presented with.
Again, I can't see this
very clear on here,
but I know the image pretty well.
I think what you can see is areas
of filling, essentially, from the --
and you can see -- I think
you can see the damage
and I think you can
see regions of growth,
mold growth, around the cylinder.
But, again, with this type
of artifact we're able
to basically -- ah, here.
That's a better picture.
We're basically able to --
like we saw with the previous
presentations this morning,
we've got part of the
groove structure
and then we can do interpretation.
But there's no groove
here but we can then --
we can add the time
period in as a blank,
and that should get the sound.
Ah, here's a good example.
So here you can see --
it's getting trajectories.
So the blue line would
be the conventional line,
and then you can see -- this
is the broken surface here.
Then we've just changed the
trajectory of the stylus.
You can see where these things --
I can't see it very well on here,
but I think you can,
hopefully you can see
to the left you can see the
structures basically follow.
The green line becomes
the retro slice.
So this is a great advantage
with this technology,
that you can use software
techniques,
basically, to interpret the data.
Let's just play one of these.
I'll do -- this is "Opticum."
[ Static and Singing ]
So that's a -- I think
I recognize that.
I think that's a -- it's a
song I think which used to be
like a church song, for
those in peril on the sea.
So that's recognizable.
This is the stylus.
[ Static and Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Maybe I should have
played this one --
[ Static and Singing ]
So at the time we were doing this
project it was quite frustrating
because we developed the technology.
But everybody who came
to us came to us
with an impossible sample
to measure [laughter].
So this was an example of
something that was really difficult
like the Queen Victoria
recording on this one.
Then we represented -- oop.
Let me jump to this.
Tinfoil recordings came our way.
This is the U.K.s oldest recording,
so it's an Edison tinfoil,
and we were presented with this
to see if we could scan this.
Because we did that, actually
the sound from this --
I don't know how -- I
think I have it here.
But because we'd done this piece
of work we were then contacted
by the Norwegian Archive.
I don't read Norwegian.
>> I can.
>> Can you read it?
>> [Inaudible] I can.
Oh.
>> It's 1879.
I can read that [laughter].
>> So [inaudible] any old
[inaudible] is sort of flat
on our -- the first
phonograph has been --
-- has been [inaudible]
-- has been recorded
over an Edison phonograph in Norway.
>> It's handwriting
which is the [inaudible].
Okay. We have the date.
>> Okay.
>> So 1879.
This was quite interesting.
Let's play -- I think I
have this one [static].
Oh, this is the [inaudible], sorry.
This is the U.K. one which
is the Edison [inaudible]
from the British Library.
This is -- I think this is on an
exhibition in the British Library
in London, and actually the same
from this is also at
the British Library.
Okay. So you can see how that works.
This piece of equipment
is an air bearing.
I don't -- five minutes, okay.
That's fine.
A very expensive piece of
equipment, but it's basically used
for silicon manufacturing.
It gives you a very flat surface,
very high speed, and it's that type
of technology we were using
for doing these [inaudible].
I think -- oh, this is one --
actually I was presented with
in the U.S. This was from --
it don't show -- I can see
it very clearly on here.
We didn't do this one because
it was so badly damaged.
This is held in a museum,
I think, in New York.
>> Schenectady.
>> Yeah, yeah.
New York State.
It's very damaged.
I don't know if you had seen this,
but they were asking [inaudible].
>> We did it.
>> You did it.
Okay. All right.
Did you manage to get the sound?
>> Yeah.
>> Ah, okay.
That's great.
Because we looked at it and thought,
gosh, this looks too bad [laughter].
So this is the Edison
recording, 1877.
Badly folded and ripped.
Again, the sound is on the website.
This is the Norwegian one.
[ Static and Music ]
So I think it's somebody
playing a Norwegian horn.
>> That's great.
>> Yeah? Is that right?
So this was presented at an
Archive Conference in Oslo
at the end of this project.
I think it's in the Science Museum
in Oslo, yeah, with the sound.
I'll play it once again.
[ Static and Music ]
But this particular artifact was
in very good condition
compared to the British one.
>> Okay. I'm just going to
come towards the end here.
I'm going to jump the 78 disc
and just go on to the Berliner.
So the EMI Archive is right next
to Heathrow Airport in London.
They have a museum which
is not open to the public.
It has some of the most incredible
artifacts I think I've ever seen
just lying around this room.
Some of you may have seen it.
It's just incredible.
Everywhere you looked there was
some incredible piece of history
from sound recording, and it
was just in this vault, yeah?
They gave me this to play
with which is a Berliner.
I think this is one of the
earliest examples they had.
I'm not quite sure
the history of this.
I was looking online just to
remind myself where this came from.
But this was a metallic master used
for printing probably on rubber.
We actually scanned it.
We never actually got around to
finishing this piece of work off
so we have the surface and
we just haven't really got
around to finishing it.
But I just wanted to show
that to you as an example.
I'm just going to finish with -- I
should say thank you actually to all
of the people who have
helped me with this.
There were too many people to
mention but one of my PhD students,
Anthony, who did his PhD in this,
went on to work in
the film industry.
So he did a PhD with me on early
sound recordings in engineering.
He now works for a software
company in London doing CGI, yeah?
He sent this to me, this
movie, which I like.
[ Music and Singing ]
Okay. So what he's done
is he's taken raw data
from a scanned surface,
put it into CGI software,
and recreated the surface.
So you could fly through
this surface.
You could do whatever you
want on a movie with this.
You could actually follow
the grooves or whatever.
So he just sent this
to me as an example.
Just actually by coincidence,
I said, "Ah, I got to go
and present something,"
and he sent me this.
I thought you'd like to see it.
I really like it.
What it says is something about
the future of what we could do
with some of this scan technology.
This is maybe trivial, but it could
be something that would be good
in a museum as a demonstration
of what these things are.
This data's raw data.
He just created it as a
movie as part of a CGI.
I can't remember the
name of the company,
but it's quite a well-known
CGI company in London.
He's probably working
on the next Batman movie
or James Bond or something.
I think that's it.
I hope you've enjoyed it.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Let's take a moment and --
[ Inaudible Conversation ]
Did I get close?
>> That's looking very --
>> So --
>> Thank you.
>> I think it's going to --
>> It's nice to be
here at the conference.
I want to thank the
organizer for this conference
at the Library of Congress.
It has been very interesting
days for me,
and to participate
in the conference.
I also made some other visits
here in Washington, D.C. I've been
up in Boston and Andover seeing
the IRENE technical operate.
It was very interesting.
Also been in the National Archive
and seeing how they
have been working there,
and yesterday in the Culpeper.
It was very interesting to be there
also, and heard the discussions
about all the preservations
problem they have,
as we also have in our archive.
There are many things to
go on with together I think
to manage all these problems.
This is the new possibility to make
imaging of analog mechanical records
and we have just started
-- just started, we are --
just finished it in the
end of August this year.
I will have a short
presentation on how we have worked
and what the results
so far have been done.
Yes. I'm going to do a brief
presentations of the innovations
and development projects
started at the National Library
of Sweden even called KB.
It's a [foreign words].
The project is an innovation
procurement, PCP,
entitled "Developmental
[inaudible] Playback
of Analog Records to
Digital Sound Files."
About myself and my background.
I've been working at many different
types of media and carriers, film,
sound, video, and I started
early '70, in the early '70s.
I have some experience
about these fields,
and preservations of these things.
I have also a big interest
in technical developments
in all different fields, and
this project is one of these.
Let's see.
Yeah. Here we are.
We have in the archive in KB, and
I will show you how it all started.
We have a total amount of
about 146,000 Swedish records,
and of these there are 80,000 78s
and 60,000 vinyl records EP, Single,
LPs, and so, and about
6000 lacquer discs.
We are doing some cooperation
with the Swedish Radio
and they have 285,000 records and
they also have [inaudible] records.
Depending on our extensive
archive or records we want
to investigate whether
it's possible to find ways
to transfer these [inaudible]
in real-time
and examine the sound
quality that can be achieved.
It all started when we was
contacted with a company
that showed a demonstrations of
optical playback of a 78 record.
It was surprisingly good quality.
The technical development
for image scanning used
by this company was taken
directly from the shelf
and had not been optimized
for applications we requested.
We had discussions with the company
and described our needs to be able
to transfer the disc
[inaudible] in real-time
and at the best possible
sound quality.
They also indicated that
image scanning operations
and transfers could be fostered in
normal playback and possibilities
to edit and optically
clean the discs.
We were looking -- after that
we were looking for sponsors
to investigate if it is
possible, all the technology,
to have what we asked for.
With this material and proposals
for the development project,
we ended up finally
to the innovation agency
in Sweden, Vinnova.
We made applications with a
project description of Vinnova
and got it granted as
innovation procurement PCP.
We had no previous experience
innovation procurement
and it has been very
interesting to run the project
with the development process
that applies to this type
of pre-commercial procurement.
During the whole project there
have been a form of cooperations
and dialog, but also
involved clear boundary issues
of secrecy for the companies.
These connections have created a
good and challenging development
and exchange of information.
When we started and we
brought these informations,
you can see the picture.
It was this type of just a turntable
and I have the lights
and the camera.
Perhaps they have it better
on the other pictures.
It's very dark here.
It listened like this.
[ Music ]
Yeah. With this we went on and we --
I hope I will -- yes, here I am --
make a short description how the
PCP project had been working on --
and the result we want to achieve.
That we were running at KB.
It's an innovation project with
the funding from VINNOVA and also
from KB that started the first
January 2014, and we be ended
in the last August this year.
VINNOVA is a governmental
institution in Sweden
that provides financial resources
and opportunities for companies
and governmental institutions to
apply for funds with development
and various innovations
and investigations project.
I can say today in [inaudible]
focused on innovation developments
and has dedicated enormous financial
resources that can be applied
for development and
innovation proposals today,
and for [inaudible] it's a special
program they have announced.
We're on the development
project ourselves at KB,
but have in our reference
and expert group participants
from the Development
Department at the Swedish Radio
and also external experts in optical
scanning and image recognition.
It is an innovation project,
which means that the
result will be presented.
It's a description of all the
technology have come today.
I can achieve with pictures scanning
and with development
in image processing.
The project will demonstrate the
results and the possibilities
that exist to get audio
files from analog records.
Our goal is to get
results which show --
foster the real-time with
best possible sound quality.
So on we started this
procurement and we received a total
of eight proposals from
different companies.
Oh, yeah, I have to go on here also.
Oop.
They had no earlier professional
experience in audio recordings
and were more oriented in the
industry and picture recognitions.
In Sweden typically
example of sorting
and selecting [inaudible] free
woods, planks, metal industry,
productions, detections, robotnicks
[sic], selections, failure,
in productions and so on.
We selected of these eight, five
companies with innovation solutions
that processed to Phase One.
In the continuing work in Phase
One includes producing a report
on a preliminary study
and detailed description
of its prototype solutions.
After examination of these Phase
One reports and the associated round
of interviews by these companies,
we made a second new selection,
and we selected three companies
which now participating in Phase Two
of development and
production of prototypes.
They have to make and produce
all your file is [inaudible]
in real-time from 78s
and vinyl records.
In Phase Two includes a number
of goals that should be reported
and be checked before
the final report.
We have to know something
about the result and we have --
give them these two records, test
records and reference records.
It's important that we have
good reference and test records
to compare with normal
turntable we're playing
or with ELP lasered turntable.
They had got these
records to work with
and compare the bandwidth
and other parameters.
It's the way for us to just
compare the result we get
from these companies.
The three companies
now participating
in Phase Two have different
proposed solutions and prototypes
that make it very interesting to
see how the results may differ.
They're working with 2D and
3D scanning methods, laser,
or LED lights, and other tools
that they have in their prospect.
So far I'm not an expert in picture
recognition or an image scanning
and so on, and they have to
prove and show the result for us,
and we can only see the
potential for the results
when they have delivered
the final report.
I have understand so far it's
much about the lightning,
highlight intensity,
and the brightness,
and they probably will unfocus
and blur and also the pixel size
in the cameras and so
on have limitations
for this work with imaging.
One company have used
laser and they --
there was a problem with
sprecklers [assumed spelling]
that I have understanding it's a
problem also about the quality.
We go on and we -- there
are three companies
and the first one here is
MBV Systems AB in Sweden,
and they use 3D laser triangulation,
and they use also what they
call Scheimpflug techniques made
for 78 records.
If you have questions about what
the technique is, I can't answer it.
You'll have to call Texas company.
Perhaps in the end of this
project I can more about the,
how the result will be
described and so on.
But this is the hardware
you can see here.
They have a laser and they have done
these things and I must also say
that the sound recordings and so
on I got is from some months ago.
I can say that it's a rather
short period for them to manage
and give us -- it's almost half a
year and I think they were very glad
when they have built up this
hardware and get the sound from it
and you may listen to what
it looks like and hear.
This is from the MBV system.
Here. Oh, yeah.
Oop.
[ Static and Music ]
Very short but you hear something.
The next one, the second,
is InVite Vision AB.
They use 2D and they
have mostly worked
with the LPs, vinyl discs, so far.
This is the hardware you can see.
They also have -- I go on here.
InVite Vision is another company
working with UDS and have focused
on primary vinyl records.
Pictures of the whole
equipment with a label camera.
This does meter with
display LED light, camera,
and several multi adjusting
the distance.
The disc is moving with an air
bearing, compressed air and rotate
about 20 grooves in
the detection picture.
I forgot to say something about
this I have right down here.
They are working with the
78 records and their plan is
to make it 10 times faster
than real time and catch 20
to 100 rows in a picture.
That was they have
told me and so forth.
The third one then is the --
We can listen to the
InVite Vision also.
I forgot this also.
[ Static and Music ]
This was a vinyl disc.
I think they have the
same recordings.
[ Static and Music ]
This was, what we listening to was
in a vinyl recording, vinyl disc.
The third one then is Joroma AB
and they call the system Optofon.
Joroma AB is another of the
companies working with 2D,
reported so far about
hardware competence
and improved algorhyth
[assumed spelling] for pictures
of the grooves, et cetera.
They are building the prototypes
and are doing tests and are planning
to do tests with broken
and cracked discs.
The plan is to make it 20
times faster than real time
and to catch more than
40 grooves in a picture.
Joroma AB is the Swedish
company with experience
in developing automatic inspection
system for industrial applications.
Theoretically able to capture
all grooves in two revolutions.
New processing tools
can be reapplied
to already scanned records.
Individual grooves are
extracted and tracked
as you can see in the picture.
The image processing sound is
extracted using machine learning.
I'm not sure about it.
Probabilistic methods to
avoiding defects in grooves.
It's only something
I'm not common with.
The sound processing, sound can be
processed using single processing.
Row date is always
preserved untouched.
Can be useful to apply
noise filtering.
They can be contacted.
The man who has been
working this is Josef Grahn
in Sweden in this company.
I have no audio to
reply from them so far.
The next one is then to talk about
is the, as we call, same question,
different solutions,
technical limitations.
The companies shall submit the
final report on the 24th of August
with presentations
or results achieved
and suggest future technical
solutions that they have developed.
After the project have
been finished,
we are going to evaluate
the final results to see if
and how we will proceed
in our continuing work
with optical playback
and digitalizations.
Depending on the results achieved
of some quality and how quickly
and efficiently they may
transfer the records,
we evaluate how realistically
applications
and automatically those
digitalizations could be designed.
It will be clear from the
companies' final reports
that their optical playbacks
and technical solutions
have the potential
to achieve the quality we demand.
Then it can be results that we get
from the optical playback of 78s
that will be achieved the
quality we demand but not
for transferring the
programs disc and so on.
If the results are not going to be
what we want and be good enough,
should the reasons be
described what depends on.
It may be that new
technical possibilities
of optical scanning technology
will be further developed
in the near future and
provide new solutions.
It can then, perhaps,
great opportunities
for optical transmissions
and image processing
and provide the results
we are demanding
for full quality during playbacks
of even faster than real time.
This is what we hope and
perhaps we, in the future,
have some robot to
make this to work.
We are planning to work for a -- if
depending on the results obtained
and the potential that may exist,
we plan to organize a workshop
during the autumn, late autumn,
this year and where presentations
of the results that emerge
from the participant companies.
All this information we have heard
here from IRENE Project and so on,
we will take with us and add to all
the results we get from our project
and see what we can do with all
these results for the future.
We never know.
We hope it will be what we want.
I'm eager to -- I don't know
the result from the companies.
I'm eager to see what they
can present in the end
of August this year, and
see what we can go on.
That's what we are working with
and so thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Now we have Carl Haber again.
>> Carl Haber: Okay.
I said good morning.
Now I say good afternoon.
So this presentation will focus more
specifically on the IRENE technology
which is a high resolution
direct imaging,
meaning we image directly the media.
So IRENE is a set of
tools, it's not one thing,
for non-invasive preservation,
restoration,
and transfer of mechanical
sound carriers.
It employs direct imaging
of the surface
in both two dimensions
and three dimensions.
It consists of hardware, which
you can call the scanner,
and a variety of software.
There's software that
controls the collection of data
and the control of
the scanner itself.
Then there's software that
is used to analyze the data.
There are five installations of this
equipment in one form or another
in Berkeley, there are two
at the Library of Congress,
there's a system at the Northeast
Document Conservation Center,
and at the Richard Muthiah
Research Library in Chennai, India.
The IRENE project is a collaboration
between Lawrence Berkeley Lab,
the Library of Congress,
the University
of Applied Sciences in Fribourg.
Professor Johnson and
the Smithsonian,
and something like 40
students have participated
in aspects of this work.
Then all the different agencies and
mostly public and some foundations
that have supported the project
are indicated here as well.
So this is a picture
of the IRENE system
which is actually at NEDCC now.
So it's kind of what
you would expect.
You've seen similar pictures
in the other presentations.
There's a vibration
stabilization table which is on air.
There's essentially an arch that
contains both the confocal probe
for doing the 3D imaging
and a camera
for doing microphotography
for the 2D imaging.
There's a turntable
that holds disc media.
There's a mandrel that
holds cylindrical media.
Both of these probes can be moved
around under the control
of a computer.
There's some lasers that
are used to control focus
and there's other stages
that are used
to move the cameras
and probes up and down.
This is a picture that's supposed
to evoke the three-dimensional data
where you get the full topology of
the surface and this is a picture
that should invoke the
two-dimensional imaging
where you're just looking
at the light that's directly
reflected back at 90 degrees.
Okay. There's various control
computers and so forth illuminators
that are part of the infrastructure.
So this system is quite general and
it images a whole variety of media.
The characteristics of that
media affect the quality
of the sound that you get.
There's no one number,
there's no one result
that describes how this
system works because there's
so many different variations
that occur.
But I tried to just to group a
couple of prime things here to point
out some of the differences
that you have heard this morning
and you'll also hear when
I play a few samples later.
So lacquer discs have a very,
very fine-grained material
that makes up the surface.
When you image them, so this is
a blow-up region of the groove,
the appearance is very smooth, okay?
Shellac is made of crushed beetles
and a bunch of other things.
It's a highly composite material
which has a lot of texture
and particularly as it gets
worn down different elements
of the matrix wear
at a different rate.
So you have, instead, when you image
shellac material you see already a
much more irregular structure.
When this gets turned into audio
there's going to be more hiss,
the broadband noise that you
heard some examples of earlier,
in shellac materials
than lacquer materials.
It goes back to essentially the
quality of the material and how
that represents itself in an image.
When you're in the 3D domain -- now
this is not a photograph anymore,
I remind you from what
we saw this morning.
It's a depth image, so dark is deep.
This is a curve that shows
how the surface is modulating.
Here you've got many, many points
that describe this surface.
It's not a simply an
edge transition anymore.
So you're able to do a lot
of averaging when you have
that much data, and that, itself,
has an effect on the noise.
You heard some examples of cylinder
data this morning when we looked
at the Riscossi [assumed
spelling] march in the context
of talking about frequencies.
This is another type of
three-dimensional imaging.
This is an aluminum
transcription disc.
So it's a groove that's actually a
lateral groove, but it's embossed,
so you have soft aluminum,
and the cutting tool
doesn't remove material.
It just moves it, okay?
So what the groove looks like is
it's a depression like a groove
but -- so it's got
these horns on it, okay.
The horns are the material that's
been pushed up out of the aluminum
and now sit up on the side.
If you shovel snow, it's the stuff
that you pile up along the sides.
But so the audio is stored down
in here where you have many points
that you can use to
characterize the groove,
and then that has an
effect on the sound.
There's a lot of software
that's come about,
both controlled data
acquisition and analysis.
So just to give you an example of
what the operator might encounter.
This is the analysis software
that's used to process 3D data.
So it's one of the software tools.
So what you've got here is a
panel with a bunch of controls.
This is a summary of the data
that was taken from a cylinder.
So imagine the cylinder.
You slice it and you unroll it.
It becomes a -- a cylinder becomes
a rectangle when you do that.
So these stripes indicate the groove
and the top of here would go down,
and then it would join again.
So it's a mapping of a
cylinder to a rectangle.
If you zoom in, you can see this,
and you can see a lot more
detail of the surface.
You can see all this mold damage.
I talked about that this
morning when we looked
at the Eeschi [assumed
spelling] cylinder.
So this gives the operator
a much kind
of more detailed understanding
of what's going on.
Here along this line you see the
actual up and down profile that,
roughly speaking, tells you
where that stylus would be moving
and how it would be moving.
So there's many, many
options that this gives you,
and I realize that -- somebody this
morning was saying there are too
many options.
In fact, that is an issue.
What you would imagine in some
context is that this thing converges
on a much simpler set
of presets and controls
and even becomes an application that
can be distributed and used along
with -- [inaudible] stated
that clearly people said
that they would like to have.
Okay. This is another view of
another aspect of the software.
This is a chart which explains all
the software tools that were created
at the -- with the design and
specifications of the Library
of Congress to enable them to
operate the IRENE machine that some
of you saw when you
went down to Culpeper
in a production workflow
sort of environment.
So the red flowchart is sort of
what the operator would be doing
when they're scanning a disc.
The grey stuff here is the analysis
of the data that's being created
as happening automatically
in the background.
So here's some database
and the operator would
enter some information,
and some information would then
be pulled in from a database
through this front panel.
Then there's some automatic kind
of calibration procedures that go
on that quickly figure out where
the disc begins and ends and exactly
where to focus to start
off the acquisition.
IRENE, as I said, uses direct
imaging, and so focus control
and depth of field are
technical specifications
that are much more detailed and
important to the way it functions
than when you have a lot of
depth of field as you might have,
for example, in visual audio.
So it automatically
finds the record.
This is sort of the
beginning and the end,
and it figures out
what the focus is.
Then it basically gives the
operator an image quality feedback
and then the person
executes the scan.
The data gets written into a file
and there's a program that's
sitting there looking for new data.
When the new data comes it analyzes
it by pulling in all the images,
edge detecting, tracking
the position of the groove,
cutting out the noise if necessary,
and creating an audio file.
Okay? So this is, I guess,
with some probably improvements
because this is an older slide,
similar to what NEDCC is using.
This kind of tool set.
Okay? Okay.
So let's listen to an example.
So this is a laterally-cut
shellac disc, circa 1930,
which was in pretty good -- no,
I would say moderate condition.
So it's imaged using the
two-dimensional aspect of IRENE.
So you're basically ending
up with pictures like this
and those pictures
have high contrast.
They're kind of like the
pictures you saw in VisualAudio,
but they're directly imaged.
There's no film, intermediate
film step.
Edge detection is applied, in
this case, just to the bottom
of the groove, not to the top of
the groove, which we use more worn
and potentially more
of a source of noise.
So, if you play this record with
a stylus, it sounds like this.
[ Crackling Sound and Music ]
Okay. So I don't know if you can
notice with the sound system,
but there's obviously the audio and
there's some crackle which is kind
of a, not a broadband hiss but a
kind of a campfire kind of sound.
A lot of repetitive small impulses.
The frequency spectrum
that is represented
by what the playback
here is the light blue.
You can see that the audio is kind
of dying out somewhere between,
I don't know, six or
seven kilohertz.
Then what's left is just a noise,
a higher frequency
noise, represented here.
Now we're going to listen to the
IRENE version of the same disc,
and what you're going to -- I
believe what you're going to hear,
this would stay on the page,
is obviously similar audio,
less crackle, more hiss.
[ Music and Hissing Sound ]
I believe you heard the hiss, right?
So the additional hiss that
you're hearing is represented
in the difference essentially
qualitatively
between the high frequency
'til here, which is also hidden
under here obviously,
and the lower noise
of the shellac, stylus version.
That maps back to this picture
that I told you, that you've got,
this texture, and that
texture's in the material.
Okay. So let me talk a little
bit of the technical aspects.
So sound carriers, discs,
cylinders, they're never really flat
and they're never really round,
and in some cases they're
way, way off that.
So this is this notion of
warpage and depth of field.
The 2D and 3D systems that
directly image, they have limits,
just like cameras do,
to the effective depth
of field that they can achieve.
For 2D, we're limited
to about 30 microns.
So it's a really, really
small depth of field.
But having that small depth of
field gets us these very high
resolution images.
The 3D systems are limited to about
2- to 300 microns of depth of field.
That number is typically
smaller than the out-of-roundness
and out-of-flatness
that you often encounter
in these things, even that number.
So, both of these situations lead us
to have active focus
control systems.
That's the way we deal
with depth of field.
We follow the surface as best we
can using an additional measurement
to which we'll just say,
for example, a laser.
Additionally, the probes that we
use have sub-micron resolution,
particularly the 3D probe.
This requires very,
very stable mechanics
and really good vibration
isolation because it's not hard
to get two things to move apart
at the hundred nanometer level.
The images that we take are built
up by a scanning and/or stitching
method, and so when you do
that you have to have really good
control of the data collection
and the systematic, so that
everything stays in phase
and things don't slip with
respect to each other.
In 2D imaging, the illuminators
that we use, they need to be DC,
and I mean really DC, okay?
Because if they're flashing or
flickering at 30 hertz or something,
that shows up as striping
in the images.
That gets misinterpreted by the
edge detection as small shifts,
and that shows up as spurious tones.
So those are the kind of issues
that you really, actually,
spend a lot of time dealing with
once you put the thing together.
So I can re-express these
things as challenges.
The intrinsic characteristics
of mechanical sound carriers,
so old yet so precise, and one of
the other speakers alluded to that,
they really drive these
technical requirements.
Failure to control the technical
aspects can lead to artifacts
in the data which are
real easy to see.
We've encountered these things and
we've learned how to deal with them.
Vibration, AC components,
the illuminator,
lead to spurious audio tones.
Poor focus control leads to
cross-talk, noise, and distortion.
Scanning phase shifts leads
to misaligned datasets.
None of these issues are fundamental
in that they're impossible to solve,
but they have to be handled,
dealing with them and learning how.
They reappear when
we build new systems
and they have to be worked out.
That's an important part of the
R&D, and you shed some blood
and sweat to deal with those.
Okay. The IRENE hardware and/or
software has processed already a
variety of historic materials --
a number of pre, say1890's
audio milestones;
personal novelty recordings
from World War II;
things that soldiers
sent back; aluminum
and acetate transcription discs
from the '30s and '40s; wax field
and dictation recordings from the
late 19th and early 20th century;
the Edison Talking Dolls that
the New York Times seems to be
so in love with; Berliners;
items from the Smithsonian
Institution Volta Laboratory
Experimental Collections; Edison
tinfoils; the Schenectady foil
that John McBride showed
was eventually scanned;
and finally the paper
phonoautograms.
So I'm kind of going
back, back in time.
The present efforts and the
projects, as we kind of go forward,
include, obviously, an ongoing
partnership with the Library
of Congress; tools to process
large collections, workflow,
and diverse materials along
the lines of some of the work
that I already showed, but
obviously doing better at that;
making the hardware faster and
robust and similarly the software.
We have not targeted
faster than real time,
but obviously we want
things to go faster.
A lot of work on at-risk
items, of broken
and delicate materials
and how to handle them.
There's an installation recently
at the Northeast Document
Conservation Center.
These guys are going to
tell you all about that.
Then pilot projects and
even major initiatives
to digitize important collections
and develop best practices
and specifications, and I'm going
to tell you about a few of those.
So we've worked -- our
group, the Library,
and the Smithsonian folks together
on the Volta Lab collection.
Some of you had the
opportunity to go for the tour.
If you haven't, I encourage you
to go over to the National Museum
of American History and listen to
-- or go and see "Hear my Voice,
Alexander Graham Bell, and the
development of sound recording."
In the 1880s, Bell establishes
the Volta Lab here in Washington
with his cousin
and an instrument-builder
named Charles Sumner Tainter,
to conduct research.
They experiment with an astounding
variety of materials and formats,
and produce numerous patents
before settling on the wax cylinder
which becomes so important
that Victoria's voice gets
recorded on a wax cylinder.
Right now, I think, the
collection is something
like 400 experimental recordings,
and in the recent years
we had the chance to scan
and process just a dozen of them.
That's what's focused
on the exhibit there.
I think it's been an ideal
application for IRENE
and a significant future
opportunity to go and actually try
to do this entire collection
if we could ever organize that.
Carlene and Cherry are the SI
Curators, staff folks, that --
I think they're going
to talk to you later.
I think tomorrow.
I'm going to play you one
record from that collection
because it's my favorite
and it's kind
of the most unusual one
that I've come across.
One of the things that Bell did
was, and this is a little off-topic
because we're talking
about grooves carriers,
was actually an optical recording.
He took a glass plate,
coated it with emulsion,
and they brought light in the mirror
through a lens and down this tube.
They exposed a light
path, a light track,
a spiral track on this photo disc.
They modulated the light by spraying
a jet of ink or dye and then causing
that to move in sympathy with the
sound which varied the intensity
of the light which
varied the exposure.
They wrote this exposure track.
Okay? So it starts in the middle
and it spirals until it gets
to this blotch here which is an
over-exposed moment where the --
clearly the thing stopped turning
and the light just
burned into the surface.
They're doing the usual
nursery rhyme thing,
and suddenly something goes wrong
and they say something
spontaneous [laughter],
which I believe is
a really bad word.
Some people say it's
not such a bad word,
but I just think it's
really inappropriate,
so I'm going to play it [laughter].
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Okay. Only in Washington, right?
Okay. Then, of course, there's a gap
and they pick right back up again.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Okay. That high-pitch thing was a
trilled R which was then chirped
because they were speeding up.
Anyway, go over to the exhibit,
and I think it's a great exhibit.
Okay. So a major new initiative
for the project is happening now
at the University of
California at Berkeley.
It's called "Linguistic and
ethnographic sound recordings
from early 20th century
California --
Optical scanning, digitization,
and access."
It's a collaboration of the
Department of Linguistics,
the Phoebe Hearst Museum of
Anthropology, the University
of California Libraries, the
Berkeley Physics Department,
and the Lawrence Berkley
National Lab.
It's a three-year project to scan
a collection at the University
of 2700 wax cylinders from 1900
to 1938 which were collected
by Professor Alfred
Kroeber and T.T Waterman,
and document California
Native American language,
culture, song, and story.
The project is supported by the
National Science Foundation,
the National Endowment for the
Humanities, through a program called
"Documenting Endangered Languages."
It's something that we're really
excited about because it's going
to be this very focused,
concerted effort that's going
to run basically 24/7 for three
years just scanning cylinders.
Some of the technical innovations
that we're trying to feature as part
of this is a more efficient
scanning method.
So the mandrel becomes longer, and
we plan to stack multiple cylinders
like a shish kabob
kind of arrangement,
and then have a control
system that can, overnight,
work its way through
the entire skewer.
Also there's fixturing
to hold individually broken-off
pieces and scan them, so.
I think this is going to
be a really great project.
Another project we're doing
with Harvard is looking
at aluminum discs.
They were prominent in
the early mid-'20s to '30s
as an improved material relative
to wax for field recording.
However, they have a very shallow
and irregularly embossed groove.
I talked about aluminum
grooves a moment ago.
The groove is only five
to ten microns deep.
The groove on a regular
commercial shellac disc is
like 75 microns deep.
So these are tiny grooves.
These are electrically recorded
so they're typically quite loud,
and there's a problem
to keep the needle
in that groove and
not fly off, okay?
So the tendency is to
want to weigh it down,
but the aluminum is really
soft, so you're in a spot there
which is not comfortable.
So optical scanning is
potentially a good choice for this.
Harvard, through IMLS, has a
grant for a feasibility study
that we're doing with them
which could eventually lead
to a future initiative.
This is an amazing collection
from the historical point of view.
It's called the Milman Parry
Collection of Oral Literature.
So Milman Perry was
a classicist who went
to what was called the South
Slavic Kingdoms at that point,
with this aluminum
recording machine.
Recorded people like this individual
who were reciting poetry and stories
that went on for a long
time that they learned
through an oral tradition.
He analyzed the structure and
the superstructure behind this
that created the ability for these
guys to remember these things.
That analysis of oral song led
to the view that the epic poems
of Homer and others were
also orally transmitted
because they feature
the same structures.
So this is like empirical
data-driven humanities work done
in the 1930s, looking at a living
laboratory and referencing it back
to these incredibly important --
I mean the beginning
of Western literature.
So there's Parry aluminum disc and
obviously this is to evoke the --
I guess it's the slaughter
that occurred
when a disc just got
back home and found
out what the hell was
going on [laughter].
This is what one of these aluminum
discs actually sounds like.
They're striking when
they're optically scanned.
If I can get the cursor.
[ Singing and Music ]
So I mean, they're pretty good,
the quality of those recordings.
Yeah. Here's actually a
display off the software package
of what the aluminum
datasets look like.
Actually we saw that.
It's a lateral groove, and you
saw the zoomed- in [inaudible].
Interestingly, on this one, there
was a little burst of noise,
kind of right in the middle of the
playback, and we traced it down.
You can see that the groove is
actually deformed in this one region
and it corresponds to just this
little patch in the material.
So lacquer transcription discs.
A colleague spoke about
them earlier.
They're a very, very
important region, area,
for optical scanning as well.
There are significant collections
of radio transcription discs here
at the Library and,
of course, elsewhere.
This type of disc has
a number of chemical
and mechanical pathologies
associated with it.
Typically we see pretty
good performance
when you scan these optically
relative to a stylus transfer.
A year or two back, 600 sides
of these discs were done here
at the Library as a pilot study
using the World War II Armed Forces
Radio collection.
So here's a -- I'm going
to first compare a stylus
to an IRENE transfer on
a lacquer disc from 1950.
It's a radio show.
Then I'm going to play one of the
Armed Forces optical transfers.
So here's the stylus version.
>> Do you deliberately
keep visitors from me?
Has the physician told you
to keep my friends away?
>> Oh no, mistress, no.
>> Then what is it?
>> Mistress, I -- unless
I am mistaken [inaudible]
and all the others will
never enter this house again.
>> And why not?
>> Carl Haber: I'm dying to
know why not [inaudible].
Okay. So here's the IRENE version.
>> Do you deliberately
keep visitors from me?
Has the physician told you
to keep my friends away?
>> Oh no, mistress, no.
>> Then what is it?
>> Mistress, I -- unless
I am mistaken [inaudible]
and all the others will
never enter this house again.
>> And why --
>> Carl Haber: And why not?
Okay. We still don't know.
I think you could hear
that that the hiss --
>> I think you might have
a question over there.
>> Carl Haber: I think
we're going to do -- what?
Five minutes, yeah.
No problem.
It wasn't a question.
It was an order.
Yeah. Okay.
I think you can hear that
the hiss has a quite --
is quite less as compared to what we
heard when we listened to a shellac.
So I want to remind you of
the media comparison picture
and the relative smoothness
of those materials.
Okay. So here's the Armed
Forces Radio broadcast.
I only have the IRENE
transfer for this one.
>> When the lieutenant saw several
of his men wounded and fires started
by Japanese shells, he dashed from
his shelter, braving the enemy fire.
He brought the wounded back to
cover, saving the lives of several.
A sweeping order from the War
Production Board tonight ends the
use of iron and steel in more than
400 articles of common civilian use,
and thereby puts the finishing
touches on the enforced conversion
of a great section of our economy.
In 90 days no more fountain pens,
pie plates, cigarette lighters,
toolboxes, pleasure boats,
automobile accessories,
street light poles,
not even bathtubs.
>> Carl Haber: Okay.
So one area that is really
important for lacquer
and other materials
are the broken discs,
and how do you deal with them.
So the point was made that
once they break they're not
in a plane anymore.
Much even worse than sometimes
you have just with warpage.
For a direct imaging system which
has such a narrow depth of field,
30 microns, it's an issue.
How do you image something that has
so much, now, vertical differencing?
So, here's a picture taken with
the IRENE Scanner of this disc,
which is just broken
into four pieces.
Even if you break it,
because the stress is changed
in the broken things, the surfaces
just move even a little bit.
And with 30 microns' depth of
field, once you cross the crack
into the next region,
you're not in focus anymore.
And it's very hard for focus
control to follow so quickly
across such a sharp transition.
Okay. So one approach that
we've taken to this is
to develop a special version
of the scanning software
that actually scans the
disc in both directions,
and can accommodate the crack in
this way, getting one side in focus
in one acquisition,
and the other side
in focus in another acquisition.
So with that data, we can actually
tell the control system how to end
up in focus when you're
here, and how to end
up in focus when you're here.
And now we have two images,
and we have to merge them,
so a process was developed
essentially pixel by pixel
to decide what is in
focus and what isn't,
and synthetically create
a super focused image
by merging these different images
that complement each other.
Now that works in a case like
this, where you're only broken
into a couple of pieces,
but when the number
of pieces approaches infinity --
which is often what happens on
lacquer discs -- this doesn't work.
You can't -- you just cannot get
things moving around fast enough.
So another approach has
been under development,
and one of our students is
writing his thesis on this,
is to take actually
a stack of images,
so that in some image,
everything is in focus.
You know if you combine.
And then to use a statistical method
to merge, again pixel by pixel,
to get a super focused
image from this big stack.
So both of these views,
some related concepts.
But we view them as good strategies
that I think are going to work
out for bringing broken
discs together again.
[ Music ]
See I didn't put the bad part in.
Okay. Okay, so the last
point I want to make is
about the technical performance --
fundamental technical performance
of 2-D and 3-D sensors, as
used for direct imaging.
Sensors have spatial resolution,
which is well matched to the kind
of submicron size of groove
modulations, and John talked
about this and Ottar talked about
this, the scale of these things.
These sensors easily sample to in
excess of 100 kilohertz if required.
But the scan speed is
proportional to sampling.
So if you want to sample at 96
kilohertz, it takes twice as long
as sampling at 48 kilohertz.
Just, that's the way it works.
The groove profile,
okay, the amplitude,
is measured on many points
and the position is averaged.
In 2D you measure a
couple of edge transitions,
but on 3D you measure a dozen, two
dozen, 30 points across a groove,
and you can combine those.
Okay. So on a per point basis, one
of these 3D probes, for example,
confocal probe, it can measure
the surface with a resolution,
if you like, of something
like 12 or 13 bits.
Just in terms of the
measurement of the surface.
But the measurement of the
surface is not the audio.
It's just a measurement
of the surface.
Okay? The audio results
from averaging many points
and then differentiating the result,
because the audio is not the surface
of the record, it's the speed
over which a stylus will move.
Okay. So simply asking how many bits
of surface height I have is not the
same as what the audio is, okay?
It's in fact difficult to
uniquely specify an audio bit depth
in the same way that
people do when they talk
about a simple voltage converter
of this synthetic result.
The real question, and I believe the
focus should be on this question,
is whether the measurement
at the end is well matched
to the effective bit
depth of the data itself.
How much information is actually in
this audio that we're recovering?
When we're talking about historical
and old materials,
they're noise dominated.
There's a limit to the amount
of information that's present
in the vicinity of
so much random noise.
Okay. So, what does
it mean when we say
that we're digitizing an audio
recording to a certain bit depth?
Regardless of the bit depth of
the ADC -- 24 bits, 16 bits --
the effective bit depth, the
real bit depth, is always limited
by the intrinsic noise
of the recording relative
to the size of the signal.
So we studied, for example, recent
stylus transfers that were done
from field recorded wax cylinders,
like the Jesse Fuchs collection.
Okay. When we compared
the signal and the noise,
we found that the available
bit depth in a stylus transfer,
even if it was digitized with a
24-bit ADC, is only either seven,
or as little as four bits, when
you compare the noise level
in those recordings to either the
maximum or the average signal.
So you can use 100-bit
ADC, but it doesn't exist.
But when you have random noise
present and a small signal,
there's a limit to the amount of
information that's actually there.
And also, when you
talk about bit depth,
it also depends upon the
frequency and the distribution
and the bandwidth over which
you make the measurement.
The IRENE Optical scans in 2D
and 3D are more than sufficient
to measure these signal-to-noise
levels,
as well as even lower noise
levels on newer cylinders,
and are in fact flat to
100 kilohertz if required,
which I argued in this
morning's presentation.
The thing to keep in mind is
that any measured data set has
an effective number of bits.
Okay. And that effective number of
bits is limited by the relationship
between the signal and the noise.
No matter how many bits your
ADC has, the effective number
of bits is limited by the
random noise in the data.
Okay, finally I want
to talk a little bit
about education and training.
I mentioned that this morning.
We have had a very significant
student participation
in this project.
There have been about 20
University of California undergrads
and about 20 thesis students from
the University of Applied Sciences
in Fribourg, and also
from ZHAW in Zurich.
They have been in fields
like electrical engineering,
mechanical engineering,
physics, anthropology.
They've worked on measurements, on
data analysis, on code development,
algorithms, and it's been a great
opportunity to expose students
in engineering and physical
sciences to problems
in preservation and conservation.
Olivia Dell, she just
graduated from Cal as a physics
and art history double major,
and she received an undergraduate
research prize that's supporting her
to work on this big
cylinder transfer project
over this next year.
So, I don't know, I'm hoping
that maybe she's going to go
on to do preservation science
with this great art history
and physics background,
but we'll see.
We'll see what it takes her.
She's brilliant.
So, to conclude, I hope
that in the greater context,
and also specifically with
IRENE, I've given you the idea
that digital technology
of today provides a window
on this great period
of sound recording
that we've been focusing on.
So Bill Veillette from
NEDCC, he told me,
"Your ultimate audience
is posterity."
I don't know if he tells
everybody that, but,
I like that, so I keep
it in my talk.
Irene.lbl.gov is the project website
and there's Phoebe A. Hearst Museum
of Anthropology.html has a more
focused discussion of the importance
of having a high resolution
flat frequency distribution
for capturing vertical media,
so I draw you to that
if you're interested.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So, Peter's running away?
So, we're going to
do questions right?
For all of us?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, so I can sit down?
>> Question for Carl.
This is Martin Jacobson from
the U.S. National Archives.
You may have said it, I may
have missed it, but I'm assuming
that the IRENE system uses
a laser light which is close
to a sign wave, is that right?
Or are you using a
frequency spectrum?
>> Carl Haber: I'm not sure
what you mean by a light --
>> Sensor as the [inaudible].
>> What is the wave length of
the light that you're using
for reading the information
off the disc?
>> Carl Haber: For the 2D or the 3D?
>> Either one.
>> Carl Haber: Okay, basically,
we're talking about white light.
In the case of the 3D sensor, the
light source is a xenon arc lamp,
which is a fairly broad
frequency spectrum.
And because the 3D sensor uses
this color based confocal imaging,
in fact, that's what you want.
You want a lot of color
so you can disperse them
and then use them individually
to find the light.
For the 2D imaging, we've used a
variety of white light sources also.
Some LED based, some xenon based.
But you -- some of these
applications are light starved
and so having bright light
illuminators that are flat
in time is really important.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Carl Haber: Sure.
>> Well, we're talking about
preservation, and so far,
I don't think I've heard
anyone talk about stampers.
This would be the equivalent
of going back
to an original printed book as
opposed to a photocopy book,
if you wanted to make a microfilm
preservation copy in the old days.
Why is it that -- aside from the
absence of stampers, and, of course,
many of those were melted
down for the base metal.
Why is it that there isn't a greater
degree of emphasis on going back
to the or, or text if
you will, the basic text.
Which is the original.
And is IRENE, or are
the other systems
that have been brought forward,
capable of handling stampers?
>> Carl Haber: Okay,
there's no reason
that you can't scan a stamper.
It's just upside down,
depending on how you look at it.
One of the items from the Volta
Lab collection that is on display
at the Smithsonian is actually a --
or a stamper, I guess, it's like,
I don't know, Patrick, tell me
if I'm wrong, but I think it's
like the first stamper, right.
It's a little laterally cut disc
that is a copper electrotype
taken off wax
that they must have sacrificed.
So, they actually worked
very really well, I have it.
But from time to time,
stampers have come up.
We -- as you know, there are
Galvano's, and we did scan --
I didn't have time to include
it, but we scanned a Galvano,
which was a sacrificial
Galvano, so it opened up,
but it's certainly possible to get
a probe now that's small enough
to fit inside a Galvano and
scan the inside surface.
So, for folks that don't know,
at the Berlin Phonogram Archive,
the mode of operation was to
bring in the new wax cylinder
and immediately make a
copper electrotype of it
and then sacrifice the original,
and then cast duplicates
for the customer, or the
user, or the scholar.
And they've recently
revitalized that process,
but they have 20,000 Galvanos,
or something in Berlin.
So that would be the
cylinder version of a stamper.
But yeah, there's even a
little control in the IRENE,
in the 3D analysis program, if
it's a stamper, flip it, you know.
>> So, I showed a Berliner
disc, which is a stamper.
They're very -- they're
actually easier to measure
in some respects than
the other discs.
>> Carl Haber: In the front.
>> Well I guess all of the
cylinders are master records, so.
Likely directly recorded.
>> Carl Haber: Right, so
that's, but they're not stampers.
>> But, you introduced a social
aspect the university social aspect
in your slide on educational
factors.
I noticed that you had --
you claimed 40 students
involved with these projects.
And at Berkeley, all
20 were undergraduates
and no master's or PhD students.
And the thesis students
were all Fribourg.
>> Carl Haber: [Inaudible] --
>> Does that imply
that you were not able
to interest regular faculty
members and departments
at Berkeley in these projects?
>> Carl Haber: That's
a great question.
We've been very successful in our
collaboration with our colleagues
in Switzerland and we've had many
masters and bachelor students.
By the way, these Swiss
bachelor students are essentially
like American master students,
in terms of what they have to do.
They have to write 150-page
thesis, which is original.
And we actually have twice as many,
because they also come and work
with us on high energy
physics projects.
But we -- and -- so we've had
a number of master students
and bachelor students that
all do major thesis work
that take months and months.
But we have never had any Berkeley
professor in a technical field,
you know, kind of say, "Let's work
together," or something like that.
With the -- with this new
project with the libraries
and the linguistics department, we
are linked up now with professors
and faculty who have a research
interest in the materials.
But, for example, no
engineering professor, has --
and I think the reason why is
because in major research
universities,
people have big programs
that they're already into.
That's why they're there
at those universities
and they're typically not looking
for some cool little project
to like donate their students to.
And it's different, New Yorkers
may be more open minded to this,
but I think it's hard
in American universities
to make this kind of change.
Sure.
[ Inaudible Speakers ]
>> I just wanted to say
that I worked in the U.K.
until a few years ago and I was
actually able to get funding
for Ph.D. students to work on audio
preservation, specifically bring
in doctoral students to do
audio preservation projects,
which you can't do the
same kind of thing here.
I mean, I got HRC funding
specifically to do that.
>> Carl Haber: And you, you...
>> And that's just a different
way that the funding works.
>> Well, that's humanities.
Yeah, in engineering
it's quite difficult.
I think I did one.
Yeah.
>> But the structure is
there in a way that it isn't.
>> Carl Haber: I mean I've
felt that there's a bunch
of projects would have been
great Ph.D. projects for students
in electrical engineering,
information technology,
library science.
It would be great to collaborate
with an American colleague,
but it's not happened.
And you know, I presented this
work on campus numerous times,
in the statistics department, the
engineering school, and so forth.
>> Yes, I would maybe
complement what Carl say.
I had in Fribourg maybe 20 students
working on their bachelor thesis
or master's thesis, and
one Ph.D. thesis also.
And, in addition, yes, many
of my students went to Carl.
It's very easy to convince
them send them to Berkeley,
California, San Francisco.
And that's why our students, some
other student, they go to Berkeley
to do work for Geneva, you know.
For the [inaudible] -- So I
believe sometimes it's the geography
and probably maybe I would be more
successful than Carl if in trying
to get Berkeley students,
because coming
to Switzerland could be
interesting for them.
>> Yes. I have a question regarding
has there been any discussion
about establishing a business model.
In particular, if we get the
universal player, the ideal thing
that we have the Center of
Excellence and we can now go
from one institution to another,
and everybody is capturing
the data one way.
Everything you've been
talking about so far is very,
very heavily dependent on software.
Very different than buying a
needle, buying a turntable.
Once you get into the realm
of software dependency,
who will have ownership of the
source code and how will we preserve
that and allow this, if we
develop this universal tool,
to continue for posterity sake?
Because if we don't
have access to that,
we are going to become obsolete
in a very different way.
I appreciate the brilliance
on stage, but like records,
we all don't live forever.
So how do you do that?
>> All right, can I,
can I take this one?
>> Carl Haber: Yeah.
>> Because actually a lot of
the clever software is actually
in the control system
for the measurement.
And if you have a system and
it's doing the measurement
and you're producing the data,
and then circulating the data,
the data's actually
quite easy to interpret.
Most people with an
undergraduate degree in physics
or engineering could just
write a piece of code,
probably first year,
to get the sound off.
There's nothing particularly clever
in the way the sound is taken
from the three dimensional data.
>> Isn't there in the
algorithms that are then applied?
So by definition, if you're
capturing raw data, Level 1,
think like a Photoshop model,
you've got the raw data.
The very next thing that happens,
and you say it very casually,
"Okay," and then we get
rid of some of the noise.
That's a decision someone is making
in defining what particular
algorithm they're going to use
versus the algorithm somebody else
might use to get rid of noise.
>> You can then load
Audacity for free.
And Audacity is an
incredible sound system
for actually taking the noise out.
You can control everything.
It's free on the internet.
>> Carl Haber: So I agree with
John that conceptually a lot
of the transformations are
not actually that complicated.
However, I definitely
appreciate the sentiment
of your question and your comment.
And I have to say that when
we started down this road,
because the Library of Congress
engaged so early and so strongly
to this, we felt like it was a
good -- that was a good way to go.
Because here we were
working with an institution
that has this important leadership
role, at least nationally
and as a collegial institution
with the British Library
and the others internationally.
And frankly, mostly we're in
service to public collections.
So I think that this thing really
belongs in the public domain
and that institutions
like the Library
of Congress should be the places
where these tools have
their ultimate home
and that they're validated
and they're specified,
and they're maintained, and they're
distributed freely and openly.
So a business model of a basically
a not for profit free, open source,
community of users and
developers, guided by the Library
or some international consortia
of research libraries, whatever,
but I think it belongs in the
central publicly controlled
and publicly spirited in place.
But, yes, I think there does
need to be a stability to it.
But I think that's not a -- I think
that belongs at Apple or Google,
or some company that
has its own agenda.
It belongs in the public institution
like the Library of Congress.
>> I was hoping you would say that.
>> Carl Haber: Okay.
[ Laughter ]
>> First of all, I love to hear
democratization of access talk.
That's really great.
But in general, when you start
talking about archival and,
you know, sharing these data
sets and things like that,
one of my concerns is
always size of the data set.
So, could you provide -- I know it's
completely dependent upon sampling
and the original source
material, how quickly you have
to sample along that, but could
you bracket perhaps what size
of data sets we're talking
about in these image sets.
>> Carl Haber: Yeah, so for example,
maybe Bill or Mason, because you're,
you're producing these data
sets for your customers.
I mean I can toss out some numbers.
They're going to have the
gigabyte connected to them.
But, I don't know, is
Mason and Bill here?
Yeah. What do you, what
are you giving out?
>> Sure. Cylinders are
typically about a gigabyte.
For a four-inch cylinder,
one-and-a-half [inaudible].
>> Carl Haber: The raw,
the raw image data.
>> For just the raw image data.
And then discs are 30 to 80,
depending on the speed and size.
>> Carl Haber: Right.
But if you sample at twice the
speed that you're doing, or three,
then they're just going to grow
linearly with sample speed.
>> That's right.
>> Carl Haber: So,
were talking gigabyte,
kind of, you know, data sets.
>> When you're talking about
the commercial or the workflows
and you're trying to, not
so much commercialize it,
but send it off to
production, right?
>> Carl Haber: Yeah.
>> How do you quality control?
So if you're reading at three times
the speed, do you still have someone
that has to listen to
the whole 15 minutes.
What do you do on that side?
>> Carl Haber: Okay, so it's
not, when you say reading
at three times the speed,
you're saying you're having
like many parallel lines
running at the same time?
>> I guess I'm saying once you scan
it, right, somewhere you're going
to scan, you're going to
create the sound file, right?
Who quality controls the sound file?
So that you can gain efficient sets.
>> Carl Haber: So, Peter, you
pretty much designed the work flow
that was used.
So, do you, do you
want to field that?
>> Well, so, as you turn your
image file into an audio file,
the way Carl and Earl
designed the IRENE software,
it effectively has what's called
tracking, so you can visually see
that it's lining up with the
actual grooves in the media.
So the biggest problem in
terms of a general sense
of getting an unacceptable kind
of output would be
when it missed tracks.
Now if you want to get into
the weeds and say, you know,
the absolute best you can get out
of the image, that is more of a,
you know, you're going to have
to get in there and listen to it
and tweak parameters and things.
But we were trying
to do it more in a --
what would be a high
throughput mode,
in which case you wouldn't
necessarily listen to everything.
And in that case, if you
get the tracking right,
the audio generally
falls into place.
And so, that's a fairly
easy failure to detect.
And so that's the way
we approached it.
>> Carl Haber: Right.
So the IRENE analysis code
keeps track of how many defects,
how many dust particles, how many
scratches, how many conditions
that fail various cut
levels, threshold levels,
are accumulated throughout
the analysis.
So you can also have a report,
a histogram, a bar graph,
that comes out which is telling
you about the data quality, yeah.
But, I mean -- yeah, these
issues -- I mean, the closest --
I mean, working like in physics, we
do experiment, we're taking data day
and night, producing huge amounts,
and there's quality reports
that just stream out and
somebody watches and looks
for outliers and things, and yeah.
So there's many, many approaches.
And I'm sure in industrial
settings they have all kinds
of statistical process
stuff that they do.
>> I was just wondering
in the Swedish --
you're very close to
getting to the point
of where you're going
to see the results.
And given what we heard,
what is your sort
of prognosis for the outcome?
>> Ottar Johnsen: Yeah, we
have first to see the result
from them now in the end of August
and we have to validate the result
that we have asked them for.
And --
>> I think the reason I asked is
the second one, which was the LP.
>> Ottar Johnsen: LP,
yes, that's right.
>> It seemed a bit, I don't know,
not exactly what I expected
from an LP recording.
>> Ottar Johnsen: No.
I have a bit away, ongoing, and
this is the first result they have
managed and we -- they're
having the beginning told us
that 78s is much easier than LP and
they have started with the LP's.
And when I come back here
to Sweden, they have,
are going to make a
demonstration of the project,
so for more precisely,
and I don't know.
The other two say that the
vinyl discs are a big problem
and I can't say more about it.
And I was very surprised
from one of the companies
that are very promising and they
think, "Oh, this will be for 78's,"
enough good results in the
reports they will give us
in the end of this, of the August.
And I don't worry.
I am eager to hear.
I'm not expecting in the -- and I'll
take all this information with me
to Sweden from the
Carl and all others,
and mix this information together
and give the next step for us.
I think so.
>> Carl Haber: You know, listening
to the examples that you played.
I was thinking that maybe they
were not applying a derivative
to the data that they were taking.
They were just playing
the shape of the groove.
That's the way it sounded.
And it didn't sound like they were
also then applying the normal EQ
curves to them.
>> Ottar Johnsen: Exactly.
>> Carl Haber: So that will
definitely change the sound
if they do.
>> Ottar Johnsen: And they --
if they also say is that if you
have the picture, you can go on
and use the picture
for preprocessing --
after processing the picture,
and that's what I know
about imaging and so on.
I really don't know much more about
the process to make this pictures
and imaging and I hope
they have the competence
to make the best result they can
do with our project, and we'll see.
Yeah.
>> This is a good sideway
to my question,
which is about what is the
bottleneck for getting faster
than real time transfers?
Is it the size of the light beam
or why can't it be done
much faster than real time?
>> Carl Haber: So the 3D probes,
the best ones take
nearly 200 points at once.
And they take them at a
certain exposure time.
They just need to expose.
And so, they can run as fast
as 2000 exposures a second,
for the nearly 200
points, and when you just,
if you just do the arithmetic of
how many exposures you have to take
to cover the surface
area of whatever it is,
that works out to more
than real time.
Depending upon the density, it could
be for say a four-inch cylinder,
it could be 20 minutes or
it could be a few hours.
Depending on what you want.
So you need either faster probes --
and that's going to mean they have
to be brighter basically,
or probes with more points.
You could imagine that.
I mean when we started,
it was a one-point probe
and then suddenly it
became 180-point probe.
There's now 190-point probe.
I've heard them talking
about 1000point probe.
But once you get to 1,000 points,
you start to get into issues of,
you know, it becomes big and
systematic things pop up.
You could run multiple
probes in parallel, okay.
But your cost goes up by a factor
of twofor -- start adding probes.
Probes are like $50,000, okay.
For the IRENE and visual
audio 2D scanners,
one of the bottlenecks is
just like disc writing speed
for the data you're generating.
The 2D scanning I think
has the greatest.
Because right now, it takes like 15
minutes to scan a three-minute disc.
I think there's hope along those
lines of pushing that, but maybe,
Earl, you want to comment, because
you've thought about this a lot.
Where do you see it going?
>> Right, so we're definitely
sort of a factor to speed limited
by disc writing currently.
And that's just because we
haven't taken the time to,
body, or research the faster.
And then of course, we're
still light limited as well.
I mean once you get
past that factor too,
then it becomes a light
limiting factor.
>> So, can I make a
comment -- comments here.
I mean the only reason for
increasing the speed is throughput.
But if you automate,
then you don't need it.
You know, if you automate the system
and you can just have
the discs piled up
and then you can just
feed them through.
So it's actually -- what's more
important -- is actually automation.
So, it's, you can just
automate the whole thing.
>> Ottar Johnsen: How
we are inputting in this
in the beginning was that we have
to take more than 20 years for us
to make this discs we have
in the archive for audio file
and we have it continuing
for five years,
if they put the records
on, and it takes 5 years.
And we have, what can we do?
The material in the archive
will be standing in the shelves
and no one had listened to it.
We had to find, is it
possible to find a new method
to make this and listen to them?
And this was the input for
us to see is it possible.
And they have to prove it, the
competence was left in the project.
And so on.
One input is also, is the
quality enough just for listen.
We know that vinyl's and
78's records are stable.
You can take it back
if you don't crush it.
And you have a listening copy
for researchers and so on,
not in the high end quality,
but it's enough perhaps
for hear what they say and so on.
This is one of the results that we
have to manage in the end of it.
>> Carl Haber: So if
you just want what,
I guess you would call them access
copies, for listening purposes
of 78's, you could take a scanner
like the visual audio scanner
or the IRENE scanner, which
are essentially the same thing.
You could put four or six
cameras on there and just whoosh,
and you could just scale it
up and you could get it in,
if you could deal with
the disc writing,
you have multiple disc drives and
you just, you just dump the thing.
I mean that's like a brute force.
If your goal is really to read a
three-minute record in a minute,
you probably could make that happen
by just throwing multiples of $6000
at it until you had enough cameras.
I mean at some point you
won't fit anymore cameras
and it becomes a packing problem.
[ Laughter ]
>>Thank you.
>> Question for Dr. McBride.
In your Journal of
Acoustic Society paper,
you note that you were getting
10 nanometers of axial resolution
on a top to bottom groove
dispersion of 10 microns.
Which is 1000 units of measurement.
Which is about 10 bits, right.
>> Okay.
>> Simple math.
And you state that the digital
audio bit depth is equivalent
to the image bit depth.
Do you still hold to that?
>> Have you got the paper there?
>> I do.
>> [ Laughter ]
. Okay, well when was
that published?
>> 2008.
>> Okay, wow.
>> The question is,
has this advanced?
Is there -- I'm understanding from
Dr. Haber that the axial resolution
in the image domain
does not translate
to digital audio resolution.
>> No, you need to --
>> I'm trying to resolve this.
>> No, you need to
take the derivative
of the surface to get
the sound from.
But you still need to have
the raw data to start with.
>> Of course.
No, I've only taken a couple of
college level classes in physics.
>> Yeah, so you still have to, you
still have to have the raw data.
>> You have to have the raw
data there, that's right.
And if the raw data is only there
with a precision of, in
your case, 10 bits...
>> I don't recall either.
>> Okay.
>> On that slide I showed it
was the 20 kilohertz harmonic.
Oh no, sorry, two kilohertz
harmonic --
>> Yes.
>> In a spoken word.
>> If the image is measured
with the precision of 10 bits --
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Is there any transformation that
you can do to increase resolution?
>> You cannot go -- you
cannot change the resolution
of the sensor that you're using.
So that graph was actually
about defining.
It's about the quality of the
potential audio that you can get
from this and we were
interested in preservation.
So we're at the first stage of this.
It's about preserving the raw
data, you know, for future use.
>> Understood.
>> And that's where that
measurement came from.
It was a displacement
measurement against frequency.
If you look at the lower
frequency, I think,
I pointed that on the slide,
what was it, 600 hertz?
The magnitude of that particular
harmonic was much higher, yeah.
So this is -- I was focusing
on the harmonics associated
with the spoken word, yeah.
So it's a very kind of
detailed scientific issue.
>> I understand.
I do understand.
But let me ask the question
again, perhaps in a way
that we can all understand.
If something's measured
with 10 bits of precision
in the digital optical domain.
That's a level precision.
Is there any transformation
that can be done?
Because that's the digital,
that's the preservation master.
Right? Is there any
transformation that can be done
to bring that up to 16 bits?
>> So hang on, Actually --
>> Carl Haber: Okay, okay,
so I addressed this --
>> [Inaudible] The 10 bit,
we didn't publish that.
You've done a calculation
which is the ratio
of the 15 nanometer height,
which we just referred to.
>> No, no you published it.
I'm looking at it right here.
>> What does it say?
Does it say 10?
>> That's not, that's
not my point --
>> Yeah, I don't think that's
correct because it actually, that,
that's -- is that comparing
the depth
of the groove to the 15 nanometers?
Is that the number that you said?
>> Yes. I'll read it to
you so we can have it.
>> Yeah, I don't think
that's correct.
>> Carl Haber: Okay,
here's the thing.
>> Yes.
>> Carl Haber: You measure the
surface at a certain point.
But you take many points
and you combine those points
to get an estimate of
the depth of the groove
at a certain moment in time.
So the depth of the groove at
that moment in time is synthesized
from a number of measurements.
So by combining multiple
measurements
through an averaging
process, you can improve
through averaging your measurement.
So, just taking -- just
interpreting what the resolution is
on a single point, and then
comparing it to some number,
10 microns, 20 microns, that you're
sort of picking out from some place.
It's just the beginning of a more
complicated story that leads you
to a certain performance which comes
out from combining all this data,
taking the surface, differentiating
it, and turning it into audio.
A statement that you can make
which is very well defined
about the instrument that you buy
is that it has a range of a certain,
say 200 microns, 300 microns,
depending on the instrument
that you choose, the
optics that you choose.
It has a certain resolution
inside that range, 50 nanometers,
10 nanometers, 120 nanometers,
depending on the one you use.
And that ratio, between its
fundamental resolution and its range
that defines its capability in bits.
>> Theoretical bit depth.
>> Carl Haber: For a
single point measurement.
Okay?
>> Right.
>> Carl Haber: That's
just the beginning
of a more complicated story.
>> I understand.
>> Carl Haber: And
there's no -- there's --
sorry it's very hard to see you
because Mason [inaudible] is
a little disconcerting, but,
I feel like I'm talking to,
looking behind somebody.
But, you know, so that's why
I went into this discussion,
because there's no simple little
answer and frankly when people
in audio engineering say, "Oh,
I'll digitize this at 24 bits,
that's a -- it's a
big simplification
about what's actually going on.
And there has to be.
>> I understand.
Unfortunately, this conference --
>> Carl Haber: Well, just a minute.
And there has to be a recognition
that noise, random noise,
sets the scale that we
have to base everything on.
If you want to measure the
radius of a billiard ball,
I can give you a pair of precision
calipers and you can measure
that radius to whatever you like.
If you want to measure the
radius of a tennis ball,
the diameter of a tennis ball,
it's a poorly defined problem
because a tennis ball is furry.
All right?
So there's an arbitrariness
due to the random structure
of the surface of a tennis ball.
That means that fundamentally,
you can't measure it the same way
you can measure a billiard ball.
Audio engineers recognize
this when they say,
"Well a 24-bit ADC is really only 20
bits, or 21 bits, because, you know,
there's fundamental noise in the ADC
electronics that knocks already four
or five bits out of the game.
And I tried to build
up that explanation
and in just a few minutes
it could be the subject
of an hour long discussion.
You know, you can go on Wikipedia
and read pages and pages about,
you know, if you want to run
your clock at three megahertz,
you can have a one-bit
ADC and digitize audio
at very, very high quality.
So there's no simple
little, I know you're trying
to get a simple little answer
and say, "Well I can do 24 bits
and you can only do 7," or something
like that, but it doesn't work.
>> Carl, that's not
what I'm trying to do.
>> Carl Haber: Okay.
>> I'm trying to get to the bottom
of a question that's been bothering
me and a lot of other people,
and for which you and Dr. McBride
seem to have very different answers.
>> Okay, I wasn't...
>> Carl Haber: Do we?
>> Well, I don't think we do.
>> Okay, but, but --
>> I mean, maybe a line that's
in a paper which was published,
you know, what, what would he say?
Eight years ago [laughter].
>> Okay, that's fine.
>> You should have given me a
prior warning; I would've looked
up the background for it.
>> That's fine.
>> The sensor -- I've
just did a calculation,
the sensor that we use is
actually 15-bit resolution.
You've got a 350-micron range
and it resolves to 10 nanometers.
>> Yes, and that's where Carl
got his 12 to 13 bits as well.
>> Yeah, so all, I think all we were
saying is that it's really important
that if you want to get
the best quality audio
from these old recordings,
you have to have a sensor
that has a minimum resolution of
around 50 -- is it 50 nanometers?
Oh, what does it say,
you've got it there.
>> Yes. 50 nanometers.
>> Whatever it is.
>> Carl Haber: And that thing --
it depends on the material,
but that's sort of it.
>> That's the key thing.
>> We're cutting into the
next session and it seems
like maybe we have to deal with
this, I definitely want to deal
with this, but we could --
but maybe John could look
at the paper again --
>> Yeah, sure.
>> We could pick this up
>> Carl Haber: Okay.
>> Like at the end of
things, we'd have bigger time.
>> Carl Haber: Okay, sure.
>> We're cutting into other
people's talks right now,
so I think we should have a very
quick coffee break for five minutes
and move the new talkers
in and then get started.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay, so our first
presentation is --
we actually have kind
of two duos this time.
From NEH we have Joshua
Sternfeld and Jesse Johnston.
So, Josh, Joshua's
speaking first right?
>> Sure.
>> Yep. So.
>> Joshua Sternfeld: That's
the best kind of introduction.
Jump right in.
So, hello everyone.
I am Joshua Sternfeld.
I'm a senior program officer
with the National Endowment
for the Humanities, Division
of Preservation and Access.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Jesse Johnston,
also from the Division of
Preservation and Access.
So, today we are going to
talk about a few things here.
I think we're going to move from
the very technical discussions
that we've heard, up to this point.
And perhaps in the course of just
talking about our grant programming
and some of the projects that
we've supported over the years,
we will begin to kind of see a way
of answering some of the questions
that Carl was raising
earlier this morning,
about where do we go from here.
And how do we take all of
the research and technologies
that have been developed up to this
point and begin to scale them upward
and begin to apply them to
more and more collections?
So that will -- for our purposes
here today, that will begin
with a very, very brief
overview of NEH.
Many of you are already familiar,
some of you are actually awardees,
past awardees, but I realize
that there are some that are
from outside the U.S., so I will
give you the 30-second rundown
of what we do.
And that will kind of move
us into some of the projects
that we have supported along
audiovisual-related projects.
Mostly through research
and development, but,
as Jesse will indicate,
we have had support
through almost all of
our grant programs.
And so one of the things
that I think will become more
and more clear as we talk
about those programs is
that perhaps we could look at the
suite of programs that we offer
as a kind of paradigm
for how to begin
to support these new
approaches to preservation
and access going forward.
And Jesse will conclude with
a little bit of indication
of how interested NEH is
currently with the topic
of audiovisual preservation
and access.
We are ramping up our interest
more and more as we speak.
And so we're delighted to be here
and we thank the Library of Congress
for having us and hopefully
we will be able
to continue this dialogue both in
this panel and perhaps afterwards.
So, a little bit about NEH.
We're divided into a collection
of offices and divisions
that covers the scope of
humanities activities.
That includes everything from your
very basic individual fellowships
and research, and educational
opportunities, to development
of public programs, things like your
documentaries, museum exhibitions
and so forth, and, what
Jesse and I work on,
the Division of Preservation
and Access.
So we actually are
devoted to helping
to preserve humanities-related
collections, of all types,
audiovisual, archeological,
literary, historical, etcetera.
And so in the Division of
Preservation and Access,
we try to cover the entire range
of activities as best we can
that is related to the
basic care and stewardship
of humanities collections.
For all types of institutions,
I should indicate.
I know there is some
perhaps misperception
that we're only geared towards
the high research universities,
but that's simply not true.
We do our best to also reach
out to smaller institutions,
things like historical societies,
public libraries, small
museums, etcetera.
So that range of activities
of course can cover everything
from your basic intellectual
control.
Things like cataloguing,
arranging, describing.
Things like your basic conservation
treatment, reformatting, of course,
rehousing of collections.
We do digitize.
We have actually gone out into
the academic world and heard that,
"Well NEH doesn't digitize
any longer."
That's not true.
We love to digitize
audiovisual collections
and see projects of that sort.
We also do support the
development of databases,
spatial tools, reference resources.
And we're increasingly, in the
last, I would say five or six years,
moving towards sustainable solutions
for preventative conservation care.
And those are projects that
are to address the entirety
of a storage environment.
And we actually have a
few, a handful of projects,
related to audiovisual
collections on that front as well.
So, a little bit about where we
come from in terms of our support
for audiovisual preservation
and access.
And mostly, my job here today is
to focus on the R&D side of things,
since I think that's
kind of most in tune
with what we're talking
about here today.
So we can go back all
the way to the 1980s
and you probably won't find a
program specifically called R&D,
like you do today, but in
various forms over the years,
we supported very kind of
specialized research projects.
At the -- beginnng in the '80s and
'90s, a lot of those awards went
to the Image Permanence Institute
over at the Rochester
Institute of Technology.
Many of you are probably familiar
with the great work that they do.
They began in the mid to late-80s
working on, actually early '80s,
working on photographic prints and
then it's almost like a chronology
of audiovisual formats
and the projects
that they've worked
on over the years.
Moving through various formats,
landing in magnetic
media in the '90s.
And then in the early 2000s,
we started to see support
for a number of other institutions.
Many of you are may be familiar
with the Sound Directions Project
that was a collaboration between
Indiana University and Harvard.
Those were a series of projects
that eventually developed a set
of audio digitization guidelines.
So we're very proud of that.
One of the reasons we're proud
of that project is not only
for the R&D work that they did, but
the fact that it had such an impact
on the wider cultural
heritage field.
And so what we love
to see are projects
in our other grant programs,
particularly, for example,
in projects to digitize
specific collections
that are referencing the
sound directions guidelines
as the standard, or best practice,
that they are trying to adhere to.
So when we see R&D work
show up in footnotes
in our other grant programs,
it gives us a little chill
-- or thrill, if you will.
And also around this time,
in 2004, we got this kind
of curious project called
"Developing an Optical Method
to Recover Sound from
Mechanical Recording Media."
I was actually able to
dig the original file up
and it's quite a massive
collection of documents.
You see here one of the original
images for what then became IRENE.
So NEH was proud to be at the
kind of ground level for the work
that Carl and his team did
beginning back in 2004.
And obviously, you can see the
fruits of all that labor here today.
So, I won't go into the
history of the project,
since we've already gone quite
extensively, but I thought,
you know, seeing the early 2000s
kinds of technologies is kind
of a fun little trip
down memory lane.
But we do love the IRENE project
as a kind of exemplar of research
and development projects
that we've supported.
One is simply that it responded to
a real need in both preservation,
as well as in cultural
heritage fields.
And I think all of the speakers
that you've heard this morning
covered those needs quite well.
And then, I think a true testament
to the success of an R&D project is
that it then of course leads
to additional projects,
additional research.
And that could be in specifically
in an R&D type setting,
or it could lead to, as it did with
additional testing and evaluation,
but it could also lead
to reconsiderations
of broader stewardship practices,
and as Carl was hinting at,
shifts in how we think about
education and training as well.
So, that leads me a little
bit to talking about a few
of our main grant programs
coming out of the Division
of Preservation and Access.
And, again, for some of you this
might be of interest directly,
in thinking about getting
a project to us.
And, of course, whenever we go out,
we always love to field questions,
one-on-one types of questions, of
a project that you have in mind.
But, I think also, for the purposes
of this panel and for today, again,
the suite of programs that we
have can also be considered a kind
of framework for considering
how to expand all
of these great technologies
going forward.
So, the way we -- this
is one way of how we look
at our grant programming.
The core of what we do, the
foundation of program that we have,
is called "Humanities Collections
and Reference Resources."
And that's a program that is geared
to enhance the preservation
and/or access
of specific humanities collections.
So we get, again, institutions of
all shapes and sizes come to us
and say, "We have a great collection
of X and we need to do work,"
whether it's to rehouse
them, to catalogue them,
to reform them, etcetera.
And for us, that really
is our wheelhouse.
Our humanities collections.
Because it enables us to bring in
humanities practitioners, scholars,
curators, folks in the cultural
heritage sector, into our panel
and review setting and
conversing with preservationists
of all stripes, archivists,
librarians, and so forth.
But we realize that
the work that goes
into preserving a humanities
collection requires a lot
of other work that kind
of encircles that work.
And I'll be talking again a little
bit about research and development
and the particularities
of that program.
Sustaining cultural heritage
collections, as Jesse will explain,
tackles the preventative
issues as well.
And of course, there is education
and training, and we're very proud
to support a few audiovisual-related
projects in that realm as well.
So, R&D. We underwent an
intensive review of this program
in the last year-and-a-half or so.
We just received -- and we
restructured the program,
and we just received
that first batch
of applications a few weeks ago, so
that's beginning the review process.
So, in one sense, the good news is
that the next deadline
is an annual deadline,
and you have until June
21st of 2016 to think
about getting another project to us.
Again, this program is designed
to address major challenges
in preserving and providing access
to cultural heritage collections.
And it's also designed to support
the development of standards,
best practices, methodologies,
and work flows.
It supports applied research.
And then I know some of the
subsequent presentations coming
up will be talking about
considerations for how
to develop best practices
in this area.
So we have two tiers of funding,
and I'll give you the quick
specifics around those.
But I do want to add,
we are very proud
to support international
collaboration.
The only requirement being that the
primary applicant institution needs
to be a U.S. based institution.
But we have supported and will
continue to support projects
that show collaboration with
institutions outside the U.S. So,
again something to
consider going forward.
So, I mentioned that we have
two tiers of projects here.
So a Tier 1 project
is for up to $75,000.
And what we notice -- this
is really the newest aspect
of our R&D program, what we notice
is that if we only had one tier,
which was up to $350,000.00,
there can be a lot of great work
at these lower levels
that are getting squeezed
out from the limited
funding that NEH has.
These can be anything from
surveys to case studies,
to small scale experiments.
So, particularly in the field
that we're talking about here,
optical image preservation, I
think there could be a lot of cases
where these kind of small case
studies could really develop
valuable data that can be fed
back into the larger community.
And one of the things that we're
trying to emphasize with this level
as well is that this can be a
great opportunity for graduate
and post-doctoral training
and experience.
Secondly, we have a Tier 2 level.
Again, this is the higher level, for
up to 350,000 for up to three years.
And this is the whole
enchilada if you will.
We want to see projects
that are really striving
to develop best practices
standards, methodologies, workflows,
that can reach a very
broad preservation
and cultural heritage audience.
So, one of the things that
we changed with this program
and this might be something that we
could pick up again during the Q&A
and beyond, is this
notion of dissemination.
So we have a lot of great projects
coming out of R&D over the years
and we always did require
a short section
that we called dissemination.
But over the last few years, we
were getting dissemination plans
that included, "Well, we'll
develop a blog, but we will kind
of update every once in a while,
and then we'll get on Twitter
and we'll tweet it
every now and then.
And -- or on Facebook."
And somehow this whole community
is going to just magically pick
up all this great new
knowledge and run with it.
And in some cases that
was true, and it worked.
But I think in a lot of cases,
the dissemination plan failed
to match the great work that was
being conducted at the R&D level.
And if you are going to be -- if
you are going to develop standards
and best practices, you have to
really engage the community, right?
You have to really understand
what the communities' needs are
and how they are going to receive
that knowledge and work with it,
and begin to accept those
best practices going forward.
So, we tried to elevate our
dissemination plan a little bit.
We require a one to
two-page appendix that --
and we're asking a
kind of demonstration
that you understand how
to reach your community
that you define within
your application.
And, of course, there's
a whole suite
of possible dissemination
activities that can fall into a kind
of creative plan, which can run
from workshops and training,
to educational modules,
publications, and then we're getting
into things like code
sprints and conferences.
And, of course, if you're looking
at getting a standard accepted,
of course that will require
communication with a kind
of regulatory body in some cases.
So, the bottom line is we
would love to see R&D projects
that are interdisciplinary.
And, again, I think this came up
in some of the earlier discussions
about ways in which the
work being conducted
on a very technical level can
link up with some of the work
of the cultural heritage field.
And I think the project
that Carl mentioned earlier,
the linguistics project,
which I think Jesse will talk
about further, is a great example.
So we're striving to see projects
that are interdisciplinary
in nature, international, again,
that sort of merge the
humanities and the sciences.
And of course, the sciences, when
we're talking about preservation,
can run the gamut from
the information sciences,
to computer science,
natural sciences, of course,
and many cases here today, and
conservation science as well.
So, I feel -- I think
I would be remiss
if I didn't actually give an
example of an optical audio project,
besides supporting
IRENE in its early days.
And so we've actually supported a
project coming out of the University
of South Carolina, which
they call EF -- AEO Light.
Is anyone familiar with AEO Light?
A little bit, yeah.
Okay. So this is again why
dissemination is so important.
This is actually related
to the film community.
So, I don't know if I'm committing
heresy talking about film
in an audio media environment,
but I think it's applicable here.
So, as you can see in this image
here of a still from a film
of Martin Luther King, Jr.,
you see the optical track
running on the side.
So, what the project director,
who is Greg Wilsbacher,
he is collaborating with
the mathematical institute
at South Carolina.
And what they're doing is
essentially very similar
to what we've been
talking about here today.
They are creating images --
digitized images of 60 millimeter,
35 millimeter film, which
captures both the optical sound,
as well as the image.
They're even going so far as to go
all the way out to the sprockets,
and I'll show you why in a second.
So -- and then what they
do is run an algorithm
that extracts the optical
sound and links it
with the digitized film images.
Apologies for my email
going off like that.
So, why is this significant?
Why was it funded by NEH?
Well, quite simply, what
they're hoping to accomplish,
and I think they're getting to it by
their second phase of their project,
is essentially cutting
perhaps not completely in half,
but close to half, the time
it takes to digitize a film.
The process traditionally is
to capture the image first
and then the audio second, and
then link them up afterwards.
They're saying by capturing
audio and image simultaneously,
and then linking them through this
mathematical software program,
you can digitize the
film in half the time.
And that's the hope.
And I think they're
getting along their way.
So if you go to their site,
you can actually download
their software program.
It's open source.
I think they would be thrilled
to hear from a lot of you
to get your feedback on that.
And of course I'll play just a
very short clip of a test clip
that they have on their
website here, so bear with me.
Hopefully this will work.
And this is a film of
Benito Mussolini from 1931,
I believe from their Fox Movieton
[assumed spelling] collection.
[ Playing Film ]
So you can see the audio track
on the left hand side running
simultaneously to the image,
and you can see, of course, the
words on the very far edge of this.
And the argument goes
that from a kind
of digital humanities standpoint,
this is valuable information.
This is essentially
providential information
that certain humanity
scholars, media scholars,
film scholars might find
quite valuable to help date
and locate [inaudible]
of their film.
So with that I'm going to turn off
my e-mail and hand it over to Jesse.
[ Applause ]
>> Joshua Johnston: As Josh said,
he's talking more about the research
and development sorts of
projects that we've supported
that are somewhat related to the
IRENE and audio imaging efforts.
And I'm going to talk about
the rest of our programs,
and hopefully give you an
idea of some of the ways
that they can support some of
the efforts that are happening
in the audio preservation world.
The Humanities Collections
and Reference Sources program,
which is one that Josh has already
mentioned, is our largest program.
And it's really focused on
advancing preservation and access
for specific collections, as
Josh said, or also the design
of reference resources, like
dictionaries and grammars.
And in both of these areas it's
actually supported audio projects.
So as you can see, we're sort
of illustrating what these
programs can do by way of example.
But if you have specific
questions about what sorts
of activities are eligible or
ineligible, technically speaking,
we can answer those
questions at the end.
The examples I think are
probably most interesting,
so I'll focus on those now.
In 2012 the University of North
Carolina received an award,
many of you are probably aware
of the Southern [inaudible]
Collection there
and they're preserving audio
recordings and photographs
that document traditional
music and musicians
of southeastern United States.
And that actually is a hybrid
collection, so there's a lot
of audio there, but this
is an archival collection
that also has photographs,
related field notes as well.
And so hybrid collections
are certainly something
that we frequently see, given
that our collections really cross
the broad range of documentation
of humanities activities.
In the Reference Resources category
of this program we've also
supported discographic projects,
including what's become the
American Discography Project,
which grew out of the
Encyclopedia Discography
of [inaudible] Recordings at
the University of California
in Santa Barbara, which
received an award in 2011,
and a couple of other times.
Recently we've supported a new level
in this program called Foundations,
which offers support for
sort of early stage projects.
So if all of the technical
details perhaps aren't set,
hoping to bring together maybe
technical preservation people
with humanities scholars
to lay the foundations
as it were for future projects.
I also want to tell
you about the Education
and Training program that we offer.
This is a program that also, like
R&D, has been longstanding priority
at any age, and we've supported
preservation education and training
in various forms since the 1980s
when we took over a program
of regional field services
that was previously funded
by the National Endowment
for the Arts.
And these now offer basic
preservation services,
such as preservation
assessments, rehousing supplies,
conducting emergency
preparedness workshops.
And you're going to
hear a lot more from one
of those services in a moment.
And they can sort of be the example.
But this program also
supports other things.
It supports master degree programs,
and it also supports workshops
that address preservation
and access topics
of national significance
and broad impact.
And we include there in our
guidelines that the preservation of
and provision of access
to recorded sound
and moving image collections is one
of the priorities in this program.
I think that it would be
accurate to say that we hope
to continue that priority.
And also, to give you an idea,
we have supported in the past.
For example, we've supported an
award to New York University in 2014
that provides scholarships
to students
in the Moving Image Archiving
and Preservation program,
for doing up to 24 internships, that
is 24 students doing internships
at cultural heritage institutions
in the New York metropolitan area.
The Center for the
Conservation of Art
and Historical Artifacts also
has offered audio workshops
through their preservation
field service,
as have some of the other ones.
The Documenting Endangered Languages
program is a unique program
that we have, it's a partnership
with the National Science
Foundation.
Carl has already mentioned the award
that we recently made in partnership
with the National Science Foundation
to the university of
California Berkley.
And this, I guess at least the
second award that NHS has made,
which supports an IRENE
focused project.
And, as you know, they're
working on digitizing cylinders
of Native American languages
gathered in California.
It's a very unique collection
with high value to the humanities
for documenting early history
of anthropology, as well as,
and this is why it came
to the Documenting
Endangered Languages program,
documentation of languages that
are no longer spoken or they may be
in a sort of [inaudible]
state and very few speakers,
or an aging speaker population.
We feel that these are
invaluable for scholarly research
and broader purposes of cultural
and linguistic revitalization.
And as you heard when the
project was mentioned earlier,
this is actually supported an
internal institutional collaboration
between different units
of the university,
as well as Lawrence Berkeley labs.
And so we hope that is an example
that points to sort of the power
of these programs to help
to encourage that sort
of cross institutional and
inter institutional work.
I'll just say a few words in
conclusion about our priority
on audio/visual preservation.
You have a better sense
now, I think,
of our divisions main grant programs
and how they related to preservation
and access of audio/visual
materials.
And we have placed a priority on the
preservation of audio/visual content
through various efforts,
some of which I've covered
here, since at least 2000.
So for about 15 years.
And in 2001, I believe, we supported
a symposium here at the Library
in cooperation with some of the
other agencies and the Library
on preserving folklore
documentation.
And that was kind of a
first step and we hope
that we're continuing in that vain.
Our hope in sharing with you
some of the audio/visual projects
that we've discussed today, and that
NEH has supported over the years,
is partly to remind you that our
grant programming can support a wide
spectrum of preservation activities,
from research and development
to education, to digital
reformatting.
We also want to communicate
to you that we are interested
in exploring options
for participating
and supporting this
effort in better ways.
We've heard the need to consider
areas as far ranging as format
and playback equipment obsolescence,
mass collection assessments,
selection and appraisal,
quote storage for films,
professional training, and
continued research and development.
But we do hope to hear from those
working in these fields directly
about how we could
better support that effort
in a continuing way in the future.
However, in a restricted
resource environment we do hope
that in the spirit of the National
Recording Preservation Plan,
and all other calls to action
that we are aware of as funders,
we do want to facilitate the maximum
impact of what is a small amount
of financial resources by
fostering collaboration
and coordination among many
stakeholder communities,
which is why we've stressed that
theme of collaboration throughout.
Many people that we've
spoken to have reminded us
that audio/visual collections are
often overlooked, whether that's
for lack of funding, preservation
experience, or simply lack
of interest in relation to
other types of collections,
or perhaps lacks of
technical familiarity among
collection stewards.
Given NEH's connection
to the scholarly
and professional communities,
we think that our --
one of our contributions as a funder
can be to bring together the voices
of scholars and researchers and
other audiences for these materials
with preservation communities.
That's sort of one of the unique
positions that the Division
of Preservation and Access occupies.
In fact, we believe that only
with the voice of content
and subject specialists,
including many that are here
and who may be speaking tomorrow,
can effective arguments be made
for the significance and importance
for expending scarce resources
that are required to
select, access, reformat,
and use the many audio/visual
resources
that face uncertain futures.
And finally, by reaching
out various user audiences,
including researchers and educators,
we hope to raise greater awareness
of the scale of the challenge
of audio/visual preservation,
which as many of you know is great.
And we also hope to foster clearer
understandings of the various uses,
approaches and ways to make
choices that confront us
as we face this audio/visual
preservation challenge.
If you're interested in our programs
you can ask us questions after this.
You can also contact us on e-mail
and here's our contact information.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Bill Veillette: So hi
everybody, I'm Bill Veillette,
I'm the Executive Director
of the Northeast Document
Conservation Center.
Very quickly, we're in some
respects the odd man in the room
because we're actually a paper
and book conservation center.
And you might ask why are we
involved with audio preservation.
Well, back in the '70s we
started doing microfilming
and film duplication.
And then in 2008, because
it was hard to get film,
and I'm very impressed that you
can still get it in Switzerland,
the transitioned the imaging over --
the microfilming and film
duplication to digital imaging.
And then at that point,
because there's so much involved
in post processing
with digital transfer,
it didn't become a very big leap for
us to start thinking about audio.
And in fact most our
clients are archivists,
not obviously audio engineers.
And many, many archivists are
also charged with the stewardship
of audio collections, but
they're scared to death.
So here we are as a nonprofit that's
been serving them for over 40 years,
they're very comfortable with us and
trust us, and they started asking us
to get involved with audio.
So that's why we are here today.
That led to a conversation
with the Institute for Museum
and Library Services to take a
look at this thing called IRENE.
This is a few years ago.
And we ended up writing a
grant to do a pilot to see
if we could take IRENE from the
lab successfully to the market,
so to speak, and use it not
as a scientific instrument,
but as a reformatting
production tool.
So these were the -- these were
the principle goals of the project.
There were other questions as well,
but I thought those
other ones wouldn't be
as interesting to this audience.
But the first one -- but
you can read them here.
We were curious about
these kinds of question
because these are the
questions that go
into whether we could
sustain a service,
and run it without losing money
and going out of -- going bankrupt.
So I'll just cycle us
through these questions.
First of all, what we did find
was that it is actually quite easy
to learn to operate the
IRENE system with a person
of average intelligence,
however you want to define that.
It starts to become a
little bit more difficult
when there are mechanical issues,
so you do need some greater
than normal mechanical aptitude
to do some troubleshooting.
If you are all thumbs and
have no mechanical aptitude,
this is probably not
the technology for you
at this stage in its development.
But in terms of the software,
although software is very stable
and it's not particularly buggy,
which we felt very good about.
We were concerned that it might
be crashing every 10 minutes
and we can't get anything done,
that is not the case at all.
But when you want to make an
enhancement or a tweak or something,
that requires a callback to
Lawrence Berkeley National Labs.
So almost half jokingly, but not
really, we have said that we need
to take He-Man life insurance out on
Earl Cornell, which is a little bit
of a morbid thought,
Earl, sorry about that,
but we haven't gotten
it, don't worry.
Okay, in terms of the hardware,
we did receive this upgrade model,
you've all heard about that, you saw
pictures of it that Carl presented.
It has the 2D and the
3D on the same platform
so that we could switch easily to 3D
to scan a disc without having to go
through a lot of extra setup.
There are some issues, though.
As parts get upgraded
or replaced, there is --
there are some issues with
having to then potentially have
to modify the software, and even
the firmware, the OEM might have
to make some modifications.
So we saw that with I
think our probe, you know,
early on where we had
to go back to the OEM
and ask them to make some changes.
But the good news is
that it's very reliable.
Once it works, it works,
mechanically
and in terms of the software.
Now, there are some challenges,
and we'll segue to Mason
in a second here where he'll talk
about some challenges that had more
to do with the carriers themselves
and having to do some fussing
because of the optical approach.
Okay, what I really want to focus
on here is some of the questions
that were being asked earlier in the
day which is, so if you're trying
to use this as a tool, how practical
is it, how much can you get done.
And in our case our clients want to
know, what is this going to cost.
Now, there are three variables to
providing this kind of a service.
One is, you're efficiency,
which is how many billable hours
out of all the paid hours in
the day your staff can work.
The next is the billing rate which
has more to do with NEDCCs overhead.
And then finally the productivity,
which is ultimately
the ultimate measure,
which is how many recording
you can do per billable hour.
So in terms of efficiency it
actually has nothing to do
with IRENE or any piece of
equipment that you're using.
This is how many hours
out of the day you're able
to bill your time out.
So you're taking out
any administrative time
and you're reducing it down to how
many hours am I actually serving
a client.
So that really has to do
with the operator, you know,
their work ethic, the work
ethic in the workplace.
And we start work at 8:30, are
people serving clients at 8:31,
or are they kind of getting
around to it after a couple
of cups of coffee, right?
The billing rate also
nothing to do with IRENE,
has all to do with the
costs of labor and overhead.
But productivity has
to d with two things,
it has to do with the operator
and their workflow habits
within the constraints of the tool.
So, what are the constraints
of the tool?
Well, in our case one of the
things we were trying to test
with the pilot was, you know,
could we operate multiple IRENE
machines at once by one operator.
And our conclusion at this stage
is, with our current configuration
of the machine, it would be
impractical to try to have more
than one machine person, and you'll
see why in a second, I have a slide.
But we need to be mindful that
in the, you know, 12 or 15 years
of development of IRENE,
the focus has not been
on its production capacity, it's
been on the science of imaging
and analyzing those images.
So there's this now new phase
of opportunity to start focusing
in addition on productivity.
So these are not problems
with IRENE,
these are opportunities
going forward.
There is a little bit of
multitasking you can do.
Once you've scanned
your first carrier,
you could be scanning the second
carrier while you're analyzing the
first one, okay?
So there's a little bit of
two to one workflow for all
but the first and last recordings.
And then, because of that, the first
and the last recordings
are 50% more expensive.
So all this means is that we say
to clients, look, if you have more
than one carrier, don't send
them to us one at a time.
Bunch them up and help us help
you by making these projects --
you know, scaling these
projects up a little bit,
because we can get you
-- save you some money.
So, you know, here's what we
can do with our one machine.
We can start a scan and then while
recording one is being analyzed we
can start scanning
recording two, etcetera.
Until finally, at the end of the
day, you know, you're just kind
of analyzing the last one.
Now you could be recording something
for the next morning, of course,
but this just an example of if
you had an eight carrier project.
Now two to one with IRENE is not the
same as two to one with a stylus.
Two to one in real time means
that you can't be doing
two things at once.
Or rather you're attending
to two things at once,
so one of those things that
you're not paying attention
to is not being paid attention to.
But two to one with a
scanning approach means
that the imaging can be unattended,
which is okay because
there's really nothing
to do while it's being imaged.
I mean, you could watch
it as it's being imaged,
but there's no point in doing that.
But the analysis is
always attended, okay.
So it's -- there's not this issue
that people are concerned about,
you know, 12 to 1 workflows,
because the vendors is
really not paying attention
to what they're doing, right,
they're just more focused
on their own bottom line.
So here's an example.
At NEDCC we strive
for 90% efficiency.
In other words, we want 90% of
the seven and a half hour workday
to be focused on clients and
not on admin stuff and things
that would be distracting.
So that translates
to 6.75 hours a day.
Our billing rate is $125 an hour.
And if takes 90 minutes to scan
and analyze a single carrier,
using that graph that I
showed you previously,
we could do eight carriers a day.
So if you do the math on
that, it's $105 per recording.
Now, it can get quite
a bit more expensive
if the recordings are broken
or cracked or dirty we have
to clean them, you know,
there could be added costs.
If they're, you know, large
discs, bigger cylinders
and those kinds of things.
So there is this opportunity, as
I mentioned, to now start to --
now that we know the
technology works
and in some cases it works
better than the stylus approach
because we can get more signal,
there is this opportunity now
to start focusing in
addition on productivity.
And you've heard Carl talk --
he gave you the picture
of the shish kabob design,
which we're very interested in,
but he also just verbally described
some other approaches you could do
by just throwing cameras
at the situation.
I was talking with Earl about
this at lunch and, you know,
we were talking about some of the
challenges and the bottlenecks,
and what might seem expensive
in terms of equipment
from our standpoint is a cheap date.
Because when you're billing
out at $125 an hour, you know,
if you had to spend $500
for some component or $1000
for some component to cut the
time in half, that's nothing.
You know, you can make that back
within hours, you know, or days.
So really this is -- you know,
this isn't a physicist math,
this is a business persons math.
But I would not discount spending
a lot of extra money, frankly,
to speed up the process, because
you'll get it back in production.
We just need to do the
back of the envelope math.
So at this point what I'm going
to do is turn it over to Mason,
who's going to describe some of the
challenges the physical carriers
that can throw a big time wrench
into that graph I showed you
where we could do eight
units per day.
>> Mason Vander Lugt: Hi
everybody, can you hear me?
I'm Mason Vander and I
operate the IRENE at NEDCC.
I'm going to try to make this quick
because I've got a presentation
of my own that we're
kind of going over.
So none of us expected IRENE to be
ready off the shelf when we got it.
We understood we were kind of
inheriting a complicated technology
that was combining
image sensors, lasers,
vibration isolation, networking.
So we expected a lot of that
and had a lot of small problems
that were mostly kind of bug fixes,
hours on the phone
with Earl and Carl.
But kind of one of the
most standing issue
that we still [inaudible] is
making lacquer disking a little
more reliable.
So the biggest problem with lacquer
discs is that they can be difficult
to image, and we saw this
earlier in Stefano's presentation,
that the groove bottom isn't
always visible and that's
where we want to get our audio from.
So this is actually a shellac
disc on the corner of the screen
and it -- I'll explain a little bit
more about how these images work
in my own talk, but what you
see is a number of grooves,
the vertical blank lines.
In the middle of each black
line is another white line,
which represents the
bottom of the groove.
So that's -- you know, when I see
that I know I can get good
sound from these images.
Lacquer discs are cut instead
of pressed, and so in the middle
of groove, instead of a clear
groove bottom we often seen nothing.
If it's an angle it doesn't
really reflect light.
So we see this, you know,
just the black line.
So this is an example
of the lacquer disc.
One of the ways we've tried to get
around this problem is
by using side lighting.
So instead of illuminating
the imaging from the top,
we bring in a light from
the side at an angle
and it gets a different part
of the groove, and these kind
of thicker white lines are the
bottom corner of a groove, I guess.
It can act as a groove bottom and
we can get good audio from that.
The problem is that
it takes a lot longer.
Another way to get
around this problem is
to analyze the groove tops instead.
Again, this takes a lot longer
and doesn't produce the same kind
of audio we expect
from a groove bottom.
I need to go back a minute.
So these are things that we'd
like to see become more reliable.
Using either side lighting
or the groove top analysis we can
usually get something from a disc,
it's just not the eight
recordings a day that we
like to keep productive with.
Another problem we have with
lacquer discs is a loss of focus.
Lacquer discs, while lacquer itself
is transparent or translucent,
instead of the kind of opaque
and textured shellac discs.
So the lasers we use to
detect the recording's surface
and move the camera to stay in focus
sometimes see through the lacquer
and read the bottom of
the discs, or see texture
in [inaudible] oxidation.
And because IRENE uses such
a small depth to focus,
even very slight misreading
in the [inaudible] system,
which is the laser, can cause
an instant of loss of focus.
And there are a couple ways we've
talked about working around this,
like increasing the depth of
focus, or using a different system
to detect the recording's surface.
And then finally one of the
ways we lose time frequently
with lacquer discs is a
difference in tracking them.
As Carl described, tracking is
telling the computer software
where the groove goes through
the image, so from kind of top
to bottom of the image and across.
Lacquer discs can be a huge range
of different types of
recording's, really.
So from commercial masters that
are predictable and well recorded
to basically toys and
paper based [inaudible].
And I'll get into this more
in my next talk as well.
But this is a shellac disc
and it's a commercial disc.
But often we see something more
like this, where I don't know
if the recordist wasn't trained,
or the machine wasn't calibrated,
but the grooves run together.
And then when the software is
trying to track this automatically,
it doesn't have the same information
and kind of skips grooves or,
you know, reads in between the lines
and creates these kind
of blue things.
And then I have to go
through and manually track.
So this is the [inaudible]
tracking algorithm.
And the other automatic
tracking we use is new tracking,
and that uses the groove bottom.
And so often if there isn't a
groove bottom, or if there's texture
in the top of the groove,
like we see in this scratch
here, it just skips grooves.
And so, again, I can work around
this using manual tracking,
it's just one of the things that
cuts into our time if we're trying
to keep any kind of
meaningful workflow.
So I'll turn it back to Bill
and I'll be back up in a minute.
>> Bill Veillette: So, you know,
another consequence of some
of these issues with the
carriers that you don't are there
until you can scanned is that, you
know, one thing clients expect is
when you give them a
proposal, they want to know
that the price is the price.
So, you know, we do have some
caveats in the proposal to say,
you know, sometimes we can't
see the groove bottom, etcetera.
And so far so good, you know, people
have been pretty understanding
that the technology is, you
know, still being developed.
Okay, just a couple slides to end.
We got a big grant from the
Mellon Foundation to do a study
of the audio preservation
market because we're planning
on getting further
into audio preservation
by reformatting magnetic media.
And so we hired AV Preserve
to do this study and they --
and this is just a little data
point out of it where they found
that there are 46 million
preservation worthy grooved carriers
that require a specialized workflow.
Now, this 46 million happens to be
the same number as the 46 million
that the Heritage Health Index came
up with for all audio back in 2005.
AV Preserve's number now
is 250 million audio items.
And there's a paper
where they can defend
that number that I'll refer you to.
You can Google it.
But, you know, this 46 million
isn't all rare groove carriers
like wax cylinders
and lacquer discs.
But presuming we just use that
number, if we can do 1720 cylinders
or discs per year based
on 215 productive days,
in a best case scenario, and
you do the math over 50 years,
you would need 535 IRENE
machines over 50 years
to complete all this work, if you
did them all with IRENE machines,
which is not appropriate.
They're appropriate for certain
materials, and less so for others.
But the point here is
that prioritization
and selection is going
to be critical.
So our counsel to clients
is that, IRENE is best used
for delicate recordings
that are unique, rare.
Recordings that are rare formats
where the equipment may not be
available to play them otherwise.
And then the obvious one
that everybody thinks of,
and we don't need to tell them,
is damaged and broken media.
But we specifically say to
them, please don't, you know,
use it for commercial recordings,
we want to reserve our time
on our IRENE machine for people who
have these other types of materials.
The final thing that we were charged
with in our IMLS grant was to figure
out if there was a way we could
help sustain R&D for IRENE.
And there were lots of different
things we were talking about,
but this turns out to be really
probably the best way we could help.
We had some focus groups that
were not part of the IMLS project,
or part of the that
Mellon funded study,
but we kind of folded some
IRENE questions into it,
and found out that
clients are willing to pay
up to 15% more for
an optical approach.
And remember, most of these
clients are archivists,
they're not audio engineers,
and they're just --
you know, these are
people who don't like to --
anybody to touch anything.
So it's very appealing to
them the noncontact approach,
and they're willing to
pay a premium for it.
The question is, can we use this
15% to support our R&D and would
that provide enough
money to move the needle.
So if you do the math on our
billable hours and our rate
and whatnot, the bottom
line is it comes
out to $27,000 per IRENE
machine that we could feed back
to the effort to develop
the system further.
So that might seem
like a small amount,
but really the world needs more
than one IRENE machine
providing services.
And so it could end up
being a pretty good amount
as you multiply this by
the number of machines
that are put into production.
Finally, our study
found out that 46%
of perspective clients
could not proceed
with their audio projects
unless they had a grant.
So if you do the math on that
as well, knowing that based
on the previous slide we
need $208 [sic] per year
to sustain each IRENE machine at
full capacity, we need to make sure
that there are enough grant
programs out there to the tune
of $96,000 per machine
to sustain the machine.
Otherwise we actually get starved of
kind of capital which is the oxygen
for doing all sorts of
-- any kind of work.
So that's our presentation.
If you want to learn more we have a
very robust section of our website
where we describe the
service in more detail,
what the deliverables are, you
know, what is part of the proposal,
these caveats that I mentioned.
And we also have some very good
examples about how to clean discs
that we put up there based on
[inaudible] vetted approach and how
to ship and pack and
all that kind of stuff.
So it's a very interesting
website in terms of, you know,
understanding how an optical
scanning service is being presented
to perspective clients, so I
encourage you to go there to look
at those kinds of things.
So at this point I'm going
to turn it over to Mason
who has a really interesting
presentation.
I know we're running late on
time, but let me just pause here
and get his up and
we'll get him going.
>> Mason Vander Lugt: All right,
so I want to talk a little bit
about using images for not
their intended purpose.
What am I going to talk about?
So we use IRENE because
it is contact free
and doesn't risk our recordings.
But as an intermediary step we
are left with these digital images
that are very high
magnification and high resolution.
And I think these images
are pretty useful.
If we take a step back I
think they can teach us
about the recordings themselves,
the degradation of the recordings
and also help us improve the
operation of our IRENE system.
So I think some of you -- everybody
understands this at this point.
IRENE uses 2D and a 3D camera.
They're both line scan
cameras, and so we take a pass,
the cylinder rotates, we
move on to the second pass.
And over time we're
left with a complete map
of the surface to the recording.
So the natural proportions
of the images,
their width is constrained
by the image sensor.
But we want to take
enough image samples
so we can get the desired
audio sample rate.
So this long black line on the left
is actually the natural proportion
of the image.
If we zoom in at full resolution
we're left with this middle image.
And then there's another
kind of image I'll show today
that is a little bit
less easy to understand,
but we call them binned images.
And this is what we do when we're
analyzing software to help us --
analyzing the data,
rather, to help us track.
And we sample the image vertically
so we can get a full picture
of where the grooves go
without having to scroll
through a long image like this.
So this is just a condensed --
vertically condensed image
like the one on the left.
So what can we learn
from the pictures?
One of the things is objective
information like groove width.
So this is a series of
four different types
of disc recordings organized
in descending order
by their groove width.
The top is a voice-o-graph disc, and
the bottom is a microgroove disc.
So they range from 110
micrometers at the top
to 50 micrometers at the bottom.
We can also gain qualitative
information.
So when I see these I know what kind
of audio we'll get
from the recording.
On the left it's a commercially
produced wax recording,
and on the right it's a
field recorded wax recording.
And just based on the training
of the recordist, the conditions
in the field where it was recorded,
and the type of machine
it was recorded on,
it change the audio quality we get.
And when I see these images,
I kind of get an idea of what
to expect from the audio.
So like I said before, this is
a binned image of the grooves.
So you can see where the
grooves go throughout the image.
This is a commercial
shellac recording,
so this is about as
consistent as it gets.
The grooves are evenly spaced,
and they all have groove
bottoms, I believe.
This is the image that I used
in my other presentation.
Sometimes they are not recorded
as well and the image --
the grooves move throughout
the image.
This is another example, this is
from a paper based lacquer disc
and the groove spacing is terrible.
It was planned well for the
excursion of the grooves.
And I don't know what you would get
if you played this on a turntable.
But if you look at it under IRENE
you know that you're not going
to get something that you want.
This is another kind of
poorly recorded disc.
You can see the cutting lathe was
not set to record deeply enough,
so once a revolution actually lifted
from the disc leaving a
section where it was undercut.
This is something,
again, if you play it
on a turntable you would
probably come to understand
that something is wrong
with the disc.
But we see very clearly
now what's going on.
And, you know, beyond
assessment one thing we can do
with IRENE is actually just
trace across these gaps
and at least get all of the
information that is recorded.
Obviously can't get
anything that wasn't.
Here's another example.
I turned the image on its side, just
because I think it's interesting.
It was kind of undercut or maybe
the recording machine wasn't working
at its best that day, but the head
actually skipped across the surface.
Each of these black lines is
a groove, and at some point
in the recording process it skipped
across the surface like a stone.
This is a cylinder that was
overcut, and this is another one
of these we're comparing
with a mechanical transfer.
We wouldn't have known exactly
why this happened playing it
with a stylus, just that in two
sections it would get quiet.
But looking at it under IRENE we
can see exactly why it got quiet is
because it was overcutting
and the stylus wouldn't
have read this fully.
This is just a fun example,
can't really learn much from it,
but it's interesting
to look at, I think.
And another tin foil where
you can see kind of the nature
of the impression on the foil.
So my examples up until now have
been about what we can learn
from the original recordings
as they were recorded,
but we can also learn a
lot of interesting things
about how recordings get
damaged or degrade over time.
This is another paper
based lacquer disc.
This is the first couple grooves,
kind of a run in groove,
a lead in groove.
And you can see that it's
just a mess, it's in tatters.
It wasn't recorded well,
but you can also see,
through subsequent playbacks,
I guess high tracking
[inaudible] dragged across it
and created extra grooves.
I think this actually
was recorded twice.
I think this is another
cutting head was put
on the disc and cut in the track.
As we progress through this we
see more new tracks, more wear.
And as we progress we see
some kind of chattering
up in the top, some inconsistency.
If we zoom into that we can
see the disc was actually bent.
The paper is more flexible
than the lacquer,
and so when you bend the paper based
lacquer disc the surface lacquer
crazes and leave us with something
we couldn't get a whole lot
of audio from.
Here's another example
of a crazing disc.
You can see the actual
grooves in this image.
Don't look like the grooves
in most of IRENE images,
and that's because it's
actually a white disc,
that leaves us with less contrast.
And that's another challenge for us
is figuring out how to image these
and get the same contrast that
will allow us to get good audio.
So continuing on in the
damage and degradation,
this is a disc that delaminating.
And you can see it's a lacquer
disc that was delaminating.
I think you all understand what that
means, but the surface material,
the lacquer, and the bases
don't always stick together well
over time, and the pieces kind
of can separate from the surface
and separate from each other.
And zooming into this, you
can see that the places
where it began delaminating the
lacquer was actually pulling apart
and it separated at the thinnest
part, which is the groove bottom.
I think that's interesting.
So we can learn something about the
nature of the delamination process.
Here's another image of a flake of a
lacquer disc that was delaminating.
There's a bit of an illusion here,
as the camera loses
focus below this line,
but you can see this piece was
flaking up and didn't keep in focus.
And you can see the light shines
through the translucent lacquer.
Here's another condition I think
a lot of you are familiar with.
This disc was exuding
plasticizer, and looking at it
under the magnification or IRENE,
we can actually see the
crystalline structure
of the fatty acids that came out.
And it's interesting to me to see
that the same structure is
present beneath the groove bottom,
so that's throughout the disc.
Here's a broken glass based
lacquer disc where you can see --
so the disc broke, but also chipped
away at the interface of the break.
And you can see the
sheer of the glass chip.
And also if you look closely you
can see the texture of the glass,
the bubbles in the glass.
Here's a frayed paper
based lacquer disc.
This is a voice-o-graph
disc, it was a voice letter
from the Second World War that
had been played too many times,
and wore away the lacquer
in this area.
And you can see the
paper base beneath it,
but you can also see the
lacquer was kind of pulling away
and the thickest part in
the groove tops remained.
You can kind of see this when you
look at the disc at eye level,
but this gives us a lot more
information about how this happened.
Here's a disc that was
covered in adhesive residue
and left glue covering the groove
bottoms and the groove tops.
Just we couldn't see
through this at all.
And a similar one where a disc had
been written in with wax crayon
and it filled the grooves but
left the groove tops alone.
And here is a disc that was damaged
with some kind of mysterious
pitting.
I don't really know what caused
this, but the disc was very noisy.
I think you can actually see
the disc is splitting again
down the middle of
this groove as well.
Groove-top wear, this
is what it looks
like when we play a
disc and it's noisy.
And so I'll go through a couple
similar examples for cylinders.
This is what we expect to see
from a clean commercial cylinder.
They're vertically
recorded, as you all know,
so the grooves don't go side to
side as in a [inaudible] recording,
but up and down and that's
why you see the pits in here.
This is what mold damage
looks like under IRENE.
You see the audio grooves on
the left side of the recording,
on the left side of the image, and
the mold damage on the right side.
One thing I think is interesting
about this is that the mold seems
to have taken up residence in
the pits created by the audio.
This is -- you can see
impressions made by the fibers
of original wax cylinder
recording container,
and this is actually
useful information for us.
It tells us that you don't really
want to store wax cylinders
in the original cut
and line containers
because they can leave marks in your
disc that will be audible later.
Similarly this is a
brown wax cylinder
that was beginning to
effloresce or bloom.
This is kind of -- I don't think
there's a lot of research on this,
but this at least shows
me that this is not mold,
it's actually a different
failure mode.
Here's a talk doll
cylinder recording,
as Carl mentioned earlier.
This is what they look
like kind of typically.
And then you can see one
that had been played more.
I don't know if the first has been
played never and the second once,
or the first only a few times,
and the second many times,
but you can see the wear in the
middle, it's these black lines
that have been played by a stylus.
So finally we can use the
images and also images produced
by the analysis software
to assess our performance.
The reason I have this image
here is because this motor,
if it's off in alignment by
fractions of a degree vertically
or in the [inaudible] into
and out of this image,
we can lose focus throughout
the image.
And one of the ways we can calibrate
that so that doesn't happen is
by using the depth information
gathered by the 3D probe,
and the same information
in another plane gathered
by the [inaudible] laser.
So in order to prevent
artifacts in our sound
and 3D we want our images
to align very precisely.
It's sounds like it would just be
360 degrees around and the width
of the sensor in a
step, but that leaves us
with small duplication in the data.
So what we do is guess and
check until there's no overlap,
but the features of the
recording are visible smoothly
across the lines at the end of a
pass, as you see on the left side,
in between passes as you
see on the right side.
So this is what we want
to see from tracking.
When I began working
with IRENE in fall
of 2013 we couldn't leave the
software to analyze on its own
because we didn't have any
indication whether tracking
went successful.
So we asked them to
add tracking images
so we could leave the
software to analyze overnight
and review tracking in the morning,
which means I can do
other things instead
of watching the software analyze.
This is what we have at risk
if we don't know whether
the tracking was successful.
But if I see this, looking
at tracking images in review,
I can go back and redo this and
it won't give us faulty audio.
We can also see how
blob clean is doing.
I don't know if anybody has
described blob clean at this point.
But it's a way of cleaning
up the sound only
because the software can tell, based
on the shape of the pits in 3D,
and the depth, what's
mold and what's audio.
If we are too aggressive with this
algorithm, it can remove audio.
But we can review the images
while we're analyzing and see
that this one actually did a pretty
good job figuring out what was blobs
or mold spots and what was audio.
And so we know we're
using the right settings
for the blob clean algorithm.
So this is a dirty licensee disc.
Not really exuding
plasticizer, mostly just dirty,
but we can't really get
great audio from this.
So when I began working
with IRENE we looked
into ways we could improve our data.
Fortunately somebody from
Preservation Research
and Testing here was
already working on this
and we adopted a cleaning
method from his process,
and ended up being
really successful with it.
This is the same image --
or the same disc, rather.
You can see the features here.
The only difference is
before and after cleaning.
So this tells us that our
cleaning is doing well.
If you want to know more
about our cleaning process,
I've got a URL here
but you can just go
to our website and
it's easier to find.
And finally, like I said earlier,
we have added side lighting
to our process for discs
without a good groove bottom.
When we originally invented this --
or designed this rig to
hold the light in its place
to illuminate the side of the groove
wall, we had overloaded the motor
and it left us with an
image that was out of focus
when the camera had to move quickly.
We figured out that we could get rid
of some other weight in the system
and found immediately that
that helped our focus problems.
And I think finally, we can see
in our data before we analyze it
if there are bugs in the system, and
don't waste time analyzing the data.
So when I see these glitches on the
right side, and the detailed view,
I know that I have to fix something
before I try to keep analyzing.
So thank you.
If you have any questions,
I'll be here.
And I'll be here.
[ Applause ]
>> I'm curious as to
[inaudible] with recorded discs,
about percentage request
3D analysis?
Do you have enough data on that?
>> Bill Veillette: Well, the
clients don't -- can you hear me?
It's on? Yeah.
The clients don't actually
request 2D or 3D.
We use the approach that's
the best for that carrier.
So -- but we've had only one client
that we're proposing to use 3D
on for their discs, but it's
a vertically cut disc, too.
So have --
>> Mason Vander Lugt: We do it
sometimes with paper based lacquers,
and we did it once with an
aluminum transcription disc.
But yeah, as Bill said,
we don't let people choose
which process they're going to use,
we just use whatever makes sense.
>> Well, my question really went
to how many people want all the
information that's in a 3D analysis?
Because this morning I
inferred that if you really want
to preserve a document, you want
to preserve all the data you can,
and that made 3D analysis desirable.
But we're talking so your
clients are not cognizant of that.
>> Bill Veillette: Right.
Well, there are image
files for 2D and 3D.
And the 2D image files
are also very interesting
to look at, as we just saw.
We have two different kind
of templates for clients.
We have one for institutions
and one for private clients.
We've had actually quite a large
number of private clients initially
because there was more
publicity through popular media.
But now the mix is shifting
toward institutional.
With the instructional
clients, we, as a default,
give them the image
files, and charge them
for the external hard drive, you
know, that can hold all those files.
With the private clients we don't,
as a default, but we let them know
that we're not giving the image
files, but if they want them,
we could add that to the proposal.
Most private clients don't
care about the image files,
they just want the audio.
But we also have language in our
proposal that tells the institution
to treat those image files as the
master file, and to take care of it.
We also let them know that there
is no software that they can use
to do anything with it, but that
we will make our best efforts
to maintain our software.
And that the ultimate goal is to do
what Carl was talking about earlier,
to have somebody, perhaps
the Library of Congress,
maintain an [inaudible]
version of it.
>> I'm Jim Nye [assumed spelling]
from the University of Chicago,
and it was wonderful to hear
that at NEH international
engagements are taking an important
place in your planning.
I'd like to press that
a little bit further,
particularly because I
think arguably the linkages
that NEH has had with [inaudible]
over the years have been
enormously productive,
and also have extended the
funds that are available
in limited quantity from Congress.
My question is about
what might be involved
to initiate new relationships
with counterpart bodies,
let's say in the developing world?
And I work in South Asia,
so I'm thinking specifically
what would be involved in setting
up a relationship like the
DFG/NEH, but with India?
>> Joshua Sternfeld: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I mean, it's a long and
tenuous process to a kind
of longer term relationship
like the one you're describing.
I don't know the history of the
DFG program and how long it took.
I do know that we are
undergoing some talks,
we're having a Transatlantic,
it's not a conference,
a coordination amongst I
believe 12 funding bodies
from both I think South
American and Europe as well,
it's where you get the
Transatlantic moniker.
And so I don't -- I think
that's in the early stages.
I do know that our
director of the Office
of Digital Humanities actually
went to Korea recently to sort
of probe possibilities of
creating some Asian connections.
I don't think I can speak
much further than that,
it's all sort of -- you
know, we're just sort
of probing possibilities
at this point.
The program that is perhaps
the most international
in its structure is the
Digging into Data program,
which has had two funding
cycles so far.
That's a coordination of, I believe,
eight funding institutions,
some U.S. based.
NEH, [inaudible] NSF, some
of our Canadian counterparts,
some of our UK counterparts,
and so forth.
And, you know, I know for example
Carl, I guess he walked out,
but he was proposing, for
example, a kind of pilot study
of the possibilities in a kind
of digital humanities sense
of what we can do with these
datasets, these large datasets.
That Digging into Data program
is I think a perfect vehicle
to encourage collaborations --
international collaborations
to take these datasets
and to derive new ways
of understanding them
and analyzing them.
>> Joshua Johnston: Well, and
also, if I could just add, I think,
the implication of the
question is that all
of these examples aren't reaching
some areas of the world, I think.
And typically those are initiated
with particular people, you know,
and so if those agencies in
those areas are interested,
there are probably people
that they can contact at NEH
if you want to talk further.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.